IS OUR ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEE HEARING ON EDUCATION
FINANCE TODAY IS AN
INFORMATIONAL HEARING THERE
WILL BE NO VOTES TODAY AND WE
WILL NOT BE TAKING THE ROLE
CORRECT. CORRECT THIS HEARING
IS ON THE HIGHER EDUCATION
PORTION OF THE STATE BUDGET FOR.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
BUDGET. THIS IS OF COURSE THE
FOCUS ON OUR COLLEGES
UNIVERSITIES IN OUR FINANCIAL
AID SYSTEM AND WE KNOW LIKE
MANY THING ELSE IN CALIFORNIA
OUR HIGHER EDUCATION SYSTEM
FACED A MAJOR CHALLENGE AND
STILL FACES MAJOR CHALLENGES
DURING THIS PANDEMIC A STUDENTS
HAVE LOST THEIR JOBS IN INCOME
AND I HAD TO MOVE TO ONLINE.
COURSES AND STRUGGLE WITH
FAMILY AND HEALTH ISSUES-
CAMPUSES AND FACULTY ARE
WORKING IN A NEW COMPLICATED
ENVIRONMENTS- WITH ALL THREE
SYSTEMS FACING LOST REVENUE AND
INCREASED COSTS AND LOTS OF
UNCERTAINTY AND GOING FORWARD-
LAST YEAR'S BUDGET MARK THE
FIRST CUT IN STATE FUNDING. IN
EIGHT YEARS AFTER STRONG GROWTH
IN OUR ECONOMY- WELL TWO ROUNDS
OF FEDERAL FUNDING IS HELPING
IN THE THIRD ROUND MAY BE ON
THE WAY WHAT ELSE IS ONE TIME
FOR ONE TIME PURPOSES AND THAT
DOESN'T ALWAYS NEED TO STUDENTS
AND COLLEGE NEEDS. SUPPORTING
STUDENTS STAYING IN SCHOOL
PARTICULAR THAT COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND GETTING STUDENTS-
BACK WHO HAVE DROPPED OUT AS A
TOP PRIORITY OF OURS WE KNOW
THAT IT'S KIND OF THE HAVES AND
HAVE NOTS IN HIGHER EDUCATION
IT SEEMS THAT WITH COMMUNICABLE
DOESN'T SOME EXTENT CSU. THOSE
STUDENTS ARE DROPPING OUT IN
STUDENTS AT THE UC AND OTHER
PRIVATE COLLEGES ARE ARE
THRIVING IT JUST SHOWS THAT
SOME OF THE STUDENTS HAVE
OTHER. REQUIREMENTS WITH THEIR
FAMILIES AND ECONOMICS AS WELL
SO SUPPORTING THE STUDENTS IS A
IS A TOP PRIORITY OF OURS. AT
TODAY'S HEARING WILL ALLOW THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IN LA- TO
DISCUSS THE GOVERNOR'S MAJOR
PROPOSALS FOR THE SEGMENTS WE
WILL HEAR A SPECIAL
SHARK FROM OUR THREE SEGMENT
LEADERS- PRESIDENT DRAKE FROM
THE UC NICK CHANCELLOR CASTRO
FROM CSU AND WELCOMING BACK THE
LEADER OF OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AT CHANCELLOR OAKLEY
LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING FROM
THEM. AFTER MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC PLEASE NOTE THAT- WE
WILL HAVE PUBLIC COMMENTS AT
THE END OF THE HEARING. IF BY
SOME WE FINISH THIS SECTION
WILL TIME BEFORE FOR. WE WILL
DO A LITTLE BIT OF PUBLIC
COMMENT BETWEEN THAT TIME AND
WE HAVE A SPECIAL. PRESENTATION
AT FOUR O'CLOCK- FINASTERIDE
SOME. SPECIAL INSTRUCTIONS
BEFORE WE BEGIN. THIS IS A- IS
THAT PANDEMIC ESSENTIALLY COVER
NINETEEN PUBLIC HEARING NEW
RULES IN PLACE WE ARE IN OR
FORTY TWO ART FORTY TWO A TWO.
WE HAVE A PHYSICAL DISTANCE
HEARING IN PERSON HERE. EVEN
THOUGH WE'RE A- LARGE AND THAT
TOO FEW TO ACCOMMODATE TO
MEMBERS AND MINIMAL STAFF WE
ARE LIMITED- PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION. DOESN'T LOOKING
THAT'S AN ISSUE TODAY- WE DO
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY FOR PEOPLE
TO PARTICIPATE- ON THE PUBLIC
COMMENT LINE THAT WOULD COME UP
ON THAT THE SCREEN WHEN THAT.
TIME IS APPROPRIATE. BUT AS
WELL JUST- WE WANT TO KNOW THAT
THE NUMBER IS. EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHTY NINE
FIFTY SEVEN. AGAIN THE NUMBER
IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE
TWO EIGHTY NINE FIFTY SEVEN
THAT THE PUBLIC ACCESS CODE. IS
ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR TWO
TWO. ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR
TWO OH TWO. OKAY THAT WAS
ENOUGH FOR OKAY THAT WE WILL
PROCEED WITH OUR- HEARING. WITH
THE L. A. L. DEPARTMENT FINANCE
TO GIVE AN OVERVIEW THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. TWENTY ONE TWENTY
PROPOSALS- DO WE HAVE ANY
INTRODUCTORY COMMENTS RANGING
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS- YES
ASSEMBLY MEMBER S. THANK YOU I
FIRST WANT TO BEGIN BY THANKING
THE CHAIR FOR ORGANIZING THIS
HEARING TODAY FIRST OUT FOR ALL
THE WORK DONE TO PREPARE FOR IT-
ELVES THE CHAIRS IN THE CAN
BEFORE COVERT NINETEEN MANY
STUDENTS WERE ALREADY
STRUGGLING. TO AFFORD THINGS
LIKE HOUSING AND FOOD AND THE
RISING COST OF TUITION STATE
THE PANDEMIC HAS ONLY MADE IT
HARDER FOR STUDENTS TO STAY
AFLOAT. WHEN THE JANUARY BUDGET
PROPOSAL WAS RELEASED AT THE
START OF THIS MONTH I WAS
PLEASED TO SEE THE GOVERNOR AND
HIS ADMINISTRATION PRIORITIZED
FUNDING FOR LEARNING LOSS. FOR
TECHNOLOGY COSTS FOR MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES AND BASIC NEEDS
LIKE FOOD AND HOUSING FOR
STUDENTS. I'M ALSO ENCOURAGED
BY THE GOVERNOR'S COMMITMENT TO
REQUIRING OUR LOCAL EDUCATION
AGENCIES TO CONFIRM THAT ALL
HIGH SCHOOL SENIORS COMPLETE
THE FAST FOR OR DREAM ACT
APPLICATIONS. IN THE UPCOMING
SCHOOL YEAR. IN THE CURRENT
STATE OF ECONOMIC UNCERTAINTY
WE NEED TO DO ALL THAT WE CAN'T
TO CONNECT OUR PELL GRANT
ELIGIBLE STUDENTS TO THE
FINANCIAL AID THAT IS AVAILABLE
TO THEM. EVERY STUDENT
REGARDLESS OF BACKGROUND OR
CITIZENSHIP STATUS DESERVES
EQUAL OPPORTUNITY TO ACCESS
HIGHER EDUCATION. AS WE LOOK
AHEAD OF. TO THIS NEW YEAR OUR
SCHOOLS AND STUDENTS FACE A
GREAT DEAL OF UNCERTAINTY I
LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING FROM
OUR FIRST PANEL ABOUT HOW THE
PROPOSED CUTS AND DEFERRALS IN
STATE FUNDING. WILL AFFECT OUR
UC'S USE AND OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND HOW FEDERAL
FUNDING MAY SERVE TO MITIGATE
THE IMPACT OF THESE CUTS. I
ALSO LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING
FROM PRESIDENT DRAKE.
CHANCELLOR COST THROUGH. AND
CHANCELLOR OAKLEY ABOUT
STUDENTS NEEDS ON CAMPUS AND
HOW. UNIVERSITIES PLAN TO USE
FUNDING TO ADDRESS A PERSISTENT
EQUITY GAPS THAT EXIST IN OUR
HIGHER EDUCATION SYSTEM. WANT
TO THANK ALL OF OUR PANELISTS
FOR BEING HERE TODAY AND FOR
THE DEDICATION TO SERVING OUR
STATE'S UNIVERSITIES AND
STUDENTS IN THESE CHALLENGING
TIMES. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
OKAY THANK YOU. SAY NO OTHER
COMMENTS WE WILL PROCEED NOW
WITH THE HEARING. WE HAVE A
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. WITH
THIS. YES GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
NUMBER DANTAN ARE WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- I'M
GOING TO BEGIN WITH THE HIGH
LEVEL OVERVIEW OF THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FOR HIGHER
EDUCATION. AS WELL AS SOME OF
THE MAJOR SPENDING PROPOSALS
FOR THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND
THEN HANDED OFF TO MY COLLEAGUE
JENNIFER THAT WE WOULD HAVE GOT
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSALS
FOR THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA AND CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY. THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET IS FIRST AND FOREMOST A
STUDENT FOCUSED BUDGET. THE
ADMINISTRATION RECOGNIZES THE
CHALLENGES FACED BY OUR STATE.
POST SECONDARY STUDENTS AS A
RESULT OF THE COMPANY EIGHTEEN
PANDEMIC AND DOING RECESSION.
THESE CHALLENGES HAVE LED TO AN
ESTIMATED 8% DECLINE IN
COMMUNITY COLLEGE ENROLLMENT
FROM PAUL TWENTY NINETEEN. BALL
TWENTY TWENTY IN PRELIMINARY
YEAR OVER YEAR DECLINE OF 10%
FOR FASTER COMPLETION FOR A
FIRST IMPRESSION. TO ADDRESS
THIS THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSES INVESTMENT FOR THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. CSU AND UC.
ENABLING THEM TO CLOSE EQUITY
GAPS- COMPLETION. HE'LL
INNOVATION AND THE COURTS
DIDN'T UPWARD ECONOMIC MOBILITY.
THESE RESOURCES WILL ALSO ALLOW
THE SEGMENTS TO BETTER POSITION
THEMSELVES AND ADDRESSING THE
VERY NEEDS OF THEIR STUDENTS.
AS A CONDITION OF RECEIVING THE
CALL UP FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGES
AND BATES AUGMENTATIONS FOR THE
UC AND CSU. THERE ARE SEVERAL
EXPECTATIONS PUT FORWARD BY THE
ADMINISTRATION. THE FIRST IS
THAT EACH OF THE SEGMENT FOCUS
ON EFFORT THE DIGNITY CAN
REDUCE AND EVENTUALLY CLOSE
EXISTING EQUITY THAT. SECOND
THE SEGMENTS WILL ALSO BE
EXPECTED TO ADOPT POLICIES THAT
WILL INCREASE THE AMOUNT OF
ONLINE COURSES PROVIDED BY TEN
PERCENTAGE POINTS. ABOVE THEIR
TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN LEVEL
WITH THE GOAL OF ALLOWING
STUDENTS GREATER FLEXIBILITY IN
ACCESSING EDUCATION. ONE DEPEND
ON THE CUT SIDE. THIRD
REQUESTING THE SEGMENTS BETTER
CONNECT STUDENT LEARNING
OBJECTIVES WITH WORKFORCE IN
AND DISTRIBUTED. FURTHER THIRTY
IF YOU AND YOUR TEAM ARE
EXPECTED TO CREATE A TOWARD
MISSION PATHWAY ALLOWING FOR
STUDENTS TO BE GUARANTEED
ADMISSION UPON COMPLETION OF
LOWER DIVISION COURSES. AT A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE. WHAT A
VEHICLE THE EXPANDED UPON IN MY
COLLEAGUES COME. IN ADDITION TO
THE INTERSEGMENT TO
EXPECTATIONS THEIR INTERSTATE
MENTAL INVESTMENTS THAT CAN BE
SEEN ACROSS EACH OF THE THREE
SEGMENTS. AS THE ADMINISTRATION
RECOGNIZES THAT THEY FACE
SIMILAR CHALLENGES IN
RESPONDING TO A MOVING BEYOND
THE CALL THE NINETEEN PANDEMIC.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET CONTAINS
NEW FUNDING FOR STUDENT BASIC
NEEDS INCLUDING THOSE RELATED
TO MENTAL HEALTH AND DIGITAL
EQUITY. NUMBER TWENTY FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE GRANTS TO STUDENTS.
AND CULTURALLY COMPETENT
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT FOR
FACULTY TO LEVERAGE TECHNOLOGY.
I'D ALSO LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT THAT
FOR OF THE PROPOSED INCLUDED
FOR HIGHER EDUCATION ARE PART
OF THE EARLY ACTION PACKAGE
DESIGNED TO HELP ADDRESS THE
IMMEDIATE NEEDS OF CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS. AND COLLEGES. WITH
THAT I'LL TURN TO SOME OF THE
SPECIFIC PROPOSALS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
LOOKING AT THE BIG PICTURE THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET BUT THIS TEN
POINT FOUR BILLION IN LOCAL
ASSISTANCE FUNDING FOR THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND ADULT
EDUCATION. INTRANSITIVE FOR ALL
OF YOU MAY KNOW THE TWENTY
TWENTY BUDGET ACTIVE BURKE ONE
POINT FOUR FIVE THREE BILLION
IN TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE
APPORTIONMENT. GIVEN EXPECTED
INCREASES IN PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSES TO REDUCE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO TO FOR
ALL. THE THREE HUNDRED TWENTY
SIX POINT FIVE MILLION
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND PORTION.
ADDITIONALLY THIS BUDGET
PROPOSES TO REPAY THE TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TO FOR ALL OF
ONE POINT FOUR FIVE THREE
BILLION. HEATING SOURCES FROM
MULTIPLE FISCAL YEAR. INCLUDING
A HUNDRED AND FORTY FOUR POINT
SIX MILLION. THE CLEAR TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY. NINE HUNDRED
POINT EIGHT MILLION FROM FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
AND FOUR HUNDRED AND SEVEN
POINT NINE MILLION FROM. FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO. THANK BUDGET ALSO THE COST
OF LIVING IT. OF ONE FIVE.
TOTALING A HUNDRED ELEVEN POINT
ONE BLLION. IN FUNDING POINT
FIVE. IN LAWMAKER. TOTALING
TWENTY THREE POINT ONE BILLION.
AS A EARLIER THERE CAN UPON
RECEIVING A COCA. FOR EACH
COMMUNITY TO SHOP SERB DUE TO
SPECIFIC PLAN. ON HOW THEY PLAN
TO CALL ACHIEVEMENT GAPS BY
TWENTY SEVEN. CONSISTENT WITH A
OF OUTLINED IN A CHRIS. SECOND
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES INCLUDE
POLICIES TO MAIN ONLINE. AT A
LEVEL THAT THE TEMPERATURE
POINT THAN EIGHT NINETEEN. IN
THE PUBLIC NINETY EIGHT
GUARANTEE THE BUDGET INCLUDES
BASS TO HELP OF THE ISSUES BY
COCA NINETEEN. THIS BUDGET IS
DESIGNED TO HELP ADDRESS THE
NEEDS OF STUDENTS DURING THIS
DIFFICULT TIME AND TO THAT END
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES
SIGNIFICANT FUNDS TO HELP
ADDRESS STUDENTS. ABILITY TO
ATTEND COLLEGE. THE DIRECTLY TO
BUDGET INCLUDES TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION AMERICANS YOU
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE GRANTS FOR
STUDENTS. OF WHICH ONE HUNDRED
NINETY INCLUDING EARLY ACTION
PACKAGE. IN ONE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY MILLION. OF WHICH THIRTY
ITS ONGOING FIRST- TO ADDRESS
THE BASIC NEEDS. THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET ALSO PROVIDES SUPPORT TO
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES. AND THE
FUNDING TO DECLINING ENROLLMENT
AND HEADING TOWARDS ONLINE
EDUCATION AND TECHNOLOGY BASED
SOLUTIONS. TO ENSURE THAT THEY
ARE ABLE TO BEST MEET THE NEEDS
OF THEIR STUDENTS. THE BUDGET
PROPOSES TWENTY MILLION ONE
TIME FOR OUTREACH TO INCREASE
STUDENT RETENTION INVOLVEMENT
RIGHT- WHICH IS ALSO INCLUDED
IN THE EARLY ACTION PACKAGE.
TWENTY MILLION ONE TIME FOR
CULTURALLY COMPETENT
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT FOR
FACULTY THAT LEVERAGES MODERN
TECHNOLOGY. TEN POINT SIX
MILLION TO SUPPORT THE
CONTINUITY OF EDUCATION AND
QUALITY DISTANCE LEARNING.
INCLUDING ACCESS TO ONLINE
TUTORING. ONLINE COUNSELING AND
ONLY DIDN'T SUPPORT SERVICES
SUCH AS MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES.
EIGHT MILLION TO ADDRESS OUR
EIGHT MILLION ONGOING TO
ADDRESS ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS
INCREASES ASSOCIATED BUT THE
CALIFORNIA FOR THE CORPORATION
FOR EDUCATION NETWORK
INITIATIVES IN CALIFORNIA OFTEN
AND CHECK THE OFFICE ALSO
CONTINUES ITS COMMITMENT TO
WORK BASED LEARNING HELPING
STUDENTS GAIN EMPLOYMENT AFTER
FINISHING THEIR PROGRAM. THIS
COMMITMENT HAS BECOME EVEN MORE
IMPERATIVE I THINK OF THE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC WHICH
AFFECTED EVERY SECTOR OF THE
STATE'S ECONOMY AND BECAUSE
RECORD HIGH UNEMPLOYMENT. TO
THAT END THE BUDGET INCLUDES
THIRTY FIVE MILLION FOR WORK
BASED LEARNING PROGRAM. OF
WHICH FIFTEEN MILLION IS
ONGOING TO AUGMENT THE
CALIFORNIA APPRENTICESHIP
INITIATIVE. THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET ALSO INCLUDES A NUMBER
OF ADDITIONAL PROPOSALS TO
ADDRESS STUDENT CALL. AND
SUPPORT STUDENT SUCCESS IN
HIGHER EDUCATION OPPORTUNITY
INCLUDING FIFTEEN MILLION ONE
IN ONE TIME FUNDING. THE
DEVELOPMENT OF YOUR TEXTBOOK
COST AGREED I WHICH IS AFTER
BUT- BY THE FUNDING IN THE
TWENTY SIXTEEN BUDGET ACT. TWO
POINT FIVE MILLION ONE TIME FOR
INSTRUCTIONAL MATERIALS FOR
DOING ALL THE STATE. SIX
HUNDRED THOUSAND ONE TIME TO
IMPLEMENT AB FOURTEEN SIXTY
THAT'S WHAT SYSTEM WHITE ANTI
RACISM INITIATIVES. WITH THAT
I'LL TURN IT OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE JENNIFER. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
GENERALLY WITH ON BEHALF OF
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. TO
CONTINUE HIGHLIGHTING THE
MINISTRATIONS EMPHASIS ON
ACCESS EQUITY AND BUDGET
RESILIENCY I WILL CONTINUE OUR
OUTLINED OUR PROPOSALS FOR THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AND
THE CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY.
FOR USE TNCS TO THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSES SUBSTANTIAL
ONGOING AND ONE TIME
AUGMENTATIONS IT MEANS THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSES WITH
THE FOLLOWING EXPECTATIONS. WE
EXPECT THE CSU AND UC FIRST TO
MAINTAIN IT RESIDENT
UNDERGRADUATE TUITION AND FEES
AT CURRENT LEVELS FOR THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
ACADEMIC YEAR. SECOND PREPARE A
REPORT IDENTIFYING ACTIONABLE
WAYS OF SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCING
EQUITY GAPS WITH THE GOAL FULLY
CLOSING EQUITY GAPS BY TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE. THIRD ADOPT
POLICIES THAT CAMPUS IS A STAND
THEIR ONLINE LEARNING PROGRAMS
AT10% PRIEGO COBIT LEVELS FOR
BETTER LINE STUDENT LEARNING
OBJECTIVES WITH WORKFORCE NEEDS
AND FINALLY ESTABLISH A NEW
STANDALONE TOOL EMISSIONS
PATHWAY ENABLING FIRST TIME
FRESHMEN TO APPLY FOR
GUARANTEED ADMISSION TO UC AND
CSU. UPON COMPLETION OF LOWER
DIVISION REQUIREMENTS AT A
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
SEVERAL OF OUR PROPOSED GENERAL
FUND AUGMENTATIONS DO APPLY TO
BOTH UC AND CSU THESE INCLUDE
83% AS AUGMENTATIONS FOR
OPERATING COSTS WITH THE
EXPECTATIONS MY COLLEAGUES HAS
PREVIOUSLY STATED FOR YOU SEE
THE PROPOSED BASE AUGMENTATION
IS. HOVERING THREE POINT NINE
MILLION ONGOING INCLUDING A
BASE INCREASE FOR THE UC OFFICE
OF THE PRESIDENT. FOR THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
IT'S HUNDRED LEVIN POINT FIVE
MILLION ONGOING SECOND THE
ONGOING INVESTMENT IN STUDENT
BASIC NEEDS FIFTEEN MILLION FOR
YOU SEE TO FOCUS ON STERN
STUDENT TECHNOLOGY AND MENTAL
HEALTH. NEEDS AND THIRTY
MILLION FOR CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY FIFTEEN MILLION OF
WHICH IS TOWARDS BASIC NEEDS
COMPONENT OF THAT GRADUATION
INITIATIVE TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
AND FIFTEEN MILLION FOR STUDENT
TECHNOLOGY AND MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES. IN ADDITION ONGOING
INVESTMENT FOR COMMON IN OUR
SEGMENTAL LEARNING MANAGEMENT
SYSTEM ONE MILLION FOR THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AND
TWO MILLION FOR CSU. FOURTH THE
ONE TIME INVESTMENT IN DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE. HUNDRED SEVENTY
FIVE MILLION FOR THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA. AT FOR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE AND ENERGY
EFFICIENCY PROJECTS AND A
HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
FOR CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE. IN
ADDITION ANOTHER ONE TIME
INVESTMENT AND EMERGENCY
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE FOR
STUDENTS FIFTEEN MILLION FOR
YOU SEE AND THIRTY MILLION FOR
CSU. AT ONE TIME INVESTMENT AND
CULTURALLY COMPETENT
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT FOR
IMPROVING ON MY EDUCATION AND
THE USE OF TECHNOLOGY FIVE
MILLION FOR THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA AND TEN MILLION FOR
THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY. OF FAMILY ALSO NOTE
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSES
TO PUSH BACK THE SUSPENSION
DATE FOR SUMMER FINANCIAL AID.
SO THAT BOTH UC AND CSU WILL
CONTINUE RECEIVING FOUR MILLION
AND SIX MILLION RESPECTIVELY
AND TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO. IN ADDITION TO THESE
INVESTMENTS CHAIRED BY ACROSS
BOTH SEGMENTS THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSES SEVERAL GENERAL
FUND INVESTMENTS ARE SPECIFIC
TO THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA. AND THESE INCLUDE
TWELVE POINT NINE MILLION ON
GOING TO EXPAND EXISTING YOU
SEE PRIME PROGRAMS AND CREATE A
NEW PRIME KERR PROGRAM FOCUSED
ON NATIVE AMERICAN COMMUNITIES.
TWENTY MILLION ONE TIME TO
SUPPORT UC'S CALIFORNIA
INSTITUTE FOR SCIENCE AND
INNOVATION TO CONNECT STUDENT
WORKERS TO INDUSTRY EMPLOYERS
AND FOR RESEARCH TEAMS TO
REFORM INDUSTRY PARTNERSHIPS.
SEVEN MILLION ONE TIME SUPPORT
FOR K. TWELVE TEACHER TRAINING
VIA THE UC SUBJECT MATTER
PROJECTS FIVE MILLION OF WHICH
FOR DRESSING K. TWELVE LEARNING
LOSS AND TWO MILLION FOR K.
TWELVE ETHNIC STUDIES. IN
ADDITION TO MILLION ONE TIME
FOR YOU SEE FIRED VISORS AS
PART OF THE ADMINISTRATION'S
OVERALL WILDFIRE AND FOREST
RESILIENCE PACKAGE. AND FINALLY
ONE POINT THREE MILLION TO
SUPPORT A CONSORTIUM BETWEEN
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC PUBLIC
HEALTH FOCUSED ON HEALTH
MODELING AND DATA ANALYTICS.
FINALLY THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
INCLUDES THE FOLLOWING CSU
SPECIFIC AUGMENTATIONS ONE
MILLION ON GOING TO SUPPORT
ADDITIONAL S. T. E. AT THE CSU
STANISLAUS STACKS STOCKTON
CAMPUS. AND SECOND TEN MILLION
ONE TIME FOR THE COMPUTING
TALENT INITIATIVE ADMINISTERED
THROUGH THE CSU MONTEREY BAY.
THESE FUNDS WOULD EXPAND THE
PROGRAM TO INCREASE ACCESS TO
HIGH NEED REGIONS OF THE STATE.
ALTHOUGH TODAY'S HEARING IS
FOCUSED ON INVESTMENTS IN THE
C. U. C. C. IT SEEMS TO ME
COLLEGES THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSES SEVERAL- FINANCIAL AID
INVESTMENTS. THE PROVIDE
STUDENTS SUPPORT FOR STUDENTS
ATTENDING THESE INSTITUTIONS
WITH THAT I WILL CONCLUDE MY
PRESENTATION MY COLLEAGUES AND
I ARE AVAILABLE IF YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOU. OKAY THANK
YOU I NOW WE HAVE THE L. A. O.
TO JOIN US AS WELL. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON SHARON MEMBERS
JENNIFER PATEL LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE YOU SHOULD
HAVE A HAND OUT AND ALLOW HIM
TO ENTITLED OVERVIEW OF THE
HIGHER EDUCATION BUDGET WE ALSO
HAVE THE HANDOUT POSTED ON OUR
WEBSITE THE HANDOUT IS INTENDED
PRIMARILY AS A REFERENCE
DOCUMENT FOR YOU AS YOU WORK
YOUR WAY THROUGH THE PROPOSAL'S
BOTH THIS BOTH TODAY AND IN THE
COMING HEARINGS FOR THE SAKE OF
THIS AFTERNOON FOR THE SAKE OF
TIME WILL COVER THE MATERIAL
QUICKLY PROVIDE SOME BASIC.
CONTEXT AND SOME KEY TAKEAWAYS.
FOR SOME CONTEXT AS PART OF THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE STATE BUDGET
PACKAGE THE TERROR NOTED THAT
SINCE THE BEGINNING NONE OF THE
THREE PUBLIC HIGHER EDUCATION
SEGMENTS RECEIVED BASE INCREASE
SAYS. THAT MANY COLLEGES DIDN'T
RECEIVE A BASE CUT BUT THEY DID
HAVE LARGE PAYMENT DEFERRALS
AND THEN THE UNIVERSITY IS AS
YOU KNOW RECEIVE THE GENERAL
FUND REDUCTIONS. IN ADDITION TO
THE STATE PAYMENT DEFERRALS IN
THE GENERAL FUND REDUCTIONS THE
STATEMENTS HAVE EXPERIENCED
OTHER ADVERE PHYSICAL EFFECTS
FROM THE PANDEMIC. SO WE KNOW
THAT THE SEGMENTS HAVE HAD
DECLINES IN REVENUE FROM THEIR
NON CORE PROGRAMS HOUSING
DINING PARKING MEDICAL CENTERS
AND SCHOOLS. THEY'VE ALSO SEEN
A DROP IN THEIR NON RESIDENT
INVOLVEMENT. AND THEN I HAD
TAKEN ASSOCIATED- DECLINE IN
NON RESIDENT TUITION. IN
ADDITION TO THE DROPS IN CORE
AND NON CORE FUNDING I CAMPUS
IS OFFICE ALSO HAVE HAD SOME
EXTRAORDINARY COST- FOR EXAMPLE
THEY'VE HAD HIGHER THAN NORMAL
TECHNOLOGY COSTS. SO YOU KNOW
THAT FEDERAL THE FUNDING-
CAMPUSES HAVE RECEIVED THEY'VE
RECEIVED A FIRST ROUND AND
SPRING OF TWENTY TWENTY AND THE
SECOND ROUND IS X. AND EXPECTED
THIS WINTER. THE SECOND ROUND
WAS LARGER THAN THE FIRST ROUND
SO CALIFORNIA'S ESTIMATED TO
RECEIVE AT LEAST TWO POINT NINE
BILLION FROM THE SECOND ROUND
ONE POINT NINE BILLION FROM THE
FIRST ROUND. AND THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS CONSIDERING A
THIRD ROUNDER THEY'RE IN THE
MIDST OF THAT NOW WHAT THEY'RE
CONTEMPLATING AS A STARTING
POINT EVEN LARGER THAN THE
FIRST TWO ROUNDS I'M ALMOST
COMBINED SO IF CALIFORNIA WERE
TO RECEIVE THE SAME PROPORTION.
OF THAT THIRD ROUND THAT
THEY'RE CONTEMPLATING RIGHT NOW
IT WOULD BE- GETTING
APPROXIMATELY FOUR AND A HALF
BILLION- BUT THAT AGAIN IS JUST
A POTENTIAL FUNDING TO CALM.
EVEN WITH THE FEDERALLY FUNDED
CAMPUSES HAVE BEEN IMPLEMENTING
COST CONTAINMENT MEASURES IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE FOR EXAMPLE
MOST CAMPUSES ARE HOLDING THEIR
VACANT POSITIONS OPEN. EVEN
WITH THE COST CONTAINMENT
MEASURES WE KNOW THAT THE
UNIVERSITIES ARE PROJECTING
OPERATING DEFICITS FOR TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. THE ISSUE IS
PROJECTING AN OPERATING DEFICIT
OF ROUGHLY TWO HUNDRED MILLION
ON THE CORE OPERATING PART OF
THEIR BUDGET. AND YOU SEE I'M A
DEFICIT OF- AT LEAST A HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY FOUR MILLION.
SHIFTING FROM ALL OF THIS
BACKDROP AS JUST WHERE THEY ARE
NOW- TO WHAT THE GOVERNOR HAS
PROPOSED FOR THEM YOU'VE
ALREADY HEARD OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSALS ALL JUST JUMP RIGHT
INTO SOME ISSUES THAT YOU MIGHT
WANT TO CONSIDER IN THE WEEKS
AHEAD. SO AS YOU THINK ABOUT
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BASED
INCREASE SAYS WE WOULD SUGGEST
YOU THINK OF THOSE AS A
STARTING POINT. SO AT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED LEVELS THE
SEGMENTS WOULD HAVE ENOUGH TO
COVER HEALTH CARE. AND PENSION
COST INCREASES IT HAVE SOME
LEFT OVER THAT THEY CAN THINK
ABOUT FOR MODEST SALARY
INCREASES OR STAFFING
RESTORATIONS. I THINK YOU
PROBABLY WANT TO WAIT UNTIL MAY
BEFORE YOU DECIDE EXACTLY ON
THE LEVEL OF BASED INCREASES AT
THAT TIME YOU'LL HAVE A MUCH
BETTER IDEA OF THE STATE'S OUT
YOUR OPERATING DEFICITS AT
LEAST A SOMEWHAT BETTER IDEA.
AND THAT COULD HELP YOU
DETERMINE HOW COMFORTABLE YOU
ARE WITH EITHER THE 3% AND A
HALF PERCENT FOR THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES SOMEWHERE HIGHER OF
LOWER. REGARDING THE
EXPECTATIONS THAT RELATE TO
STUDENT EQUITY ONLINE LEARNING
IN THE TRANSFER PROCESS WE
THINK THE GOVERNOR HAS
IDENTIFIED AREAS OF COMMON
INTEREST WITH THE LEGISLATURE
LEGISLATURE HAS BEEN TALKING
ABOUT THESE ISSUES FOR MANY
YEARS. BUT IT'S ON THE
PROPOSALS WE THINK COULD BE
IMPROVED- PRESUMABLY IF
INTERESTED YOU AND STAFF COULD
BE WORKING OVER THE NEXT COUPLE
OF MONTHS WORK FOR ALL THE
DETAILS ASSOCIATED WITH THE
PROPOSALS AND WE HAVE SOME
IDEAS. FOR YOU TO CONSIDER ON
HOW TO IMPROVE THEM. THE
GOVERNOR AS YOU KNOW HAS THIS
PACKAGE OF STUDENT SUPPORT
PROPOSALS STUDENT BASIC NEEDS
EMERGENCY GRANTS STUDENT MENTAL
HEALTH TECHNOLOGY ISSUES. IN
THESE CASES WE THINK THAT AGAIN
THE GOVERNOR HAS IDENTIFIED
ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN IMPOSED
BUT NOT ONLY LONG STANDING BUT
EXACERBATED BY THE PANDEMIC-
BUT IF YOU DO DECIDE TO PUT
MORE ONGOING MONEY INTO THESE
PROGRAMS WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU TO
STEP BACK FOR A MOMENT MAKE
SURE THAT THE PROGRAM'S
OBJECTIVES ARE CLEAR. THAT YOU
HAVE A WAY TO MEASURE THEM AND
THAT YOU'RE AND YOUR AND I MEAN
I'M PLACE TOOLS TO ASSESS
WHETHER THOSE PROGRAMS ARE
ACHIEVING THEIR OBJECTIVES. I
WOULD ALSO ENCOURAGE YOU TO
THINK ABOUT ALIGNING THE STATE
FUNDS WITH THE FEDERAL FUNDS
THAT YOU KNOW NOW I'M DOWN DO
EXIST FOR THE SECOND ROUND OF
RELIEF- NEED FOR EXAMPLE YOU
COULD USE THE STATE FUNDS TO-
GIVE GRANTS TO STUDENTS WHO
MIGHT BE POTENTIALLY INELIGIBLE
FOR THE FEDERAL FUNDS. OR YOU
COULD USE THE STATE FUNDS ONCE
THE FEDERAL FUNDS HAVE DRIED
DRIED UP. LONGER TERM WE THINK
YOU MIGHT WANT TO CONSIDER
HAVING A MORE HOLISTIC APPROACH
FOR HOW THE STATE IS DEALING
WITH STUDENT BASIC NEEDS.
APPROACH TO DATE HAS BEEN
SOMEWHAT PEACE NOW. THE LAST
WEEK AS THE STATE'S ON IF IT IF
THE STATE'S FISCAL OUTLOOK WORD
TO IMPROVE COME MAY WE THINK
YOU COULD CONSIDER PAYING DOWN
MORE DEFERRALS THAT WOULD BE ON
THE NINETY EIGHT SIDE OF YOUR
BUDGET. YOU COULD ALSO COME IN-
CONSIDER PROVIDING MORE FOR
UNIVERSITY DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
THAT WOULD BE ON THE NINE
NINETY EIGHT SIDE OF YOUR
BUDGET. BUT BOTH ACTIONS WOULD
HELP IMPROVE BOTH THE STATE AND
THE STATEMENTS BUDGET
RESILIENCY. SO FOR THE SECOND
TIME I REMAIN VERY HIGH LEVEL I
HAVE- SKIPPED OVER ISSUES LIKE
ENROLLMENT TUITION FINANCIAL
AID SUPPLEMENTAL CAME PENSION
PAYMENTS. BUT I'D BE HAPPY TO
TALK IN MORE DETAIL OR ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE
AND THOSE ARE OTHER AREAS. OKAY
THANK YOU I'LL HAVE A NUMBER OF
QUESTIONS BUT WHEN WE FIRST
OPENED UP TO- COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
TO ENGAGE WITH. MISTER LAKE MR
LEADER MR O'DONNELL. THANK YOU
I APPRECIATE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S CONCERN AND
PRIORITY ABOUT STUDENT BASIC
NEEDS SO JUST WONDERING CAN THE
DEFENSE D. O. F. PLEASE PROVIDE
SOME BACKGROUND IN REGARDS TO
WIDE ADMINISTRATION DECIDED TO
PROPOSE A ONE TIME FUNDING FOR
STUDENT BASIC NEEDS AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AS OPPOSED
TO ONGOING FUNDS FOR STUDENT
BASIC NEEDS LIKE IN THE UC'S
ARE CSU. HELLO I GENERALLY
WOULD DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE M.
I. A. WILL. RESPOND WITH-
SPECIFICALLY ON THE UC'S NCS
USER- AUGMENTATION AND TOUCH ON
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND IF
YOU HAVE FURTHER QUESTIONS MY A
COLLEAGUE- DAN HAD OUR WELL
WITH THE TO ME COLLEGES COULD.
SPECIFY IF YOU HAVE ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS- FOR BASIC NEEDS- THE
ADMINISTRATION- IS FOCUSED ON
PRESERVING AT EQUITY AND I'M
PERSON INCREASING EQUITY AND-
PROPOSING THE ALL FOR ALL THREE
SEGMENTS FOR FIFTEEN MILLION
FOR YOU SEE- ONGOING- FOR
MENTAL HEALTH AND INTERNET
TECHNOLOGY ACCESS. AS WELL AS
ON TOP OF THE- FIFTEEN MILLION
THAT'S EXISTING FOR THE UC'S
FOR TOTAL THIRTY MILLION AND
THIRTY MILLION FOR S. YES YOU
BREAKING BASIC NEEDS. AND AT
THIS TIME- WITHIN THE CURRENT
ALLOTMENT FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THERE'S A
THIRTY MILLION ONGOING POP
NINETY EIGHT FOR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND JUST PART MENTAL
HEALTH AND INTERNET TECHNOLOGY
ACCESS AND THE MINISTRATION-
CONSIDERS A BOTH- AS NECESSARY.
COMPONENTS TOWARD BASIC NEEDS.
THANK AND I CAN ACTUALLY. DIED
I CAN'T BE BOTHERED TO YET JUST
CELEBRATE ON MY COLLEGE POINTS
THAT THERE IS- THIRTY MILLION
ONGOING INCLUDED IN THE OVERALL
ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTY MILLION
FOR BASIC NEEDS AFTER THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND THAT
HAVE DIRECTLY TIED TO THE
DIGITAL EQUIPMENT DID NOT TO
HELP THEM- BUT BY GOLLY TWENTY
NOT YET ABOUT BETWEEN A HUNDRED
THIRTY MILLION IT IS JUST.
ABOUT THE OF WHAT HAPPENED ON
GOING TO SEARCHES. WITHIN THE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GUARANTEE. OKAY THANK YOU I
DON'T EVEN KNOW TO HAVE THE
METRICS AND UNDERSTAND THAT THE
PROGRAMS ARE WORKING AT THE
CAMPUS IS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
SO. THEY BRING IT UP THANK YOU
FOR IT ANSWER. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER A DONALD. YES
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I
QUESTION WAS JUST ABOUT THE A
PROPOSAL WITH REGARD TO THE
FAST FUN- YOU KNOW A LOT OF
PEOPLE SAY WE WANT EVERY
STUDENT TO FILL THAT OUT BUT
ACTUALLY WE DON'T BECAUSE WE
ARE UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS AND-
I'M ONE WHO IS IMPLEMENTED. YOU
KNOW THE- YOU HAD STUDENTS FALL
THE PASSWORD IN THIS CLASS ARE
MANY TIMES. AND IT IS OFTEN
THAT DAIS SOME STUDENTS FIND
OUT THAT THEY ARE UNDOCUMENTED.
SO WHAT BORDERS ARE THERE
AROUND THIS POLICY THAT SOON SO
THAT STUDENTS DON'T WALK INTO A
LEGAL TRAP. BECAUSE IF THEY DO
SUBMIT THAT FAST FOR- THAT
COULD LEAD TO AUTOMATE COULD
LEAD TO SOME CRIMINAL
PROCEEDING SO COULD YOU. DETAIL.
PROBABLY DEPARTMENT FINANCE. HI
BRIANNA FRIENDS DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE YES OF THE FACTS THE
PROPOSAL- LANGUAGE ACTUALLY
BILL LANGUAGE ON THAT PROPOSAL
SHOULD BE COMING OUT LATER
TODAY- BUT I WOULD NOTE THAT
THE PROPOSAL IS TO AND HIGHER
SCHOOLS TO ENSURE THAT A
STUDENT HAS EITHER FILLED OUT
THERE FAST ENOUGH OR THEY'RE
KEY TO APPLICATION SO IT SO IT
TO INCLUDE- UNDOCUMENTED
STUDENTS YOU'RE NOT REQUIRED.
YOU JUST ENCOURAGING STUDENTS
TO DO THAT IS THAT ACCURATE.
THAT'S CORRECT THE SCHOOL WILL
BE REQUIRED TO ENJOY THE STATE
HAS NOT EITHER QUORUM OR THAT
STUDENT HAS OPTED OUT SO THERE
IS AN OPT OUT PROVISION BE INTO
LANGUAGE OKAY THE OPT OUT THE
OPT OUT PROVISION IS. VERY
IMPORTANT PROGRAM OF REASONS
NOT JUST FOR THIS TO ORINDA-
THE FAN MAY NOT WANT. THEIR
STUDENTS THERE TRY. TO SIGN UP
FOR THE FIRST BUT I THE
BEGINNING REALLY SENSE TO THE
THAT STUDENTS ARE GOING TO
OTHER UNDOCUMENTED. AND THIS
STATE COULD BE SETTING UP A
LEGAL TRAP WE NEED TO BE VERY
COGNISANT OF AND AS ONE WHO'S
YOU KNOW DONE THIS ON THE
GROUND AS MUCH AS TELL TELL YOU
THIS IS A- THIS DYNAMIC ISRAEL
SO WATCH WHAT YOU'RE WALKING
INTO HERE AND MAKE SURE THAT
YOUR POLICY IS FLEXIBLE ENOUGH.
AND STRONG ENOUGH SO THAT THIS
THIS DOESN'T HAPPEN ACROSS OUR
STATE WERE STUDENTS ACTUALLY.
CREADA A SITUATION THAT IS
ADVERSE TO THEIR FUTURE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU FOR MAKING. MR
GALLAGHER A SENIOR NO. OKAY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER REST. IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THERE IS A
PROPOSAL FOR A MUCH LARGER COST
OF LIVING ADJUSTMENT FOR K.
THROUGH TWELVE. ESPECIALLY AS
COMPARED TO COMMUNITY COLLEGES
CAN YOU SHARE WITH US WHY THIS
IS. SURE DENTON AND WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- SO I
THINK. I'M NOT REALLY ABLE TO
SPEAK TO THE SPECIFICS OF THE
COLOR THAT WAS PROVIDED TO K.
TWELVE BUT SPECIFICALLY WITH
RESPECT TO THE- THE CODE OF OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES- THAT I
WOULD BASED ON OUR ESTIMATES
ABOUT. OF ONGOING FUNDING- BUT
BASICALLY WE REALLY WITH THIS
PROJECT WANTED TO FOCUS ON. YOU
KNOW PROVIDING FOR OUR
STUDENTS- EARLY ESTIMATES OF
ENROLLMENT SHOWS THAT IT'S BEEN
DOWN EIGHT PERCENT- AS I
MENTIONED EARLIER AND SO ONE OF
THE REALBIG FOCUSES WITH THIS
BUDGET. WHAT TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL STUDENTS RECORDS
MERGING FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE
GRANT- BASIC NEED FUNDING- THAT
WOULD HELP EARLY ENROLLMENT-
AND YOU KNOW AS AS WE ARE AWARE
DURING THE GREAT RECESSION
THERE WERE SOME STUDENTS WHO UP
TO WHO NEVER CAME BACK IN SO-
ARE PART OF THE TIME AROUND IT
IS TO. MAKE SURE THAT THAT SAME
THING DOESN'T HAPPEN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR ONE. YES SOMEONE
ELSE- THE IMPORTANT BECAUSE
MADE BY MY COLLEAGUE FROM LONG
BEACH. AND HE HAPPENS TO BE ONE
OF THOSE TEACHERS WHO DOES HELP
THEIR STUDENTS. HE HAS. I THINK
WHAT IS IMPORTANT AND I
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S
POSITION ON THIS KNOWING THAT.
THE PERCENTAGE OF STUDENTS WHO
FILL UP FAST WHEN DREAM ACT
APPLICATIONS- WHO WOULD LATER
GO TO COLLEGES SO MUCH GREATER
THAN THOSE WHO DO NOT FILL OUT
THE FORM SO TRYING TO FIND THE
BALANCE OF THE WE NEVER DO
SOMETHING THAT IS GOING TO- IT
DIDN'T CAUSE ANY KIND OF LEGAL
PROBLEMS FOR STUDENTS IS VERY
IMPORTANT- BALANCING THAT WITH
THE- THE STATISTICS THAT SHOW
THE STUDIES THAT SHOW THAT
FILLING OUT THE FAST FOR FORM.
FILLING UP THE DREAM ACT FORM-
IS GOING TO PROVIDE THE BASIS
FOR MOST OF OUR STUDENTS TO GO
TO COLLEGE SO I DO APPRECIATE
THAT THAT'S SOMETHING THAT HAS
TO BE BALANCED AND I APPRECIATE
THAT MY COLLEAGUES COMMENTS ON
THAT. OKAY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BY A
DENTIST. THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER CHAIRMAN FOR YOUR
RECOGNIZING ME I'M- SO IN THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL THERE IS
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR WORK FORCE
DEVELOPMENT PROPOSALS- I DO
WANT TO KNOW ONE MORE DETAILS
WILL BE AVAILABLE BUT-
PARTICULARLY CANNOT FUNDING BE
USED FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGES
FOR. INSTRUCTIONAL SERVICE
AGREEMENTS AS IT PERTAINS TO
PUBLIC SAFETY TRAINING- IN MY
DISTRICT THAT THE LOCAL
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CALL TO THE
CANYONS THAT I WENT TO THEY
OFFER SOME GREAT PUBLIC AFETY
TRAINING PROGRAMS AND AS WE
LOOK AT- THE BREAK DOWN OF WHAT
STUDENTS ACTUALLY GO AND
PARTICIPATE IN THIS PROGRAM.
IT'S A LOT OF LATINO STUDENTS
AND THIS BECAUSE PROGRAMS IN
PARTICULAR- ARE GOOD PAYING JOB
CERTIFICATE PROGRAMS- IT TO BE
A PARAMEDIC A AND M. T. A
FIREFIGHTER OR POLICE OFFICER
AND IF THERE'S ANYTHING THAT
WE'VE NOTICED OVER THIS PAST
YEAR- OUR HUSBAND COME BECOME
HEIGHTENED IS OUR LACK OF
PUBLIC SAFETY PROFESSIONALS
THAT WE SO DESPERATELY NEED.
RIGHT NOW I'M CAN ANY OF THIS
FUNDING BE USED TO AUGMENT THE
REALITY THAT COLLEGE OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS IN
THESE PROGRAMS ARE ONLY REALLY
RECEIVING ABOUT 70% FOR THAT
FOR THOSE PROGRAMS AND ONE WILL
ADDITIONAL DETAILS BE
AVAILABLE- ABOUT THE. TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
FOR WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT. AND
DINNER WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- UNFORTUNATELY WE DON'T
HAVE SPECIFIC I DON'T SPECIFIC
AT THE TIME ABOUT WHEN THOSE
PHOTOS ARE. WILL BE UNVEILED
THE- AND THAT YOU KNOW WE DO
HAVE THAT MONEY SET ASIDE BUT-
DOESN'T FOCUS WILL BE. RELEASED
IN ORDER MORE DETAILS WILL BE
AVAILABLE LATER ON IN THE
BUDGET PROCESS. I'M GONNA THINK
SPECIFICALLY WITH REGARD TO THE
CONCERNS THAT YOU NOTED AND
BROUGHT UP- I THINK I'M I'M
HAPPY TO TAKE THOSE CONCERNS
BACK AND AS WE- DON'T. KNOW FOR
THE BUDGET PROCESS. GREAT THANK
YOU. MR GALLAGHER. YEAH ONE
QUESTION I HAD FOR- DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE- WHEN WILL
ADDITIONAL DETAILS ABOUT THE
PLACE HOLDER TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR WORK FORCE
DEVELOPMENT- BE AVAILABLE. SHE
SAYS THAT. I AGAIN I THINK-
THAT. WE SHOULD HAVE DETAILS ON
THAT LATER ON IN THE BUDGET
PROCESS- HOWEVER I DON'T HAVE
DETAILS AND THE TIMELINE AT
THIS AT THIS POINT. OKAY AND
THEN- ON THE DUAL ADMISSIONS
PATHWAY- CAN YOU SAY AT THIS
POINT WHO WOULD ALL UC CAMPUSES
BE REQUIRED TO PARTICIPATE-
WITH APPLICANTS BE REQUIRED TO
DECLARE A MAJOR. AT THE TIME OF
THE APPLICATION- ARE THE
STUDENTS GUARANTEED THE CAMPUS
OF THEIR CHOICE AT THE TIME
THAT MISSION OR THEY SUBJECT TO
RE DIRECTION I MEAN ANYTHING
LIKE ON THESE POINTS THAT YOU
CAN. PROVIDED THIS POINT. PINE
RIDGE ALLEGED DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. I CAN SPEAK TO THE
DOLE ADMISSIONS PROPOSAL AND
SAY. IN TERMS OF A SPECIFIC
CAMPUS WE DO. IMAGINE THAT YOU
APPLY GOING IN KNOWING THAT A
SPECIFIC CCC AND A SPECIFIC UC
OR CSU IS GOING TO BE YOUR
PATHWAY. SO ESSENTIALLY THAT'S
A LITTLE BIT LIKE TAG NOW FOR
UC CAMPUSES WHERE YOU MAKE A
GREEN MET WITH FOR EXAMPLE UC
SANTA CRUZ AND YOU. KNOW
THROUGH YOUR CCC EXPERIENCE
THAT YOU'RE GOING TO SEND THOSE
THROUGH THIS AGREEMENT THAT'S
THE MODEL OF THE DAHLE MISSIONS
THAT WERE IMAGINING. WE ALSO
IMAGINE THAT EACH UC CAMPUS
UMASS. THE PARTICIPATION AND WE
DO IMAGINE ALL. YOU SEE
CAMPUSES PARTICIPATING- THEY
SHOULD ALL BE PARTICIPATING IN
THAT IS REALLY THE STUDENT WHO
MAKES THAT SORT OF CHOICE.
THAT'S RIGHT YOU WOULDN'T DO SO
WE IMAGINE YOU APPLY. NOT
GENERICALLY TO YOU SEE BUT YOU
YOU APPLY TO THE DAHLE MISSIONS
PROGRAM BY CLICKING THROUGH THE
EMISSIONS AND SPECIFYING IN
THAT PROCESS THIS IS THE CCC I
IMAGINE AND THIS IS THE UC I
IMAGINE. MR SHERIFF I MAY I
HAVE JUST ONE POINT TO ADD TO
THAT AS WELL WE WILL HAVE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE ON
MISSIONS PROPOSAL THAT WILL BE
POSTED TODAY. THAT SHOULD
ANSWER A NUMBER OF THOSE
QUESTIONS IN MORE DETAIL AS
WELL. THANK YOU. MR GALLAGHER
THAT'S ALL OKAY. I HAVE A FEW
QUESTIONS. BEFORE WE GET TO OUR
OUR OTHER PRESENTERS WE HAVE
AGAIN TWENTY MINUTES BEFORE
THEY GET ONLINE- I WANTED TO
FIRST TALK ABOUT THE FINANCIAL
AID ISSUE I AM IN FULL SUPPORT
OF FINDING WAYS TO INCREASE
STUDENTS TO FILL OUT. THE FAFSA
FORM OR I DON'T FORGET THE NAME
OF IT THEIR PURPOSE FORM TO
FILL OUT FOR THE CALIFORNIA
DREAM ACT- STUDENTS- AS REYES
RESEARCH SHOWS THIS IS A GAME
CHANGER FOR TWO REASONS ONE IF
STUENTS DON'T FILL IT OUT AND
THEY GO ON TO COLLEGE AND THEN
THEY TRY TO PLAY FOR THE CAL
GRANT. THEY GO IN THE
COMPETITIVE POT WHERE THE ODDS
OF GETTING A CAL GRANT ARE ONE
AND TWELVE ON IT GET YOUR
WANTED SEVENTEEN FOR SOME OF
THE BAD YEARS SO ESSENTIALLY
IT'S A LOTTERY TYPE THING WHERE
IS IF YOU FILL OUT THAT PASSED
THE FORM WHEN YOU'RE A HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENT IT'S AN
ENTITLEMENT SO IT'S AGAIN IT'S
1100% GUARANTEE. YOU'LL GET
FINANCIAL AID AND SO- SO MANY
STUDENTS DOWN THE ROAD. THAT
YOU ASK THEM WHY DIDN'T YOU.
APPLY EARLIER I DIDN'T KNOW
ABOUT IT MY COUNSELOR WAS BUSY
DEALING WITH. LIFE AND OUR
PUBLIC HIGH SCHOOLS WE KNOW THE
COUNSELOR STUDENT RATIOS
HORRENDOUS CENTER SCHOOL SO I
THINK THAT'S A BIG ISSUE. PLUS
THE FACT THAT RESEARCH SHOWS IF
YOU ASK- LATINO STUDENTS
SPECIFICALLY AN IMMIGRANT
STUDENTS. WHY DIDN'T YOU APPLY
MANY TIMES THEY THINK THAT THEY
COULDN'T APPLY BECAUSE THEIR
PARENTS WEREN'T. DOCUMENT AND
EVEN THOUGH THEY WERE ELIGIBLE.
AS A CALIFORNIANS BORN HERE. OR
THEY CAN APPLY FOR THIS NEW
PROGRAM THAT WE HAVE CREATING
CALIFORNIA FOR OUR DREAMER
STUDENTS SO. I THINK THERE ARE
WAYS TO DO IT AND I'M IN FULL
SUPPORT I THINK WE SHOULD PUT
THE ONUS MORE ON. THE SCHOOL
AND THE DISTRICTS TO MAKE SURE
IT'S DONE WITH THEIR STUDENT
POPULATION SO. FULL SUPPORT OF
THAT- I WANT TO IT NOTE THAT
THE CALL ISSUE- THIS COMMITTEE.
STRONG SUPPORTERS ARE A
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WILL BE
MAKING. SURE THAT WE CAN
ADDRESS. PROPRIA LONG TERM
FUNDING FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGES
I WANT TO ASK THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IF THEY COULD ADDRESS
THE ISSUE. WITH ENROLLMENT
TARGETS FOR. UC AND CSU AS MANY
OF THE MEMBERS- ALREADY KNOW
OURS ARE FRESH MEMBERS WILL
FIND OUT. WHEN YOU GOT BACK
HOME. YOUR KIDS TEACHERS ARE
GONNA COME UP TO YOU AT THE
PARK THE PARADE WHAT HAVE YOU
AND SAY. MY LOOK MY NEIGHBOR MY
CELL AND CELL PLIED TO. UC OR
CSU AND DIDN'T GET IN AND WHAT
ARE WE DOING TO MAKE SURE
WE'RE- WE HAVE SPOTS FOR ALL OF
OUR QUALITY QUALIFIED GRADUATES
AND SO. I THINK HAVING
APPROPRIATE TARGETS ARE ARE
SOMETHING THAT WE SHOULD HAVE
NOT. ALWAYS COUNT ON THE
SYSTEM. TO DO RIGHT BY THAT I
KNOW THEY TRY THEIR BEST BUT IT
THIS IS A PRIORITY OF OURS SO.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WHAT CAN
YOU PINE ON THAT THESE DEBTS
ENROLLMENT TARGETS FOR THAT FOR
THE- TWO SEGMENTS UC AND CSU.
CERTAINLY BROWN RELEASED FROM
DEPARTMENT OF. THANK YOU FOR
THE QUESTION. TO TWO POINTS
ABOUT ENROLLMENT AT CSU AND UC
THE FIRST IS OUR BIG FOCUS WITH
THIS BUDGET WAS ON THE CCC'S.
BECAUSE ENROLLMENT DROPPED
EIGHT PERCENT. WE ESTIMATE FROM
THIS FALL COMPARED TO LAST FALL.
THE SECOND POINT IS THAT CSU
AND UC- WHEREAS NATIONALLY
THERE HAS BEEN SOME STRUGGLES
WITH ENROLLMENT. WE'RE
FORTUNATE IN CALIFORNIA THAT
CSU AND UC ARE NOT PROJECTING
ENROLLMENT DROPS AND IN FACT
UC. WAS ABLE TO MEET A TWENTY
NINETEEN TARGET. INCREASE OF
FORTY EIGHT HUNDRED AND SIXTY
STUDENTS BUT THE LEGISLATURE
ADDED AND FUNDED IN TWENTY
NINETEEN. AND THAT THAT AMOUNT
OF FORTY EIGHT HUNDRED SPREAD
OVER INTO THE COVE IT ACADEMIC
YEAR. SO THERE WAS INITIALLY
THAT. ONE COULD HAVE BEEN
CONCERNED THAT MAYBE THEY
WOULDN'T MEET THAT WITH ALL THE
UNCERTAINTY. ARE SO FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE. IT'S A BIG DEAL
THE UC WAS ABLE TO MEET THAT
FORTY EIGHT SIXTY ADDITIONAL
STUDENTS AND GROW DURING CALL
THAT- SO THAT'S OUR PERSPECTIVE.
OKAY AND WHAT WHAT IS THE L. A.
L. THINK ABOUT. THE LEGISLATURE
IN THE STATE. TYING DOWN A
ROMAN TARGETS. I'M JENNIFER
PATEL AGAIN L. A. L. AT YEAH AS
WE RECOMMENDED HISTORICALLY WE
THINK- STUDYING AND ROMAN
TARGETS AS AN IMPORTANT STATE
RESPONSIBILITY LEGISLATURE
TYPICALLY DOES SET THEM- SO WE-
RECOGNIZE IT'S A LITTLE BIT
CHALLENGING THIS YEAR BECAUSE
YOU HAVE A BUNCH OF THE FORCES
OUT WORK AND IT'S NOT REALLY
CLEAR WELL THEY'LL ALL LAND SO
WE KNOW HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATES
ARE PROJECTED TO GO OVER VERY
SLOWLY. WE KNOW COMMUNITY
COLLEGES ENROLLMENT IS DOWN
PRETTY STEEPLY IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE- ROUGHLY 10% WE KNOW UC AND
CSU DID GROW A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
ONE PERCENT- AND EACH OF THEM
DURING TWENTY TWENTY ONE. WE
DON'T KNOW HOW THE ECONOMY WILL
REACT WE DON'T KNOW HOW THE
BASKET VACCINE DISTRIBUTION
ALTHOUGH WHEN BOTH K. TWELVE
STUDENTS AND THEIR PARENTS WILL
BE BACK TO. A DIFFERENT- BACK
TO THINGS A LITTLE BIT MORE
LIKE NORMAL FOR THEM SO IT'S
HARD FOR US TO TELL YOU WHETHER
YOU SHOULD BUDGET FLAT FOR THE
COMING YEAR OR OR UP OR DOWN-
WE DO CONTINUE TO RECOMMEND
THAT YOU SET THE TARGETS THAT
ARE IN ALIGNMENT WITH THEIR
ADMISSIONS PROCESS SO IT'S
ALMOST TOO LATE RIGHT NOW TO
INFLUENCE THE TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO YEAR A LOT OF STUDENTS ARE
MAKING THEIR DECISIONS RIGHT
NOW AND THEY WILL HAVE MADE
THEM BEFORE JUNE. SO WE CAN
SEND YOU THAT ENCOURAGE YOU TO
THINK ABOUT SETTING TARGETS FOR
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE IT'S
JUST IT'S HARD- YOU WILL HAVE
TO SORT OF MAKE JUST A JUDGMENT
CALL DO YOU WANT THEM TO GROW
OR STAY FLAT GROW BY 2% BECAUSE
YOU'RE NOT GONNA HAVE A LOT OF
CLARITY FROM THE FORCES AT
WORK. IF I COULD JUST ONE
MINUTE ON THIS ISSUE OF THE
COLA BECAUSE IT'S QUITE AN
INTERESTING ISSUE WHETHER IT
SCHOOL DISTRICTS COLLEGES UCCS
YOU THE BULK OF THE BUDGETS ARE
COMPENSATION AND THEY'RE ALL
FACING INCREASES IN HEALTH CARE
COSTS ARE ALL FACING INCREASES
IN PENSION COSTS ARE ALL FACING
SALARY PRESSURES AND THEY'RE
ALL STILL FACING STAFFING
PRESSURES JUST A LEVEL OF STAFF
THAT THEY HAVE. SO IT IS
INTERESTING WHY IN. SCHOOL
DISTRICTS MAKE IT THREE POINT
84% THE COLLEGE MIGHT GET ONE
POINT. PER AND UNIVERSE WOULD
BE LEFT ON LEVEL THAT'S EVEN BY
TO THEIR NINETEEN TWENTY LEVEL
SO IT'S JUST SOMETHING TO THINK
ABOUT WHAT DO YOU WHAT YOU
WANT. THE STATEMENTS- WHETHER
AT SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE YOU SEE
WHERE YOU WANT THEM TO LAND
WHEN YOU DO YOUR FINAL BUDGET
CALLS OUT. THANK YOU I
COMPLETELY AGREE 1100% THAT-
THE COST FOR. HER FOR STAFFING-
FACULTY AND CREDENTIALED.
FACULTY IS THE SAME MEDICAID
TWELVE SCHOOL COMMUNICABLE TO
YOU SEE THE CSU SO WE SHOULD DO
THAT AND I DIDN'T GET TO YET
BUT I DO- SUPPORT. WHAT WE CAN
DO TO RESTORE THOSE ONGOING UC
AND CSU. FUNDING I KNOW WE HAVE
A LOT OF ONE TIME MONEY COMING
IN. WE COULD GET MUCH MORE IF
WE HAVE THE THIRD. TESTING THIS
BILL THAT'S BEING DEBATED RIGHT
NOW IN CONGRESS. THAT'S
CERTAINLY SOMETHING THAT THAT'S
THAT'S ON. OUR LIST- OUT YOU
ONE THING THAT I THINK THAT WE
HEARD FROM- ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEE
EARLIER. AND SOMEONE MEMBER
RAMOS AT THE GET GO WAS JUST.
THE PAIN THIS IS CAUSED ON OUR
LOWER INCOME STUDENTS- DONNELLY
AT OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND
THAT ARE CSU BUT ALSO WHAT ARE
YOU SEE. AND IN THAT THE NUMBER
OF STEPS THAT THE ENROLLMENT I
THINK THAT THE HEADLINES WITH
WE SEE OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
APPLYING TO UC. ARE THROUGH THE
ROOF- THAT THE DEMOGRAPHICS OF
THOSE. STUDENTS ARE APPLY OR
SOMETHING DIFFERENT IN THE
STUDENTS AT COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
AND EVEN AT THAT THAT CSU SO.
THE SUPPORT FOR THINGS LIKE
BASIC NEEDS AN- EMERGENCY
HOUSING AND ALL THAT I THINK IS
SO CRITICAL I KNOW THERE'S-
SOME ONE TIME MONEY IN THERE
IT'S CERTAINLY SOMETHING THAT
WE MAY TRY TO PUT MORE. FOR ON
GOING OR AT THE MINIMUM- PUT
MORE ONE TIME AND HOW THE SPENT
OVER THREE YEARS SO YOU CAN AT
LEAST HAVE CERTAINTY THAT. YOU
CAN HAVE SOME OF THOSE PROGRAMS
AVAILABLE- THE MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUE. IS CERTAINLY SOME THAT
FOR CENTER YOU'RE THIS TO
TESTED- WE'LL WE'LL HEAR THAT-
YOU KNOW. THEN THAT MOUNTED THE
PRESSURE ON STUDENTS IS ALWAYS
GREAT BUT ESPECIALLY RIGHT NOW
DURING. DURING DURING THE
NINETEEN- THAT'S CERTAINLY
SOMETHING THAT I THINK ONGOING
SUPPORT FOR MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES IS THAT IT'S A
PRIORITY HERE AS WELL- SO. WITH
THAT I DON'T HAVE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS WE DON'T HAVE OUR-
OUR PANEL IS COMING INTO FORCE.
SO ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS
RECRUITING MEMBERS SAYING NONE.
MISTER MEDINA NO SO DO WE HAVE
ANYBODY WITH KNOWLEDGE OR THE
AUDIENCE OF COURSE- DO WE HAVE
ANYBODY. BY ANY CHANCE QUEUED
UP FOR PUBLIC COMMEN. NOW IT'S
SO WE WILL WE CAN ENTERTAIN
PUBLIC COMMENT FOR. TEN MINUTES
RIGHT HERE. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK.
IT HAVE PUBLIC COMMENT ON THE
AGENDA AT THIS TIME. AN
OPERATOR WILL GIVE YOU YOUR
LINE NUMBER. YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
AGAIN WILL BE DOING PUBLIC
COMMENT FOR A BIT NOW AND THEN
WE'LL HAVE OUR PRESENTATIONS
FROM THE THREE HIGHER AT
LEADERS AT FOUR AND THEN AFTER
THAT WE'LL DO MORE PUBLIC
COMMENT. OUR FIRST MY NUMBER IS
NINE SIXTY THREE LINE SIXTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO I'M MY NAME'S
ELECTED VIA AND I'M- COMMITTEE
ON BEHALF OF THE COLLEGE WILL
THANK YOU COULD- PROGRAM. I
WOULD LIKE TO- THEY- THAT I
WOULD LIKE FOR THE BASIC NEEDS
FUNDING- STEPPING ONE TIME BIG
CAN BE ONGOING- OUR STUDENTS
REALLY REALLY COULD BENEFIT
FROM THE SPENDING AT SOMEONE
THAT WORKS ON THE FRONT LINES
WITH THEM DAY BY DAY ESPECIALLY
DURING RIGHT NOW. THE STUDENT
ACCESS BASICALLY FUNDING OUR
STUDENTS ARE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS OUR STUDENTS TO
HAVE BEEN THE FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM ALONG WITH A LOT OF
OTHER AND CHALLENGES. AND AGAIN
THE SPENDING WOULD BE A GREAT
HELP AT THE ONGOING RANDOMIZED.
THANK YOU. OUR NEXT COMMENT
COMES FROM LINE THIRTEEN. LINE
THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MY
NAME IS TODD FAR RESIDENT
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY IN THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY. I'M APPRECIATIVE
OF THE GOVERNOR'S INCLUSION OF
THE FUNDING FOR STUDENT BASIC
NEEDS. AS AN EMPLOYEE OF A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM I WORK
DIRECTLY WITH STUDENTS
EXPERIENCING FOOD INSECURITY. I
OVERSEEING OUR COLLEGE FOOD
PANTRY I'VE SEEN FIRSTHAND THE
GREAT NEED OUR STUDENTS HAVE
UNLIMITED RESOURCES THAT OUR
COMMUNITY HAS AVAILABLE TO MEET
THE ON GOING BASIC NEEDS.
PLEASE DESIGNATE A PORTION OF
THESE COMMUNITY COLLEGE OF
BASIC NEEDS FUNDS AT ONGOING
RATHER THAN ONE TIME THANK YOU.
CONNECT COMMENT COMES FROM LINE
FIFTEEN LINE FIFTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON SURE MCCARTY AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
MARIA AND I'M A STUDENT AT
FOOTHILL COLLEGE INVOLVED WITH
THE WHOLE COLLEGE STUDENT
TRUSTEE AND AN ACTIVE MEMBER OF
THAT THE TRIP WILL BE CAUCUSES.
I WANT TO EXPRESS MY SUPPORT
FOR FULLY FUNDED GCC BUT- IN
APPRECIATION FOR EARLY ACTION
EMERGENCY FINANCIAL AID GRANTS
RETENTION. AND READING MOMENT
STRATEGIES. BECAUSE PATHWAY
PROTECT. AND REQUIRED. OF THE
FACT THAT ALLOCATED AND THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALL OF THE
OTHER CRITICAL PRIORITIES
REFUSING TO STUDENTS
ADDITIONALLY THE THINKING
THROUGH THAT WOULD LIKE TO SEE
BASIC NEED FUNDING BECOME AN
ONGOING INVESTMENT. FOR AN
ONGOING NEED AND IN THE
BATHROOM AND CAL GRANT REFORM
TO ENSURE THE TOTAL COST OF
ATTENDANCE WAS ACCOUNTED FOR.
NOT TO TUITION AND FEES.
FINALLY PROPOSITION SIXTY THREE
REVENUE. SHOULD BE USED TO FUND
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES FOR
FIFTY STUDENTS AND STUDENTS
WITH BATES BARRIERS TO
RECEIVING MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES FOR MY COLLEGE YOU
KNOW OVER CAPACITY I'M AWARE OF
THE DEMAND AND IMPORTANCE OF
THESE SERVICES. SO THAT ALL
STUDENTS HAVE ACCESS INCLUDING.
STUDENTS LIKE ME THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU. NINE
THIRTY. OH I'M SORRY NINE
THIRTY YEAR IS OPEN PLEASE
AHEAD. MY NAME IS TERRY ROZIER
WITH JOHN BURTON ADVOCATES FOR
YOU I WANT TO START BY TAKING
THE CHAIR FOR BEING A CHAMPION
ON THE ISSUE OF. BASIC NEEDS.
RESHAPED INCLUDING A FUNDING
FOR STUDENT BASIC NEEDS ACROSS
ALL THREE SYSTEMS AND THAT ON
GOING FUNDING WAS MADE
AVAILABLE FOR MENTAL HEALTH AND
TECHNOLOGY. THE REQUESTED A
PORTION OF THE FUNDS ALLOCATED
FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO
ADDRESS FOOD AND HOUSING
INSECURITY BE ONGOING RATHER
THAN ONE TIME. IN ADDITION TO
FINANCIAL SUPPORT STUDENTS WHO
ARE FOOD AND HOUSING INSECURITY
NEED ACCESS TO A PERSON WHO CAN
HELP THEM TO TROUBLESHOOT.
ACCESS RESOURCES AND SUPPORT
THEM TO REMAIN INVOLVED. MANY
CAMPUSES HER OVER HOWEVER WILL
NOT HIRE STAFF WITH ONE TIME
FUNDING. HOPE THAT THE
COMMITTEE WILL WORK TO FIND A
WAY TO INCLUDE AN ONGOING
ALLOCATION THANK YOU. CONNECT
COMMENT COMES FROM NINE THIRTY
TO NINE THIRTY TO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON SHOW MCCARTY MEDINA
MILLER'S MY NAME IS MEGAN
RODRIGUEZ ON BEHALF EDUCATION
TRUST WEST. OVERALL YOU
SHOULDN'T BASE SUPPORTIVE OF
THE EARLY ACTION PROPOSALS ON
HOW THE GOVERNOR'S TRYING TO
EXPEDITE DOLLARS INCLUSIVE TO
STUDENT NOW WHILE THEY'RE
LEAVING AND STRUGGLING TO COPE
WITH- WE DO HAVE BEEN
ADDITIONAL DETAILED
CLARIFICATION WHICH WE WALK
INTO ON THE FOURTH. LETTER
WE'RE EXTREMELY SUPPORTIVE OF
THE INVESTMENT INTO STATEWIDE
LONGITUDINAL DATA SYSTEM AND
THE PROPOSAL TO ENSURE ELEAZAR
OTHER TWELFTH GRADE SENIORS
COMPLETE FASTER CALIFORNIA
DREAM ACT WE APPRECIATE. WILL
GRAYSON FROM THE COLLEGE
COMMENTS AND HOW THE ELEVATED
TO MEET THAT LOCAL STUDENTS
HAVE STUDENTS CALL HOME- TO
FILL OUT THE STOCK YEAH. LASTLY
WE APPRECIATE THE FUNDING FOR
BASIC NEEDS MENTAL HEALTH AND
DIGITAL EQUITY WE HOPE
LEGISLATURE CAN EITHER
INCREASES ALLOCATION MAKE IT
ONGOING AND ALSO CLARIFY HOW
THESE BONDS THAT YOU T. TANGLE
AT TIMES SO THAT THEY HAVE THE
HIGHEST IMPACT. ON OUR STUDENTS.
HAPPY OF THE MYSTIFIED NOT. T.
WALL NEED FOR LEGISLATIVE TO.
INFORMED ON THE- QUANTITY
REASONING PROPOSED WHICH MANY
THE QUESTION OR HAPPENS ABOUT
NINE- I WILL BE OUT TO ALL THE
ALSO. NINE SEVENTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS A- PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON SURE MCCARTY AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
JACOB COUCHES I'M A STUDENT AT
AMERICAN RIVER OLLEGE AS WELL
AS THEIR DIRECTOR OF
LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS FOR THE
ASSOCIATED STUDENT BODY. ALL
EXPRESS MY SUPPORT FOR A FULLY
FUNDED C. HEECHEE SYSTEM IN
APPRECIATION FOR EARLY ACTION
EMERGENCY FINANCIALLY GRAMS
RETENTION RETIREMENT STRATEGIES.
EXPLICAR TECHNOLOGY. I'M
REQUIRED COMPLETION OF THE
FASTER AS ALLOCATED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. ALL THESE
ARE CRITICAL PRIORITIES FOR
SPEAKING STUDENTS ADDITIONALLY
EXISTENCE WOULD LIKE TO SEE
BASIC NEEDS FUNDS BECOME AN
ONGOING INVESTMENT TO SUPPORT
AN ONGOING NEED AND INVESTING
IN CALGARY REFORM TO ENSURE THE
TOTAL COST OF ATTENDANCE
ACCOUNTED FOR NOT JUST TUITION
AND FEES. FINALLY PROPOSITION
SIXTY THREE REVENUE SHOULD BE
USED TO FUND MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES FIRST IF YOU SEE.
DISPARITY THERE NOW. FOR THE
CONCERN OF SIX. OF MY CELL AS
WELL AS MY FRIEND CALLED. ME
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU.
NINE SEVENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
OF THEIR INCOME WITH WITH THE
COLLEGE- I DO THINK THAT THEY
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S
INCLUSION OF FUNDING PRETTY
BASIC NEEDS THE BUDGET BUT I'D
LIKE TO REQUEST THAT A PORTION
OF THE SUN BEAT THAT DESIGNATED
AT TE ON GOING RATHER THAN ONE
TIME. FOR COMMITTEE COLLEGES
FOR ALL THE REASONS THAT HAVE
NOT PREVIOUSLY STATED. THANK
YOU. NINE FIFTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU MY NAME IS A BATTLE OF AL
AND I WORK WITH FOSTER YOUTH AT
SANTA ROSA JUNIOR COLLEGE WHO
ARE TWICE AS LIKELY AS OTHER
STUDENTS EXPERIENCE BASIC NEEDS
AND SECURITY. I AM APPRECIATIVE
OF THE GOVERNOR INCLUDED
FUNDING IN A TRIPLE TO ADDRESS
STUDENT BASIC NEEDS AT
COMMUNITY COLLEGES BUT I'M HERE
TO REQUEST THAT A PORTION OF
THESE FUNDS BE DESIGNATED AS
ONGOING RATHER THAN ONE TIME.
STUDENT THE FOURTEENTH ACCESS
FOR HELPING AND TO SUPPORT THE
PERMANENT PERMANENT. STAFF
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NINE
TWENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HOW MANY
NUMBERS THIS IS RICK JUMP ON
TOES I'M CALLING FROM LOCAL
COLLEGE UNIVERSITY COUNTY- I
JUST WANTED TO CALL EXPRESS MY
GRATITUDE FOR THE FUNDING THAT
YOU'RE GIVING QUEUE AT THE
PARTY NEEDS AND REQUESTED IT BE
ALSO ONGOING- AS A FORMER
AUSTRIAN MYSELF AND AS A FORMER
ALMOST DID IT MYSELF- CULTURE.
OF WHAT THE- ONLY LIFE AND I
HADN'T TO. A STABILIZE MAYBE
SIX. AND ALLOW ME TO KEEP THE
THAT MY AND NOW I'M GRATEFUL
THAT BEEN ABLE TO MOVE AND THEN
CALL THE GETTING THE TO GET A
WHO. ARE HOW DIFFERENT NEEDS-
HAVE A COVERAGE SO NOT ONLY ARE
WE GRATEFUL FOR THE THAT YOU
GIVE BUT ALSO WE WOULD LIKE TO
SURE THAT OF THAT ISYOU'RE NOT
SURE ONGOING FUNDING THE KILLER
ON. LONG TERM SOLUTIONS FOR
THANK YOU THANK. NINE SEVENTY
ONE YOUR IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. DO AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
TO WILLIAMS AND I'M CALLING-
COMPTON. I IN THE CORNER OF OUR
STUDENTS HAVE ALSO THE PROGRAM-
JUST LIKE ALL MY SAID I VERY.
OF ALL THE EFFORTS TO HAVE BEEN
DONE BUT MY- REQUIRED GRANT THE
USE OF THE OUR BE ON THE PHONE-
WE HAVE A- LARGE AMOUNT OF
STUPID. LET'S LET. THAT. BASIC
NEEDS IS NOT ONE TIME- WE NEED
TO. MAKE AND CREATE AND SUSTAIN
A SYSTEM SUPPORT AND THAT'S
ONLY GOING TO BE A COMP WITH
ONGOING FUNDING THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AT THE LAST SPEAKER.
AGAIN THIS IS A LOT WEEK OF THE
SAG OF PUBLIC COMMENT WILL BACK
LATER THE HEARING LAST WEEK.
ONE MORE. NINE ELEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OF. PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
MY NAME IS GENEVIEVE COUNTY
JAIL FOR AND I'M A FRESHMAN AT
UC SAN DIEGO BETTING THERE
THANK IN PUBLIC POLICY I'M HERE
BECAUSE EVEN THOUGH I'M A NEW
STUDENT I'VE WITNESSED MY
FRIENDS CLASSMATES AND
ROOMMATES STRUGGLING BOTH ON
AND OFF CAMPUS DUE TO COVER
NINETEEN I ALREADY KNOW DOZENS
OF STUDENTS USING OUR
COUNSELING AND PSYCHOLOGICAL
SERVICES. AND OTHERS WORKING ON
CAMPUS TO MAKE ENDS MEET WHEN
FINANCIAL RECORDED DIFFICULT TO
FIND STUDENTS ARE SUFFERING SO
I IMPLORE YOU COULD PLEASE
PRIORITIZE THE NEEDS AND
RESTORE CRITICAL FUNDING PC. IN
THE STATE BUDGET THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU I WITH THAT
WE'RE GOING TO GO NOW TO THE
SPECIAL ORDER OF BUSINESS AT
FOR WE HAVE OUR THREE LEADERS
FROM THE- CALIFORNIA HIGHER
EDUCATION SEGMENTS JOINING US
TODAY WE HAVE A PRESIDENT DRAKE
FROM THE UC CHANCELLOR CASTRO
FROM THE CSU AND CHANCELLOR
FORTIES OAKLEY FROM OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND WE'RE
GONNA BEGIN WITH CHANCELLOR-
ORTIZ OAKLEY. YOU KNOW WE
ALWAYS START WITH THE UC BUT
LET'S MIX IT UP AND OF COURSE
THE COMMUNICABLE DISEASE ARE.
THE WORK COURSE OF OUR STATE
HIGHER EDUCATION SYSTEM WITH
TWO MILLION. STUDENTS AND- SOME
UNIQUE CHALLENGES DURING THIS
PANDEMIC SO- CHANCELLOR TEASE
OAKLEY YOU CAN YOU CAN BEGIN.
F. ALL RIGHT WELL GOOD
AFTERNOON THANK YOU CHAIR
MCCARTY AND- MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE IT'S A- PLEASURE TO
BE WITH YOU EVEN THOUGH WE ARE
REMOTE I WOULD MUCH RATHER BE
THERE WITH YOU BUT- THESE ARE.
INTERESTING TIMES NO DOUBT SO-
LET ME BEGIN AGAIN BY JUST
THANKING THE COMMITTEE FOR
THEIR ON GOING SUPPORT. A
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND MORE
BROADLY HIGHER EDUCATION- THIS
IS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
PARTICULARLY NOW AS WE BEGIN TO
THINK ABOUT THE RECOVERY FROM
THIS PANDEMIC. YOU KNOW A YEAR
AGO THAT THE LEGISLATURE
CONSIDERED. BURKE NEARLY ALL OF
THE INSTRUCTION WITHIN THE
LARGEST SYSTEM OF HIGHER
EDUCATION IN THE COUNTRY TO
REMOTE DELIVERY. I WASN'T EVEN-
I THOUGHT. WE DIDN'T PRESENT A
COMPREHENSIVE PLAN ON HOW TO
PROVIDE LAPTOPS AT SCALE TO
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
STUDENTS WHO CAN AFFORD THEM OR
HOW TO KEEP FOOD PANTRIES OPEN-
DURING THE MIDDLE OF A PANDEMIC
AND HELP FEED- STUDENTS AND
THEIR FAMILIES. AND IT WOULD
HAVE BEEN INCONCEIVABLE TO
DISCUSS HOW COLLEGES. SHOULD
pFROM THE RESPIRATORY THERAPY
PROGRAMS. THE STATE'S EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM. YET. WE DID
THIS AND SO MUCH MORE OVER THE
PAST YEAR IN OUR HUNDRED
SIXTEEN COLLEGES ALL STEP
FORWARD STEPPED UP. AND DID
WHAT THEY ALWAYS DO TO SUPPORT
THE COMMUNITIES. AS PANDEMIC IN
FEAR SPREAD THROUGHOUT THE
STATE ARE FACULTY STAFF AND
STUDENTS. DO WHAT THEY ALWAYS
DO- BEATTY PUT THE COMMUNITY
ABOVE THEMSELVES THEY STEPPED
OUT THEY RAISE MONEY THEY-
PASSED OUT FOOD. AND THEY DID
EVERYTHING POSSIBLE TO ENSURE
THAT INSTRUCTION WAS NOT
INTERRUPTED. IN ADDITION TO THE
RESPONSE TO A ONCE IN A
LIFETIME PANDEMIC- THERE WAS
ALSO A LONG OVERDUE- RECKONING
WITH RACISM THAT SHOOK OUR
COUNTRY TO THE CORE AND IT
CONTINUES TO RIPPLE THROUGHOUT
SOCIETY. IT WOULD HAVE BEEN
EASY FOR US TO USE THIS
PANDEMIC AS AN EXCUSE TO PULL
BACK ON OUR COMMITMENT TO
ENDING RACIAL DISPARITIES IN
OUR COLLEGES. BUT THAT
MISUNDERSTANDS THE NATURE OF
THIS CRISIS THE EVENTS OF THE
PAST YEAR HAVE MADE VISIBLE
DISPARITIES THAT ARE BLACK AND
AFRICAN AMERICAN LATIN NEXT
ASIAN AMERICAN AND PACIFIC
ISLANDER COMMUNITY SEVEN
COUNTER FOR GENERATIONS. ARE
AND YOU KNOW THESE EVENTS. ONLY
DEEPENED AWARENESS AND
CRYSTALLIZE OUR COMMITMENT TO
STUDENTS IN THE INVESTMENTS.
THAT WE NEED TO MAKE IN ORDER
TO RIGHT THESE WRONGS MY
REMARKS WILL FOCUS ON THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES BUDGET
PRIORITIES HOWEVER IT'S
IMPORTANT TO PROVIDE SOME
CONTEXT ABOUT THE SIGNIFICANT
ACHIEVEMENTS ARE COLLEGES HAVE
MADE. OUR AND OUR HISTORIC
SYSTEM REFORMS. OVER THE PAST
TWO YEARS OUR COLLEGES HAVE
INCREASED THE NUMBER OF
STUDENTS EARN CREDENTIALS BY
20% MEETING ONE OF THE SIX
VISION FOR SUCCESS SUCCESS
GOALS AHEAD OF SCHEDULE. WE'RE
MAKING PROGRESS ON THE GOALS ON
TRANSFER. OUR AND- NARROWING
THE ACHIEVEMENT GAPS AMONGST
OUR STUDENTS OF COLOR
INCREASING THE NUMBER OF
STUDENTS WERE GETTING JOBS IN
THEIR FIELD OF STUDY THIS IS
ALL THANKS TO OUR TREMENDOUS
FACULTY AND STAFF. AND THANKS
TO THE ASSEMBLY SUPPORT OUR
LEADERSHIP PARTICULARLY IN THE
LEADERSHIP OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JACQUI IRWIN. WE HAVE BANDED A
PLACEMENT SYSTEM THAT FAILED
STUDENTS BY IN ACCURATELY
MEASURING THEIR POTENTIAL. AND
THEN REPLACING IT WITH ONE THAT
IS LEADING TO MORE EQUITABLE
ACCESS TO AND SUCCESS IN
TRANSFER LEVEL ENGLISH AND MATH
COURSES EACH OF THESE
ACHIEVEMENTS THESE IMPROVEMENTS
ARE THINGS THAT SHOULD THAT WE
SHOULD BE DEEPLY PROUD OF. BUT
WE SHOULD NOT BE SATISFIED WITH
NOT IN THIS MOMENT IN TIME.
THIS MOMENT CALLS ON US AS
LEADERS TO DO SOMETHING MORE
THAT MAKES A MEANINGFUL
DIFFERENCE THIS GENERATION OF
STUDENTS. THIS MOMENT CALLS ON
US TO TAKE ACTION COMMENSURATE.
WITH THE MOMENT THAT WE HAVE
ENTERED INTO AND WE MUST
LEVERAGE THE RESOURCES
PRESENTED IN THIS BUDGET TO
SUPPORT STUDENTS WITH THE
URGENCY THEY EXPECT FROM US.
YOUR AGENCY THAT THEY NEED FROM
US. AS YOU WELL KNOW OUR
STUDENTS ARE FACING HUGE
CHALLENGES AT THIS TIME YOU
HEARD FROM ANY OF THEM ALREADY.
ONE IN FIVE STUDENTS SAID THAT
THEY HAVE BEEN FURLOUGHED OR
LAID OFF DURING THIS PANDEMIC.
HALF REPORT THEIR INCOMES ARE
LOWER. 57% OF STUDENTS ARE
DEALING WITH BASIC NEEDS
CHALLENGES INCLUDING FOOD AND
HOUSING INSECURITY. MANY OF OUR
HOMES. MORE THAN FOUR IN TEN
STUDENTS SAY THAT THEY NEED TO
CARE FOR FAMILY MEMBERS. WHILE
ALSO GOING TO SCHOOL AND CAN
AND COMPLETING THEIR STUDIES.
OUR STUDENTS OF COLOR THESE
NUMBERS ARE EVEN HIGHER
REFLECTING A DISPROPORTIONATE
IMPACT THAT COVERT NINETEEN
THIS HAD ON THEIR COMMUNITIES.
AND THE LEGACY OF EXCLUSION
FROM OPPORTUNITIES TO BUILD
WEALTH. OR ACCESS EDUCATION AND
ADEQUATE HEALTH CARE. THAT'S
WHY WE BELIEVE THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO BUDGET
SHOULD. PUT STUDENTS FIRST. WE
APPLAUD THE GOVERNOR
RECOGNIZING THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS HAVE BEEN THE
MOST AFFECTED ELECTION. AGENT
IN FOR A BUDGET PROPOSAL. THAT
LAYS A STRONG FOUNDATION. ALL
HIGHLIGHTED SEVERAL INVESTMENTS
THAT TRULY PUTS STUDENTS FIRST
INCLUDING A PROPOSED EMERGENCY
STUDENT AID. THE ONLINE
EDUCATION INFRASTRUCTURE AND
RESOURCES. OR FACULTY
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT. EVEN
BEFORE COVER NINETEEN TOO MANY
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS WERE STRUGGLING WITH
BASIC NEEDS INSECURITIES COVERT
NINETEEN HAS FURTHER EXPOSED
ECONOMIC AND SOCIAL DISPARITIES
WE MUST PRIORITIZE THE PROPOSED
STUDENT EMERGENCY AID BOTH IN
THE EARLY ACTION PACKAGE AND IN
THE BUDGET ACT LET'S NOT LOSE
ANOTHER J. GENERATION OF
STUDENTS LET'S GIVE OUR
STUDENTS THE SAME URGENCY THAT
THEY'RE LIVING THEIR LIVES WITH
RIGHT NOW. AND PROVIDE THEM
EMERGENCY AID THAT THEY NEED.
AS WE ENTER THE ELEVENTH MONTH
OF THE PANDEMIC THE IDEA OF
ETURNING TO NORMAL TEAMS
DISTANCE MATTER FACT THERE IS
NO RETURNING TO WHAT WE THOUGHT
WAS NORMAL. WE'RE ENTERIG INTO
A COMPLETELY NEW CHAPTER OF HOW
WE'RE GOING TO DELIVER
EDUCATION AND MEASURE LEARNING.
THE FACT IS THAT OUR COLLEGES
WILL FACE A NEW NORMAL WHERE
THEY LEVERAGE TECHNOLOGY
INCREASE ACCESS AND INNOVATE IN
AND OUT OF THE CLASSROOM OUR
SYSTEM NEEDS STRONG INVESTMENT
IN TECHNOLOGY RESOURCE. BY WAY
OF THE TEN POINT SIX MILLION
DOLLARS. TO MEET THIS
OPPORTUNITY AND CONTINUE. TO
OFFER DISTANCE EDUCATION TO
OVER TWO MILLION STUDENTS. WE
MUST CONTINUE TO NARROW THEIR
FOCUS AND HELP NOT JUST OUR
STUDENTS IN OUR CLASSROOMS. BUT
THE ADULT WORKERS THE LEARNERS
THAT ARE IN THE ECONOMY THAT
NEED TO BE RESCHEDULED AND
UPSCALE. OUR TO GET BACK INTO
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY. OUR
SYSTEM BUDGET REQUEST
EMPHASIZED THAT IMPROVING
FACULTY IN DIVERSITY IS VITAL
TO ENSURING STUDENTS CAN
IDENTIFY WITH FACULTY AND STAFF
TO HELP THEM SUCCEED. WE BASS
FOR SEVEN SEAT SEVENTY SEVEN
MILLION IN THE BUDGET TO HELP
WITH FACULTY AND STAFF
DIVERSITY. AND WITH EQUITY AND
INCLUSION WORK INCLUDING
ADVANCING ANTI RACISM IN THE
CURRICULUM THE PROPOSED TWENTY
MILLION. ONE TIME INVESTMENT
AND CULTURALLY RESPONSIVE
FACULTY PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT PROVIDES A CHANCE.
HILDA CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEM THAT IS MORE
JUST MORE EQUITABLE. WE STAND
FULLY BEHIND THIS WORK AND LOOK
FORWARD TO PARTNERING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE TO BUILD ON THIS
PROPOSAL AND TO ATTRACT AND
RETAIN. GREAT FACULTY OF COLOR
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL AS FOR
HIGHER EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS
TO HAVE AN ACTIONABLE PLAN TO
CLOSE EQUITY GAPS THIS IS
NOTHING NEW FOR OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE. WE HAVE THAT PLAN THAT
PLAN IS THE VISION FOR SUCCESS.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU TO ALIGN THE TENET OF THE
PROPOSAL WILL DISTRICTS LOCAL
VISION GOALS AND STUDENT EQUITY
BY. FIVE FINALLY AS WE PREPARE
FOR REVISED BUDGET ESTIMATES OF
ANY- AND SHOULD THERE BE MORE
RESEARCH. YES YOUR TIES FURTHER
PAIN DWN DEFERRALS WE MUST
BRING DOWN THE DEFERRALS. A
CLOSE BY EMPHASIZING THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
ARE HERE TO WORK TOGETHER. WITH
YOU FOR EQUITABLE ECONOMIC
RECOVERY NOT A RECOVERY THAT
FAVORS WALL STREET BUT ONE THAT
FAVORS MAINSTREET MAIN STREET
IN CALIFORNIA EVERY STUDENT
TWENTY FOR SHOT. SO LET'S.
LET'S USE THIS BUDGET PROPOSAL
TO MAKE SURE WE PROVIDE OUR
STUDENTS THE HELP THAT THEY
NEED AND GET IT TO THEM AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE THANK YOU
FOR THE TIME CANACCORD
ANSWERING ANY OF YOUR. THANK
YOU WHAT WE'LL DO QUESTIONS AT
THE END AFTER WE HAVE OUR
THREE. INDIVIDUALS THAT
PARTICIPATE AT NEXT WE'RE GOING
TO HEAR FROM OUR CHANCELLOR FOR
THE CSU SYSTEM. CHANCER CASTRO
THIS IS HIS- FIRST OPPORTUNITY
TO JOIN US SO- WELCOME. CANCER
CASTRO. THANK YOU CHAIRMAN
CARTY THE MEMBERS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE IT'S AN HONOR TO
BE HERE WITH YOU AND HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK. ALONG
WITH MY ESTEEMED COLLEAGUES AND
AT SUCH A CONSEQUENTIAL
HISTORIC MOMENT IN TIME FOR OUR
STATE AND NATION. OUR NATION IS
DEEPLY EMBEDDED REALLY DIVIDED.
OUR MOST SACRED DEMOCRATIC
INSTITUTIONS HAVE BEEN
THREATENS. FIRST THROUGH
RECKLESS AND IRRESPONSIBLE
RHETORIC AND THEN UNIMAGINABLY
THROUGH VIOLENT ACTS OF
INSURRECTION. AND STILL A
PANDEMIC RAGES WRECKING AND
CALCULABLE SUFFERING AND
CAUSING GREAT ECONOMIC
UNCERTAINTY WHILE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTING
PEOPLE OF MODEST MEANS AND
PEOPLE OF COLOR. WHO CONTINUE
TO INDOOR HEARTBREAKING ACTS OF
RACIAL INJUSTICE. BUT STILL I
SPEAK TO YOU TODAY WITH GREAT
OPTIMISM DESPITE THE CHALLENGES
THAT WE FACE I WHOLEHEARTEDLY
BELIEVE THAT WE FIND OURSELVES
AT AN INFLECTION POINT. AND AS
THE NATION'S LARGEST AND MOST
DIVERSE PUBLIC UNIVERSITY AND
ONE OF ITS LEADING DRIVERS OF
SOCIO ECONOMIC ASCENT. IT IS
OUR GREAT PRIVILEGE AND
RESPONSIBILITY TO HELP OUR
STATE AND NATION TURN TOWARD
HEALING RECONCILIATION. AND
RECOVERY. AND ENHANCING ITS
BUDGET PROPOSAL EARLIER THIS
MONTH THE GOVERNOR'S
ADMINISTRATION EMPHASIZED THE
CRITICAL ROLE HIGHER EDUCATION
WILL PLAY IN CALIFORNIA'S
RECOVERY AND SUSTAINED ECONOMIC
VITALITY. AND GOVERNOR NUISANCE
PROPOSAL REPRESENTS A WELCOME
AND NECESSARY REINVESTMENT IN
THE CSU. AND FOR THAT I EXPRESS
MY DEEP APPRECIATION AND
GRATITUDE. I ASSURE YOU WE WILL
DELIVER ON THIS IMPORTANT
RESPONSIBILITY CONTINUING TO
PRODUCE CAREER READY GRADUATES
AND THE STATE'S NEXT GENERATION
A BOLD TALENTED AND DIVERSE
LEADERS. HOWEVER WE STAND READY
TO DO MORE. AND THAT'S HISTORIC
MOMENT IN TIME DEMANDS THAT WE
DO MORE. BUT WE NEED YOUR
SUPPORT YOUR CONTINUED SUPPORT.
WE ASKED FOR AN ADDITIONAL
THREE HUNDRED AND SIXTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN ONGOING
DOLLARS AND FIVE HUNDRED AND
SIXTY FIVE MILLION AND ONE TIME
DOLLARS TO FULLY RESTORE PRIOR
CUTS TO THE CSU BUDGET. TO
PROMOTE ECONOMIC RECOVERY AND
TO SUSTAIN ECONOMIC VITALITY
INTO THE FUTURE. AND WITHOUT
FUNDING WE'LL BE ABLE TO FULLY
FUND. ACTUATION INITIATIVE
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE AS MANY OF
YOU YOU KNOW THIS IS AN
INVESTMENT WITH A PROVEN RETURN.
THE SEATTLE TO USE GRADUATION
RATES ARE CURRENTLY AT ALL TIME
HIGHS FOR STUDENTS FROM ALL
BACKGROUNDS BUT WE MUST DO MORE
TO ELIMINATE EQUITY GAPS. A
GOAL THAT IS ALIGNED WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S EQUITY MINDED BUDGET
PROPOSAL. THERE ARE MOST
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES BEARING
THE BRUNT OF THE PANDEMIC AN
ASSOCIATED ECONOMIC UPHEAVAL
OUR MORAL IMPERATIVE TO CORRECT
THIS INEQUITY HAS NEVER BEEN
MORE APPARENT FOR MORE URGENT.
WITH THE ADDITIONAL ONE TIME
FUNDS WE CAN BEGIN TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THE CSU IS CRITICAL
FACILITIES AND INFRASTRUCTURE
NEEDS. MAKING OUR AGING CAMPUS
BUILDINGS SAFER AND MORE
SEISMICALLY SOUND. WE HAVE FOUR
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN APPROVED PROJECTS
THEY CAN IMMEDIATELY PROCEED TO
DESIGN OR CONSTRUCTION. TO HELP
STIMULATE THE ECONOMY AND
PROVIDE DESPERATELY NEEDED JOBS.
AND WALDRON THE TOPIC OF JOBS
WITH THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
BUDGET AND THANKS TO OUR
PRUDENT MANAGEMENT OF THE
RESOURCES ENTRUSTED TO US. AND
THE STRATEGIC USE OF OUR
RESERVE FUNDS THROUGH THESE
CHALLENGING TIMES NOT ONLY WILL
WE NOT BE RAISING TUITION FOR
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWENTY
TWO. I WILL NOT RECOMMEND A
SYSTEM WIDE FURLOUGH PROGRAM
THIS YEAR. AND I AM OPTIMISTIC
THAT TOGETHER WE WILL NOT HAVE
TO LAY OFF ANY ADDITIONAL
PERMANENT CSU FACULTY OR STAFF.
DUE TO THE LACK OF STATE FUNDS.
BUT TO ENSURE THAT WE CAN
RETAIN THESE JOBS FOR THE LONG
TERM. THE PERMANENT RESTORATION
OF OUR BUDGET IS ESSENTIAL. THE
FIFTY THREE THOUSAND CSU
FACULTY AND STAFF HELLO BLOOD
OF THE CSU TO DEVOTE THEIR
LIVES WORK TO OUR STUDENTS
SUCCESS AND WELL BEING. DESERVE
NOTHING LESS. FOR RESTORATION
OF CUTS WILL ENSURE LONG TERM
ECONOMIC STABILITY FOR OUR
CAMPUSES AND PROTECT OUR VALUED
EMPLOYEES. LIKE YOU I BELIEVE
THAT TALENT EXISTS IN EVERY
HOUSEHOLD FROM THE PUBLICLY
SUBSIDIZED APARTMENT COMPLEX
THAT I GREW UP IN HANFORD THE
CENTRAL VALLEY TO COMMUNITIES
UP AND DOWN THE GOLDEN STATE.
WE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
UNLEASH THAT TALENT AND PREPARE
A NEW GENERATION OF BALD
LEADERS WE'RE GONNA TAKE THE
GOLDEN STATE TO NEW HEIGHTS OF
SUCCESS IN THE FUTURE. I HOPE
THAT YOU'LL CONTINUE TO SEE THE
CSU IS A RESOURCE IN THE COMING
DAYS WEEKS AND YEARS AS WE
TACKLE THE MOST IMPORTANT
ISSUES TOGETHER. AND PLEASE
CALL ME ANYTIME THAT I CAN BE
HELPFUL TO YOU OR THE CSU COULD
BE HELPFUL TO YOU. THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS
YOU THIS AFTERNOON AND WHEN THE
TIME IS APPROPRIATE I LOOK
FORWARD TO JOINING IN ANSWERING
YOUR QUESTIONS. THANK YOU THANK
YOU- CHANCELLOR CASTRO
CERTAINLY HAVE SOME QUESTIONS
FOR YOU I CAN WE BRING UP-
PRESIDENT DRAKE. A GREAT AND
GOOD AFTERNOON YES YEAH BEEF
BEFORE YOU BEFORE YOU START I
JUST WANTED TO US TO SEE YOU.
AND I OF COURSE AND I'M STRUCK
BY AND I'M SURE ALL OF US UP
HERE- ALL ALL OF YOU AND
CHANCELLOR- CASTRO'S NEW AND
PRESIDENT DRAKE YOU'RE NEW. TO
THIS ROLE IS REALLY NOT NEW TO
THE UC BUT IT'S A NEW DAY FOR
LEADERSHIP IN HIGHER EDUCATION
AND SOMETHING IS JUST
TREMENDOUS THAT CALIFORNIA
THAT. THE DIVERSITY THAT WE
HAVE HERE FOR THE FIRST TIME IN
OUR NATION AND OUR STATE'S
HISTORY ALL THREE OF OUR
LEADERS- COME FROM
UNDERREPRESENTED. ETHNIC GROUPS
OF CALIFORNIA SO NOT QUITE
PERFECT AS FAR AS GENDER
DIVERSITY BUT WE'LL GET THERE
NEXT TIME BUT CERTAINLY- IT'S
NOT LOST UPON US THAT AS WE
LOOK UPON THE SUMMER OF TWENTY
TWENTY AND- THE SUMMER OF
JUSTICE AND RECONCILIATION AS
FAR AS OUR RACIAL POLICIES
HAVING. OUR LEADERS RECOGNIZE
THAT REPRESENT THESE
COMMUNITIES IS CERTAINLY
SOMETHING THAT- THAT WE'RE
PROUD OF AND I NOTICE HERE SO I
WITH THAT- PRESIDENT DRAKE-
WELCOME TO THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSEMBLY IN OUR- BUDGET
HEARINGS AND- AND WE WISH YOU
WERE HERE IN PERSON TO SITTING
AT THE TABLE BUT- THE SHOW GOES
ON SO- YOU STARTED LAST SUMMER
WE HAD A CHANCE TO MEET YOU
TOWARDS THE END OF OUR BUDGET
PROCESS SO- YOU KNOW THANK YOU
AND- PLEASE AT PRESENT YOUR
BUDGET. TESTIMONY THIS
AFTERNOON. WELL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I. THAT THAT EUROPE
MCCARTY AND MEMBERS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE AND I WISH. THAT I
WERE WERE THERE WITH YOU AS
WELL AS- HAVING. GROWN UP MOST
OF MY- LIFE IN SACRAMENTO AND
AT THE CAPITOL SINCE THE DAYS
THAT I WAS A CHILD THAT- THAT
WILL BE GREAT TO HAVE A CHANCE
TO BE THERE IN. IN PERSON.
ALIVE WILL DODD ECHO YOUR
COMMENTS THAT'S BEEN GREAT TO-
JOINED MY COLLEAGUES IN CSU AND
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES. A
COUPLE OF US ARE GUARD
GRADUATES LIVE OR- THAT WE ARE
TRANSFERRED FROM COMMUNITY
COLLEGES TO OUR FOUR YEAR
UNIVERSITY AND- I'VE HAD THE
PLEASURE OF WORKING WITH MY-
COLLEAGUES- THAT FOR MANY.
YEARS PARTICULARLY- CHANCE
THEIR CHARACTER WE'VE WORKED
TOGETHER FOR MORE THAN. TWENTY
FIVE YEARS AND IT'S GREAT TO BE
ARRIVING- AT THIS PLACE THAT
OUR CAREERS AS AS COLLEAGUES
AGAIN AS WE LOOK TO WORK. ACT
TOGETHER TO I CREATE AN EVEN
BRIGHTER FUTURE FOR
CALIFORNIANS. OKAY LET ME SAY
THAT- I'M REALLY PLEASED TO BE
HERE TO BE ABLE TO DISCUSS THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALL CALIFORNIA
AND- AND HOW THE STATE BUDGET
SUPPORTS OUR OUR WORK THIS IS
CERTAINLY. CERTAINLY BEEN NO.
ORDINARY YEAR FOR ANY OF US.
THE PANDEMIC OUR RACIAL JUSTICE.
THE WILD THAT WERE FUELED BY
CLIMATE CHANGE. ECONOMIC
HARDSHIP AND THREATS TO
DEMOCRACY CHALLENGES AS
INDIVIDUALS. AS A STATE AND AS
A NATION. WITH YOUR CRUCIAL
SUPPORT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA'S LIVED UP TO ITS
MISSION OF TEACHING. RESEARCH
AND PUBLIC SERVICE. FROM
HELPING FIRST GENERATION
COLLEGE STUDENTS OBTAINED THEIR
DEGREES TO FIGHTING CLIMATE
CHANGE. LEADING THE FIGHT
AGAINST COVERED NINETEEN. AND
TODAY I'D LIKE TO SHARE AN
UPDATE ON SEVERAL OF OUR SHARED
PRIORITIES. IN RESPONSE TO THE
CALL GOOD PANDEMIC I USED TO
HAVE PROVIDED HIGH QUALITY
HEALTHCARE EFFICIENTLY AND HAS
RAPIDLY ADMINISTERED VACCINES
AND RESEARCH THERAPIES WE'RE
ACTUALLY DOING THOSE THINGS-
TODAY AT THIS AT THIS VERY
MOMENT. AS I FOR USING
CALIFORNIA HOSPITALS ARE FILLED
WITH PATIENTS THE EXCEPTIONAL
HEALTH CARE AND HEALTH
EDUCATION OPPORTUNITIES OFFERED
BY UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA
ACADEMIC HEALTH SYSTEM IS MORE
IMORTANT THAN EVER. AND I
REALLY WANT TO EXPRESS MY
DEEPEST GRATITUDE TO OUR HEALTH
CARE HEROES WHO ARE WORKING TO
SAVE LIVES THIS HAS BEEN AN
INCREDIBLE YEAR AFTER THEM AND
IT CONTINUES. ARE EXCEPTIONAL
LEADERSHIP ARE COVERED REACHES
FAR BEYOND THE I SEE YOU OF
COURSE THOUGH AND- TODAY I UC
SAN FRANCISCO IS OPERATING A
VACCINATION SITES FOR ELDERLY
SAN FRANCISCANS. AND FRONTLINE
HEALTH CARE WORKERS WHO ARE NOT
AFFILIATED WITH UCSF. YOUR
PARTNER WITH THE CITY OF SAN
FRANCISCO AND CITY COLLEGE OF
SAN FRANCISCO TO OFFER. A
THOUSAND VACCINATION TODAY AT A
DRIVE THRU CLINIC FACILITY. NOW
THERE IN SAN FRANCISCO. UC
DAVIS WAS RECENTLY FEATURED IN
A NEW YORK TIMES ARTICLE FOR
THEIR WORK IN FIGHTING THE
PANDEMIC FOR THE ENTIRE CITY OF
DAVIS THIS WAS JUST OVER THIS
PAST. WEEKEND I COMMEND THIS
ARTICLE TO YOU. THE CAMPUS IS
PROVIDING ALL DAVIS RESIDENTS
FREE COVER TESTING. THEY'VE
TRAINED GRADUATE STUDENTS TO DO
CONTACT TRACING THEY'VE
RECRUITED HOTEL AND APARTMENT
OWNERS TO PROVIDE THREE
ISOLATION AND QUARANTINE
HOUSING. TO ANYONE IN TOWN WHO
IS EXPOSED TO THE VIRUS. R. TWO
HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE
UNDERGRADUATE AMBASSADORS. TO
COMBAT HEALTH IN THIS
INFORMATION AND TO HAND OUT
FREE MASKS. UC IRVINE IS TURN
THEIR ATHLETICS ARENA INTO A
VACCINATION CENTERS SERVING UP-
ULTIMATELY TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
PATIENTS. AND THE CABINET THAT
IT'S HEALTHCARE SYSTEM ACTUALLY
HAVE THE CAPACITY TO VACCINATE
MORE PEOPLE THAT ARE COUNTIES
DECIDED DISNEYLAND ONCE GREATER
VACCINE SUPPLY BECOMES
AVAILABLE WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD
TO THAT. YOU SEE IS WORLD CLASS
RESEARCHERS ALSO SAYS THAT IN
THE FIGHT AGAINST CARBON. IN
JUST BROUGHT ONE ADDITIONAL
EXAMPLE UC IRVINE MEDICAL
CENTER BLOTCH CALIFORNIA'S
FIRST SITE. FOR THE NATIONAL
INSTITUTES OF HEALTH CLINICAL
TRIAL OF THE ANTIVIRAL DRUG
ROOM DISAPPEAR. WHICH ISN'T TO
BECOME A STANDARD THERAPY FOR
MANY SEVERELY ILL PLACE
PATIENTS HOSPITALIZED FOR
CORPORATE NINETEEN. ALL UC
CAMPUSES HAVE QUICKLY PIVOTED
TO REMOTE LEARNING THEY DID
THIS LAST LAST LAST SPRING AND
TO SAFETY PROTOCOLS. AND UC
CAMPUSES THOUGHTFULLY PLANNED
LIMITED CAMPUS OPERATIONS AND
REGULARLY TESTED STUDENTS AND
EMPLOYEES YOUR ON SITE. AND
HELP TO SET UP SYSTEM FOR
TRACING AND QUARANTINE. AGAIN
THERE MANY EXAMPLES OF THIS
I'LL SHARE JUST A FEW OF. THE
RETURN TO LEARN PROGRAM AT UC
SAN DIEGO PROVIDE STUDENTS AND
CAMPUS WILL EMPLOYEES THREE
WEEKLY SELF ADMINISTERED TEST.
FROM VENDING MACHINES OR DRIVE
THROUGH TESTING SITES. THERE'S
ALSO BEEN THE CAMPUS INFECTION
RATES FOR THE FALL TERM. WERE
WELL BELOW 1% FOR THE ENTIRE
TERM AND ROUTINELY BELOW ZERO
POINT FIVE PERCENT. EVEN WITH
THE POST HOLIDAY SURGE THE
POSITIVITY RATE REMAINS
EXTREMELY LOW COMPARED TO THE
RATE AND SURROUNDING
COMMUNITIES. AS OF JANUARY
TWENTY FOURTH THE- JANUARY
TWENTY FOURTH THE STATE'S
FOURTEEN DAY AVERAGE WAS ABOUT
10% CASE POSITIVITY. AMONG UC
CAMPUSES ARE GROWN ACROSS ALL
OF OUR CAMPUSES LAST WEEK THE
RATE RANGE FROM ABOUT ZERO
POINT 6% 21% OF THOSE RACING
IMPACTED ROBBING SO I'M VERY.
PLEASED TO SAY THAT WITH THE
GROWING AVAILABILITY OF COMMON
VACCINES WE INTEND TO RESUME IN
PERSON COURSES AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE IN THE FALL. YOU'RE
ALSO MARKED A NATIONAL
RECKONING ON THE ISSUE THAT IS
DEEPLY IMPORTANT TO THE
UNIVERSITY. IT TO ME PERSONALLY
AND PROFESSIONALLY THAT IS THE
IMPACT OF SYSTEMIC RACISM ON
OUR COMMUNITIES. HAVE YOU THE
ROLE OF HIGHER EDUCATION AS AN
EQUALIZER. CREATING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PEOPLE
REGARDLESS OF INCOME LEVEL
LEVEL REGARDLESS OF RACE
REGARDLESS OF GENDER REGARDLESS
OF OTHER FACTORS TO BE
SUCCESSFUL. I KNOW THAT WHEN I
BEGAN MY EDUCATION SCHOOLS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY WERE
SEGREGATED. IN CALIFORNIA THE
MASTER PLAN PROVIDED A CLEAR
WAY FORWARD FOR INDIVIDUALS
LIKE ME WHO OR OTHERWISE HAVE
BEEN EXCLUDED OR OR OR
OTHERWISE HAVE BEEN EXCLUDED.
YEAH I ATTENDED THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA AS A GRADUATE
STUDENT I MAKE COMMITTED-
COMMITTED TO ENSURING THAT
COMMUNITY COLLEGE TRANSFER
STUDENTS LIKE MYSELF ARE ABLE
TO SEEK HIGHER EDUCATION IN A
VARIETY OF- THE FURTHER HIGHER
EDUCATION VARIETY OF
INSTITUTIONS. SUCH AS OURS. IT
IS CERTAINLY- THROUGH INCLUSIVE
AT INCLUSION INCLUDES
ACTIVITIES INCLUSION THAT YOU
SEE WILL CONTINUE TO LIVE UP TO
ITS IDEALS OF ACCESS
AFFORDABILITY AND EXCELLENCE.
I'M ALSO DETERMINED TO
STRENGTHEN OUR RELATIONSHIP IN
COLLABORATION WITH OTHER PUBLIC
HIGHER EDUCATION SEGMENTS IN
CALIFORNIA. THERE IS A
CALIFORNIA IMAGE THREE OUT OF
FOUR TRANSFER STUDENTS TO APPLY
TO YOU SEE FROM THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. AND ROLES
ROUGHLY ONE TRANSFER STUDENT
FOR EVERY TO NADER FRESHMAN. WE
REMAIN COMMITTED TO SUPPORTING
OUR TRANSFER STUDENTS AND A
JOINT UC COMMUNITY COLLEGE TASK
FORCE IS EXAMINING THE
IMPLEMENTATION. OF AN AGREEMENT
TO ENHANCE TRANSFER INCLUDING
SHARING DATA ON STUDENT
ELIGIBILITY AND HOW BEST TO
COMMUNICATE WITH TRANSFER
STUDENTS AND HOW TO MAKE
TRANSFER PATHWAYS EVEN MORE
ACCESSIBLE TO STUDENTS IN THE
FUTURE. UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA
DEGREE PROVIDES ONE OF THE BEST
VALUES IN HIGHER EDUCATION IN
THE COUNTRY. AND IN COMBINATION
WITH THE STATE'S TRULY
EXCELLENT SUPPORT FOR STUDENTS
THROUGH CAL GRANT. YOU SEE ALSO
PROVIDES VERY SIGNIFICANT NEED
BASED FINANCIAL AID FOR UC'S
STUDENTS. I'M COMMITTED TO
REDUCING STUDENT DEBT LEVELS
THROUGH FINANCIAL AID PROGRAMS
AND THROUGH EDUCATIONAL OUTCOME
IMPROVEMENTS. WE SHARE WITH YOU
THE GOAL OF HELPING MORE
STUDENTS GRADUATE IN FOUR YEARS
OR TWO YEARS FOR OUR TRANSFER
STUDENTS. WE'RE PROUD OF OUR
GRADUATION RATES WHICH EXCEED
THOSE OF NEARLY EVERY PUBLIC
UNIVERSITY IN THE COUNTRY. WE
WANT TO CONTINUE TO MAKE
MEASURABLE PROGRESS IN
GRADUATION RATES FOR ALL OF OUR
STUDENTS. LIMITING GAPS IN
DEGREE ATTAINMENT WILL REQUIRE
ADDITIONAL SUSTAIN RESOURCES
AND WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR ON GOING SUPPORT. THE
GOVERNOR'S TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO BUDGET PROPOSAL
SUPPORTS THESE PRIORITIES AND
REVERSES SOME OF THE DEEP CUTS
UC'S SUSTAINED THIS YEAR.
UNIVERSITAS FUNDING REDUCED BY
THREE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
IN THE BUDGET ACT OF TWENTY
TWENTY. THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
BUDGET ACT FOR NEXT YEAR WE'RE
RESTORE ONE THIRD OF THAT
AMOUNT AND THE STATE BANK ONE
THIRD OF THAT ABOUT. STATE
REVENUES EVER COVERED WE
BELIEVE IT IS CRUCIAL TO FULLY
RESTORE THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA'S BUDGET. GIVEN THE
SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES CALL
GOOD IMPOSED ON OUR CURRENT AND
FUTURE STUDENTS. WILL NEED
ACADEMIC AND STUDENT SUPPORT
SERVICES NOW MORE THAN EVER.
ALSO GRATEFUL THAT THE PROPOSED
BUDGET INCLUDES TWELVE POINT
NINE MILLION DOLLARS IN THE UC
PROGRAMS IN MEDICAL EDUCATION
ALSO KNOWN AS PRIME. TO EDUCATE
DOCTORS WHO WILL CARE FOR
PATIENTS AND UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES. YOU SEE WOULD USE
A PORTION OF THESE FUNDS TO
LAUNCH TWO NEW PRIME PROGRAMS.
TO EXPAND MEDICAL EDUCATION.
ONE OF WHICH WILL BE FOCUSED ON
SERVING AMERICAN INDIAN
COMMUNITIES I'M I'M REALLY I'M
HAPPY TO SEE THE PRIME PROGRAM
CONTINUE TO GROW WHEN I WAS
FIRST IN THE OFFICE OF THE
PRESIDENT THE VICE PRESIDENT.
FOR HEALTH PROGRAMS OUT TWENTY
YEARS AGO WE LAUNCHED THE PRIME
PROGRAMMING IT WAS- GREAT- AT A
PHOTOGRAPH OF MYSELF FOR THE
FIRST EIGHT GRADUATES AND WAS
GREAT TO THEN PUT THAT
PHOTOGRAPH NEXT TO A PICTURE
THAT WE TOOK LAST YEAR ON THE
FIFTEENTH ANNIVERSARY. OF OUR
TOGETHER WITH ABOUT TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTY CURRENT PRIME
STUDENTS AND SO WE'RE PROUD OF
HOW WELL THAT'S WORKING AND
LOOKFORWARD TO EXPANDING THAT
PROGRAM. AS WE MOVE FORWARD.
THE BUDGET PROPOSAL ALSO
INCLUDES STUDENT BASIC NEEDS
FUNDING. TO SUPPORT STUDENT
MENTAL HEALTH AND TECHNOLOGY
NEEDS. AS WELL AS PROVIDING ONE
TIME EMERGENCY FINANCIAL AID DO
YOU SEE STUDENTS. A HUNDRED
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLAR ONE
TIME FUNDING AND DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE PROPOSED BY THE
GOVERNOR WILL ALLOW YOU SEE. TO
ADDRESS URGENT ISSUES AND
REDUCE CAMPUS RELIANCE ON THE
ELECTRICAL GRID. I'D LIKE TO
CLOSE. BY SAYING THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA WANTS TO THRIVE
NOT JUST SURVIVE. IN THIS
UNIQUE MOMENT IN OUR STATE'S
HISTORY. SO WE ARE RESPECTFULLY
ASKING THAT YOUR SUPPORT WHAT
THE GOVERNOR'S INTRODUCED.
AUGMENTED WITH FULL RESTORATION
OF THE PRIOR CUTS AND PROVIDE
FUNDS TO ADDRESS UNAVOIDABLE
COST INCREASES SO THE UC CAN DO
OUR PART FOR STUDENTS.
RESEARCHERS JUDGE ARE
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS AND FOR
OUR STATE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR CONTINUED HELP IN
DOING THIS AND THAT CONCLUDES
MY REMARKS MY REMARKS
DISTRIBUTOR. OKAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I'M PRESIDENT I'M A
START WITH MR MEDINA CHAIR OF
OUR ASSEMBLY HIGHER EDUCATION
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND I WANT TO ECHO OUR
CHAIRS- WELCOME TO THE THREE OF
YOU- HERE THIS AFTERNOON WITH
THIS. AND I HAVE A TWO
QUESTIONS- OF BOTH TO UC- VERY
DIFFERENT QUESTION BUT MY
FIRST. TO PRESIDENT DRAKE I
WHEN I FIRST GOT HERE EIGHT
YEARS AGO. TO THE LEGISLATURE I
WAS VERY SURPRISED WHEN I FOUND
OUT. THAT THE FUNDING TO THE
VARIOUS CAMPUSES- SIGN UC'S A
PER STUDENT FUNDING WAS
DIFFERENT- FROM OTHER CAMPUSES
SAY- UCLA. CAL BERKELEY. SO THE
THREE CAMPUSES THAT HAVE BEEN-
ISSUES OF DIFFERENT FUNDING PER
STUDENT ARE UC RIVERSIDE UC
SANTA CRUZ AND UC SANTA BARBARA.
AND- THIS PRE PREVIOUS
PRESIDENT- TOOK ON THE TASK OF-
TRIED TO CHANGE THAT- WITH THE
PRICES KNOWN AS RE BENCHING-
WONDERING IF YOU'RE FAMILIAR
WITH THAT AND- WHAT WE WILL DO
TO CONTINUE TO ADDRESS THE-
INEQUITIES. OF FUNDING.
DIFFERENT CAMPUSES DIFFERENTLY.
WHERE IT HAS TO SAY ABOUT THEM
THEY WERE MEDINA THAT THAT HAVE
A TO SPEAK WITH YOU AND I- I AM
A VERY WITH THE FUNDING STREAM
SUCH THAT WERE AND- PARK AROUND
TO THOUSAND TWELVE THE TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN AND- AND
ACTUALLY HAVE AN UPDATE AS OF
THIS WEEK OF PROGRESS THAT'S
BEEN MADE IN- DOING ALL THAT
CAN BE DONE TO ADDRESS THOSE OF
FUNDING GOT DISPARITIES. MANY
OF WHICH WERE HISTORIC- THEY
OLDER CAMPUSES HAVE BEEN FUNDED
LONGER AND SO THERE'D BEEN A
COMPOUND INTEREST THERE AND THE
OTHERS WERE DUBBED DEPENDENT ON
THE RIGHT RATIO OF DIFFERENT
STUDENTS IN DIFFERENT
CATEGORIES OUT MEDICAL
STUDENTS- PERSONS UNDERGRADUATE
STUDENTS AND I WOULD BE HAPPY
TO GO THROUGH WITH YOU AND IN
DETAIL- OF WHAT HAS HAPPENED IN
THESE LAST SEVERAL YEARS.
YOU'LL SEE THAT NOW THE FUNDING
DISPARITIES FOR UNDERGRADUATES
ON THAT DEPENDING ON THE
UNDERGRADUATE STATUS HAVE BEEN
LARGELY ELIMINATED WE HAVE ON A
GOAL OF HAVING ALL OF THE
CAMPUSES WITHIN 95% OF THE OF
THE MEAN NONE BELOW THE NINETY
FIFTH PERCENTILE AND- AND THAT
WILL BE ACHIEVED I THINK WITHIN
THE NEXT FUNDING CYCLE OR OR SO
AND- SO THERE'S BEEN GREAT
PROGRESS THERE TO MAKE SURE
THEY GET THAT STUDENTS WERE
SUPPORTED APPROPRIATELY. CAMPUS
THE CAMPUS NOT BE HAPPY TO GO-
THROUGH THAT WITH YOU AND IN
GREAT DETAIL BUT I THOUGHT VERY
IMPORTANT PROGRAM THAT'S THAT
WILL CONTINUING. OUT AND WE'RE
COMMITTED TO. THEY YOU AND I
LOOK FOR TO THAT. AND THAT AND
I WOULD JUST ADD. THAT THE-
SHORTFALL OR THE BUDGET GAPS.
THAT ALL THE CAP. ARE FACE.
THOSE THREE. CAP THAT I MET. I
THINK THERE THEY'RE- BUDGET GAP.
EXACT I DO. TWO YOU KNOW THE-
FUNDING SO LOOK FOR TO GETTING
THE IN. THE MICE. QUESTION AND
I HAVE BEEN FOR OF ME THE
ARTICLE IN THE NEW YORK. THE
WEEKEND- HIGHLIGHTED THE WORK
IT USED DAVIS. AND I THINK IT'S
EXAMPLE OR- KIND NOT ONLY TO
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. BUT TO
THE NATION- OF. WHAT OTHER
CAMPUSES COULD BE DOING. AND I
WAS VERY HAPPY TO HEAR IN YOUR
REPORT- RIGHT NOW- THE WORK
THAT YOU SEE IT IRVINE IS
DOING. IS ALSO GIVING THE
VACCINE IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING
THAT. YOU SEE SAN DIEGO HAD
ALSO BEEN IN THE PROCESSES OF-
GIVING VACCINES ON SOME KIND
OF. PERHAPS LIMITED BASIS. IN
IN THE CITY THAT I REPRESENT IN
MY SIXTY FIRST ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT. IN RIVERSIDE IS THERE
ANYTHING. THAT WE CAN DO THAT
THE STATE COULD NOW. TO EXPAND.
ON WHAT THE WORK THE UC DAVIS.
UC IRVINE IS DOING MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT IT YES
YOU ARE. THERE ARE. OVER TWO
HUNDRED STUDENTS- STAFF THAT
HAVE THE ABILITY TO OUR LICENSE
RIGHT NOW. TO GIVE THE VACCINE.
IF THEY HAD THE VACCINE. WHILE
THE CAMPUSES ARE CERTAINLY A
GREAT PLACE TO DO IT- IS THERE
ANYTHING WE CAN DO. HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE. TO EXPAND. IRVINE
AND DAVIS ARE DOING. WELL THE
OTHER THING YOU VERY VERY AND
POINT I THINK IMPORTANT TRY OF
US AND- YOU MENTIONED ARE DAVE
THAT'S YOUR CELL AND STANFORD.
AND GOVERNMENT THE OF THE
CAMPUSES WITHOUT MEDICAL POST.
AND YOU SEE RIVERSIDE HAS GREAT.
TO DO THIS WELL WE AT THE BIG
OR THREE FOURTH. THOUSAND THREE
THAT. VACCINE DOSES A WEEK I
THINK THE NEXT WEEK WE ARE TO
RECEIVE TWENTY THOUSAND THAT'S
DOSES WILL BE A TO GIVE OUT. WE.
EVALUATE ARE. IN BELIEVES WE
CAN GET OUT ABOUT AND TO
THOUSAND BACK DOES. A WEEK WE
HAVE THE STAFF AND PERSONNEL
AND THE TO THAT AND SO WE HAVE
BEEN EVER. BUT THE STATE AND WE
APPRECIATE THE STATE SUPPORT TO
INCREASE THE DOSES THAT WE
RECEIVED WE RECEIVED THOSE
DOSES WHERE THE MOST EFFICIENT
IN THE STATE IN GETTING THOSE
AS WE RECEIVE. P. ARE AND WE'RE
EAGER TO HELP ALL CALIFORNIANS
RECEIVE THIS EXTRAORDINARILY
AND- OUT AS MORE LIKE. BACKS I
I'M SAY THAT- THE STATE HAS
BEEN RESPONSE TO HAVE BEEN
SLOWER THE WE WISH BUT WE
BELIEVE WE'RE GETTING GOOD
COOPERATION YOUR SUPPORT HELP
US DO THAT- BE- VERY WELCOME
AND- WE SAY WE- WOULD LIKE A
HUNDRED TWENTY THOUSAND DOSES
ARE WE- YES TWENTY THOUSAND.
FOR EACH PLACES WITH THAT.
MATTER CENTER AND TWENTIETH
FOUR RIVERSIDE WHERE WE ALL
HAVE A SCHOOL SO THAT THOSE.
THE HUBS FROM WHICH WE WERE.
THE FACTORS AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO DO THAT VERY. PRESIDENT
DRINK EVEN THOUGH USE RIVERS
DOESN'T AN OP HOSPITAL- IT DOES
HAVE YOU SAID THE- SO I YES
VERY MUCH LET THIS- YOU.
RIVERSIDE ON NOT IT'S- THE BILL.
MY NEEDED IN AND OUR WITH THE
COUNTY. SET UP- IT'S- FOR. LOOK
CITY OF RIVERS WAS NOT ONE OF.
SOME PEOPLE HAD TO GO FAR. NOW
THE CITY OF RIVERS. IS OPERATE
BUT YOU SEE RIVERSIDE. X. WHICH
ARE HELP OUR AREA. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ALL SOME ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LEE. I COULD TELL YOU
RIGHT NOW. ACT THAT I AM A
PROUD PRODUCT OF THE UC SYSTEM
OF UC DAVIS IN FACT WHICH AS AN
ASSA QUITE PROUD THIS WEEKEND
OR DURING THE SPEND IRAQ AND I
WANT TO ALSO NOTE THAT I AM THE
CLASS OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN. SO
IF THERE ARE STUDENTS CURRENTLY
WHO ARE ON WHO JUST GRADUATED
TWENTY TWENTY WE'RE ON TRACK TO
GRADUATE TWENTY TWENTY ONE I
OVERLAPPED WITH THEM OR SKINNER
AYE SO I GUESS I DO OVERLAP
WITH THEM AND THAT'S HOW
TRANSFORMATIVE THE
OPPORTUNITIES ARE. AND I REALLY
DO APPRECIATE THE FOCUS AND THE
PRIVATIZATION OF STUDENT BASIC
NEEDS IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
AS WELL AS THAT REFLECT IN YOUR
COMMENTS OF ALL SEGMENT PETERS
BECAUSE I CAN TELL YOU THAT
SENATE BASIC NEEDS HAVE BEEN A
VERY BIG CHALLENGE IN AN ISSUE
THAT STUDENT LEADERS HAVE BEEN
RAISING TO THEIR MINISTRATIONS
EVEN PRIOR TO MY START AS A
STUDENT LEADER UC DAVIS SO I'M
GLAD THAT FINALLY WE'RE GETTING
TRACTION AND ABLE TO DRESS
THOSE NEEDS ON AN ONGOING
BASIS. I HOPE THAT COMMITMENT
STILSON STILL SAY THROUGH WITH
YOUR LEADERSHIP IN ALL YOUR
SEGMENTS TO KEEP PRIORITIZING
THE VOICE OF STUDENTS WHO OFTEN.
ARE TO BE LEYVA AND NOR BECAUSE
THEY CAN LEAD AND GRAB. BUT
ALSO TO LIST TO THAT BIG THESE
ARE THE ISSUES THAT YOU'LL IN.
FROM CHEN SENATE WEATHER FROM
THE GENERATION AFTER. I WITH
WELL THE GENERATION AND MINE.
SO I HOPE THAT THAT. FOCUS WILL
BE ON THERE AND ALSO I DO
APPRECIATE ALL UNIVERSITY AND
COLLEGE SEGMENTS OF HOLDING OFF
ON INCREASING ON TUITIONS AND
FEES ESPECIALLY DURING THESE
CHALLENGING TIMES. I DO HAVE
ONE QUESTION. AND MY ONLY
QUESTION IS ABOUT IF THERE IS A
PLAN. ABOUT RETURNING TO IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION DURING THIS
CALENDAR YEAR AND IF SO- WOULD
YOU BE PROVIDING OPTIONAL.
VIRTUAL VIRTUAL OPTIONS FOR
STUDENTS WHO DO NOT FEEL SAFE
IN ATTENDING. I DON'T KNOW THAT
WE KNOW WHO. WHO GOES FIRST. I
SUPPOSE WHOEVER WANTS TO GO
FIRST CONFIRMED I GUESS I'M
TALKING SO- CAL OKAY GOVERNMENT
OKAY YES I MEAN AREN'T IS HAVE
IN PERSON IN. AS MUCH AS IT'S
POSSIBLE IN THE FALL- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LEE I'LL SAY THAT THE
WHAT WILL DETERMINE THAT IS HOW
EFFECTIVE WE ARE AS A COMMUNITY
AS A NATION IN GETTING VACCINES
INTO THE ARMS OF PEOPLE AS
QUICKLY AS WE CAN. BE CURRENT
PROJECTIONS ARE AT THE CURRENT
RATE THAT WE'RE GETTING
VACCINES WE SHOULD BE ABLE TO
HAVE- THE RESULT FRACTION OF
THE POPULATION VACCINATED BY
THE SUMMER SUCH THAT WE CAN
GET- THE EFFECTIVE ENOUGH FOR
HERD IMMUNITY TO MAKE IT SAFE
FOR US TO RETURN LARGELY. THE
IN PERSON BUT I BELIEVE THAT MY
GET MY COLLEAGUES I KNOW WOULD
SAY THE SAME THING THAT
WHATEVER THE NEW NORMAL IS
GOING TO BE THAT TWENTY TWENTY
ONE IS NOT GOING TO BE TWENTY
NINETEEN AND WE WILL HAVE TO
HAVE A VARIETY OF WAYS THAT WE
PROVIDE. INSTRUCTION IN SERVICE
AND THAT WE KNOW THAT MANY MORE
CLASSES WILL BE HYBRIDIZED
THERE WILL BE A VIRTUAL
OPPORTUNITIES THAT EXCEED THOSE
THAT WERE THE CASE IN THE PAST
WE'LL KNOW MORE ABOUT THIS A
MONTH TWO MONTHS THREE MONTHS
EVEN DOWN THE LINE AS WE SEE
HOW THE VACCINATION PROGRAMS
ARE GOING BUT OUR OUR GOAL IS
TO GET AS MANY PEOPLE
VACCINATED AS POSSIBLE BY THE
SUMMER. TO ADMIT AS MANY PEOPLE
BACK TO OUR CAMPUSES IN THE
FALL INTO HAVE INSTRUCTION IN
PERSON AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE WE
DON'T EXPECT THEY'LL BE AT THE
FULL EXTENT THAT IT WAS A YEAR
AGO SOMEWHERE IN BETWEEN AND
WE'LL LEARN AS WE GO FORWARD
AND ENHANCE THEM WITH VIRTUAL-
AND AN ONLINE EDUCATION IS A
CERTAIN PART. OF OUR FUTURE.
HAPPY TO. HAPPY TO JOIN IN-
CERTAINLY ECHO- PRESIDENT
TRACED COMMA WHAT I WOULD ADD
IS. COMMUNITY THE HUNDRED
SIXTEEN COLLEGE. WE'LL SEE. BE
IN. FORM OF- HYBRID MODE. IT
ALL DEPENDS ON- HOW QUICKLY WE
CAN GET- FACULTY AND STAFF
VACCINATED WHICH IS CRITICAL
FOR ANY RETURN. TO CAMPUS- AND
CERTAINLY OUR OUR ABILITY TO.
SECURE RESOURCES TO PREPARE THE
CAMPUS. FOR A SAFE RETURN FOR
OUR FOR OUR STUDENTS. BUT TO
ANSWER YOUR QUESTION DIRECTLY I
HAVE NO DOUBT IN MY MIND THAT
THEY WILL BE- SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF PROMOTING ONLINE
INSTRUCTION IN THE FALL.
HOWEVER WE ARE PLANNING ON
BRINGING BACK. MANY OF THE
RESOURCES THAT STUDENTS ARE.
TYPICALLY AVAIL THEMSELVES- WE
WILL HAVE. IN PERSON CLASSES
CERTAINLY FOR THOSE. COURSES
THAT SUPPORT THE CENTRAL
INFRASTRUCTURE OF CALIFORNIA-
WELL AND TO THE EXTENT POSSIBLE
WORKING WITH OUR FACULTY AND
OUR CAMPUS LEADERSHIP. BRING
BACK AS MANY COURT CLASSES AS
POSSIBLE. WITHIN A PHYSICAL
DISTANCE SEEN PROTOCOL WHATEVER
THAT LOOKS LIKE. WORKING WITH.
OUR PARTNERS IN THE OTHER
SYSTEMS AND CERTAINLY WITH THE-
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH. I
JUST HAD TO. THE CSU IS ON A
LONG THE SAME LINES- AS THE UC
AND- I ANTICIPATE THAT- THAT
WILL HAVE HOPEFULLY A MAJORITY
OF OUR- PERSON INSTRUCTION ON
THE CAMPUSES THIS FALL. BUT
THAT LITTLE DETERRENT BE
DETERMINED BY THE AVAILABILITY
OF VACCINES AND- OUR STUDENTS
AND FACULTY AND STAFF BEING
INSPIRED TO BE VACCINATED- BUT
THERE WILL BE OPTIONS OF COURSE
ONLINE HYBRID OPTIONS FOR
THOSE. WHO PREFER NOT TO BE ON
CAMPUS AND I DO THINK THIS IS
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO WORK
TOGETHER WITH THE STATE TO-
HAVE A CAMPAIGN TO INSPIRE.
EVERYBODY TO GET VACCINATED AND
I'M HOPING WE CAN WORK TOGETHER
TO DO THAT- IN THE COMING WEEKS
AND MONTHS AND THAT WILL HELP
US TO ACCELERATE OUR RETURN TO
WHAT WOULD BE AT. THE NEW
NORMAL IN THE FALL. GOOD THANK
YOU I'M GLAD THE SEGMENTS ARE
TAKING THESE TAKING
CONSIDERATION AND PLANNING
APPROPRIATELY SINCE THE RETURN
TO CLASSROOMS WOULD MEAN. THE
RETURN OF THE AGE THE AGE
DEMOGRAPHIC WHICH I'M INCLUDED
WHICH IS THE LOWEST PRIORITIZE
ATION VACCINE RIGHT NOW THAT'S
GOOD. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BUT NO THANK YOU FOR REMINDING
US IN NEW GRADUATED COLLEGE
WITH AND- JUST A COUPLE YEARS
AGO I'LL JUST LEAVE IT I'LL
JUST LEAVE IT AT THAT- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RAY YES. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. THE ONE AREA I'D
LIKE TO TALK ABOUT IS EQUITY OR
INEQUITY AND I SINCERELY
APPRECIATE- AS THE NEWEST
MEMBER OF THE SUB TO SUCH AN
IMPORTANT TOPIC- IT'S GOOD TO
SEE CHANCELLOR OAKLEY AFTER.
HEARING ABOUT TWO AND SPEAKING
WITH YOU ON MY COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AS A GRADUATE FROM A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE I. HAVE A
VERY SPECIAL PLACE IN MY HEART
FOR MY COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND
OUR STUDENTS I ALSO AS A AT THE
SOCIO PROFESSOR ENGINE
PROFESSOR AT THE CAL STATE- I
ALSO WILL THINK HIGHLY OF MY
CAL STATES I'M SORRY I HAVE
NOTHING TO SAY ABOUT THE UC'S
EXCEPT THAT THEY ARE WONDERFUL
BECAUSE MY COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LEAGUE GRADUATED FROM.
UC BUT THE ISSUE OF EQUITY AND
INEQUITIES I THINK IS OF GREAT
CONCERN FOR SO MANY OF US AND I
SINCERELY APPRECIATE TO THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL REQUIRING
THAT THESE EQUITY GAPS BE
ADDRESSED- CHANCELLOR OAKLEY
YOU TALKED ABOUT THE FACT THAT
WE NEED ACTIONABLE PLANS TO
CLOSE THE EQUITY GAP. ARE YOU
ALSO TALKED ABOUT THE EQUITABLE
ECONOMIC RECOVERY A CHANCER
CASTRO YOU TALKED ABOUT THE
FACT THAT THE MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED AND
YOU ALSO TALKED ABOUT THE NEEDS
THAT THE FACT THAT WE HAVE A
MORAL IMPERATIVE TO FIX THIS
INEQUITY. AND THEN PRESIDENT
DRAKE YOU TALKED ABOUT HIGHER
EDUCATION BEING THE GREAT
EQUALIZER- AND THE FACT THAT
THAT YOU TALKED ABOUT ACCESS
AFFORDABILITY AND EXCELLENCE SO
MY QUESTION. TO YOU GENTLEMEN
IS. HOW DO SYSTEM. HOW DO EACH
OF YOUR SO PLAN TO. THE ECHO
GAPS IS REQUIRED BY THE%
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL AND DO YOU
HAVE INITIAL THOUGHTS ON BEST
PRACTICES IN THIS AREA. I'M A
BIT IN FIRST STEP AND IT'S
WONDERFUL TO SEE YOU- NUMBER
RACE- SO IN THE CALGARY
COLLEGES THE ISSUE OF EQUITY
IS. OUR NUMBER ONE ISSUE AND
HAS BEEN FOR THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS- AS YOU MAY KNOW- WE
LAUNCHED A CALL TO ACTION LAST
YEAR AFTER THE MURDER OF GEORGE
FLOYD- AND- IN THE VISION FOR
SUCCESS. ONE OF OUR GOALS ARE
MOST IMPORTANT GOAL. IS TO
CLOSE AND ELIMINATE. EQUITY
GAPS NOT ONLY STATEWIDE BUT- IN
REGIONS WHERE WE'VE HAD
STUBBORN VERY STUBBORN EQUITY
GAPS SUCH AS THE REGION THAT
YOU REPRESENT THE INLAND EMPIRE.
SO FOR US IT IS REALLY ABOUT
REINFORCING THEIR COMMITMENT.
IT'S ABOUT SUPPORTING OUR
EFFORT TO DIVERSIFY THE FACULTY-
BECAUSE AND THE STAFF BECAUSE
WE FEEL THAT STUDENTS SEEN
THEMSELVES REPRESENTED ON
CAMPUS AND IN CLASSROOMS IS
IMPORTANT- WE WANT. ALL OF OUR
COMMITTEE BECAUSE DISTRICTS TO
COMMIT TO ELIMINATING EQUITY
CAPS IN THE LEGISLATURE TO
PROVIDE THE SUPPORT THAT WE
NEED IN ORDER TO DO THAT AND TO
HOLD US ACCOUNTABLE FOR THAT
QUITE FRANKLY- WE HAVE
ACCOUNTABILITY STRUCTURE IN
PLACE IT IS NOT AN EASY TASK
BECAUSE CLOSING EQUITY GAPS
MAKE MEANS MAKING VERY
DIFFICULT CHOICES VERY.
COURAGEOUS CHOICES ABOUT HOW
WE- USE THE RESOURCES THAT WE
HAVE. MY MOM AND CERTAINLY-
SUPPORTING OUR SYSTEM PARTNERS
IS IMPORTANT TO EQUITY AS WELL
BECAUSE WE WANT TO SEE MORE OF
OUR STUDENTS TRANSFER. TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM AND THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA OUR FACULTY AND
STAFF ARE DOING. REMARKABLE
WORK AND INCREASING THE NUMBER
OF STUDENTS WHO ARE TRANSFER
RATE- MOST OF THOSE GAINS ARE
WITH- BLACK STUDENTS IN LATIN
EXTRUSIONS AND WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY HAVE ROOM AT THE
CSU AND THE UC SO I THINK
SUPPORTING. OF THOSE EFFORTS
AND- MAKING IT A PRIORITY FOR
OUR STATE. WILL HELP US ENSURE
THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO DRIVE-
THE EQUITY IMPERATIVE TO DOWN
TO THE SYSTEM- IN SUPPORT
CLOSING AND ELIMINATING THOSE
EQUITY GAPS. THANK YOU. HAPPY
TO JUMP AND NEXT TO HER OKAY
WITHOUT PRESENT DRAKE YEAH
ABSOLUTELY OKAY. EMBER HEY S. I
APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR YOUR CALL
AND- WE EMBRACE THE MINDED
APPROACH THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
TAKEN AND HAS BUDGET. AND THERE
ARE AT LEAST TWO WAYS IN WHICH
I VERY MUCH WANT TO FOCUS ON
EQUITY HERE MY FIRST YEAR- THE
FIRST ONE- RELATES TO- THE
EQUITY GAPS THAT EXIST IN OUR-
GRADUATION. RATE DATA UP AND
DOWN STATE AND IT'S MY HOPE
THAT WE CAN GET THOSE GAPS DOWN
TO IS CLOSE TO ZERO AS POSSIBLE
AS WE LEFT UP THE GRADUATION
RATES FOR EACH. OF OUR CAMPUSES
AND- IT'LL BE VERY IMPORTANT
FOR US TO LEARN FROM EACH OTHER
IN THAT PROCESS YOU ASKED ABOUT
HOW THAT COULD BE DONE IN TERMS
OF PRACTICES. AND I DO BELIEVE
THAT AT THE- THERE ARE SO CAMP
THAT. CLOSE THOSE GAPS DOWN TO
ZERO IN A PAL AREA OR IN-
UNDERREPRESENTED STUDENT AREA
AND OTHERS THAT HAVE NOT YET
GOTTEN THERE SO I THINK THERE
IS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO
LEARN TOGETHER- WITHIN OUR
SYSTEM. AND THEN SECONDLY-
PRESENT DRAKE MENTION THIS IN
HIS REMARKS I THINK THERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO WORK
TOGETHER. AROUND DIVERSITY OF
FACULTY AND THINKING ABOUT OUR
OUR PATHWAYS IN PIPELINES AND
CRAPS AND EVEN MORE CREATIVE
THAN A ROBUST WAY AND MY HOPE
IS THAT OVER TIME WE CAN. ADD
TOGETHER ALL OF OUR LEADERS
WORKING TOGETHER CAN DIVERSIFY
OUR FACULTIES SO THAT THEY
BETTER REFLECT THE DIVERSITY OF
OUR STUDENTS- SO THOSE ARE TWO
PARTICULAR WAYS THAT I'D LIKE
TO. FOCUS ON ON EQUITY HERE AND
IN THE FIRST YEAR TO. THANK YOU
MAYBE A COUPLE OF QUICK- THE
FIRM TO DO FINISH UP AND AGAIN.
YOU KNOW LIKE NOW I HAVE WORKED-
DOES. IN TOGETHER THE ISSUE FOR
BOB LITERALLY FOR TODAY. AND WE
ARE BOB TO CAN THAT WORK ACT
TOGETHER AS WE MOVE FORWARD.
WE'VE HAD- THEY ACTUALLY
PARTICULARLY AS WE FOCUS ON
EQUITY GAPS. SPECIFIC PROGRAMS
ON OUR CAMPUSES IN THE NIGHT.
THAT WAS AWAY FROM THE AVERSA
CALIFORNIA FOR THE LAST SIX
YEARS WERE WORKED ON- PROGRAMS
NATIONALLY TO SEE WHAT WE CAN
DO TO ELIMINATE EQUITY GAPS AND
IMPROVE. GRADUATION RATES AND
WE ARE COMMITTED TO CONTINUING
THAT WORK AND WILL CONTINUE TO
PUSH FORWARD TO TRY TO HAVE AN
ELIMINATION OF EQUITY GAPS IN
ALLTHE WAYS THAT THEY THEIR
CURRENT. AND IT'S ACTUALLY WE
THIS IS WHAT I WANT OF CONGRESS
FOR US WE WERE VERY ACTIVE. FOR
THE LAST TEN YEARS OR SO AND
IT'S REALLY QUITE. GRATIFYING
TO SEE THE PROGRESS THAT'S BEEN
MADE FROM SAY TWENTY TEN AND
TILL TODAY ON NARROWING GAPS ON
INCREASING GRADUATION RATES AS
WE INCREASE DIVERSITY AND WE
WANT TO CONTINUE THAT WORK ON
THE IN THE FUTURE AND LOOK VERY
MUCH. FORWARD TO WORKING. WITH
YOU AND HAVING YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU IF I MAY YES. THANK I
THINK THAT. THE THEME ALL. AS
FAR AS I SEE. IS THAT YOU HAVE
TO HAVE A PLAN. AND YOU HAVE TO
BE A- BECAUSE NOT TO HAVE- WHEN
YOU'RE TRYING TO MAKE THOSE.
AND COURAGEOUS DECISION. ABOUT
MO FUND FROM ONE AREA TO
ANOTHER. THOSE ARE COURAGEOUS
DECISIONS THAT HAVE TO BE MADE.
BUT IF THE PLAN IS TO WORK ON
EQUITY. AND IT IS INTENTIONAL I
KNOW WE WILL ACHIEVE IT. SO I
THANK YOU SO MUCH ALL THREE OF
YOU. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
VIA THAT IS. I THANK YOU
PRESIDENT JACOB CHANCELLOR-
CASTRO AND CHANCELLOR OAKLEY I
AM HAVE ACTUALLY BEEN A STUDENT
EACH AND EVERYONE OF YOUR
SYSTEMS AT ONE POINT OR ANOTHER
WE DIDN'T TAKE THE TRADITIONAL
PATH AND I'M GLAD THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT EQUITY. AS MY
PATH WAS DIFFICULT AS A MATTER
OF FACT- BECAUSE OF A TRANSFER
OF UNITS- DIDN'T COMPLETE MY
DEGREE BY A CLASS AND THAT WAS
ALSO THE TIME WE'RE FINE
THERE'S FINANCIAL STRAIN ON MY
FAMILY THERE WAS TRAGEDY. AND
THIS IS WHAT SO MANY STUDENTS
ARE DEALING WITH AT THIS VERY
MOMENT SO I AM A LITTLE CURIOUS
IS THERE ARE CAN WE EXPECT TO
SEE A DROP IN GRADUATION RATES
HOW WHAT ARE WE DOING
SPECIFICALLY TO INTERVENE NOW
TO ENSURE. THAT STUDENTS ARE
COMPLETING THEIR DEGREES- AND I
HAVE A FEW OTHER OTHER
QUESTIONS AS WELL BUT I WOULD
LOVE TO KIND OF JUST GET THE
REAL THE REAL PICTURE THE REAL
NUMBERS THAT WHAT WE THINK WE
MAY BE LOOKING AT. I WILL
START- SINCE THERE'S BEEN A LOT
OF DISCUSSION- IN CALIFORNIA
AND THROUGHOUT THE NATION ABOUT-
COMMITTEE COLLEGE ENROLLMENTS
AND IN THE DROP THERE WE'VE
BEEN SEEN NATIONALLY. THE
BIGGEST ISUE FOR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA
AND THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY. IS
RECOGNIZED IN THE ECONOMIC TOLL
THAT THIS PANDEMIC IS TAKEN ON
THEM. RECOGNIZING THAT SO MANY
OF OUR STUDENTS HAVE TO JUGGLE
MULTIPLE PRIORITIES TRYING TO
FIND WORK MANY OF THEM ARE
HAVING TO WORK IN FRONT LINE
JOBS PUTTING THEIR LIFE AT RISK
IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO PAY FOR
THEIR EDUCATION. I'M HAVING TO.
RAISE THEIR CHILDREN- AND
INSTRUCTION FOR THEIR CHILDREN
DURING THE PANDEMIC SO THE
BIGGEST ISSUE THAT OUR STUDENTS
SPACE IS ECONOMIC SO THAT IS
WHY IT'S SO IMPORTANT FOR US TO
GET AS MUCH EMERGENCY SUPPORT
TO THEM AS POSSIBLE WE'VE-
ADVOCATED FOR THAT AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL. IN THE PREVIOUS-
STIMULUS THE CURRENT SEAMLESS
IN THE PROPOSED MILEST- WE ALSO
ARE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PLAN TO PROVIDE
EMERGENCY AID FOR STUDENTS. A
BEYOND THAT OUR COLLEGES ARE
REACHING OUT TO OUR STUDENTS
TRYING TO FIND WAYS TO SUPPORT
THEM TO HELP THEM CONTINUE TO
STAY IN ROLE. WHILE SOME
STUDENTS HAVE COMPLETELY LEFT
US IN THE NEAR TERM- MANY OF
OUR STUDENTS HAVE JUST TAKEN
LESS CLASSES SO THAT DOES HAVE
AN IMPACT ON THEIR ABILITY TO
COMPLETE THEIR EDUCATIONAL
GOALS. AND WE'RE TRYING TO HELP
THEM TO RECOVER AND THERE ARE
RESOURCES IN THIS GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET TO HELP US REACH OUT TO
THEM AND GET THEM TO CONTINUE
TO STAY IN ROLE TO HELP THEM-
TAKE COURSES NOT JUST THIS
SPRING BUT IN THE SUMMER AND
HELP THEM CATCH UP- AND THEN-
FINALLY. I WOULD SAY THAT- ONE
OF THE BIGGEST CHALLENGES OUR
STUDENTS FACE IS A LACK OF
ACCESS TO BROADBAND. WELL WE'VE
TRIED TO PUT A BANDAID ON THAT
PROVIDED THEM WITH EQUIPMENT
PROVIDE THEM WITH LOW COST
PLANS OR WAR. MY FIGHTS. OUR
STATE DOES HAVE TO DEAL WITH
THIS CHALLENGE. THAT MANY OF
OUR LOW INCOME STUDENTS IN ALL
PARTS OF THE STATE. HAVE VERY
INADEQUATE ACCESS TO BROADBAND
WHICH MAKES IT VERY DIFFICULT
FOR THEM TO CONTINUE TO
PARTICIPATE MEANINGFULLY IN
THEIR INSTRUCTION RIGHT NOW. I
DO HAVE ANOTHER QUESTION IF YES
OF COURSE SO I'M- IT'S THIS IS
MOSTLY FOR- YOU SEE AND UCLA
I'M SORRY. DID I JUST SAY GO
BRUINS DIDN'T DO THAT
INTENTIONAL TODAY. YOU SEE WHAT
END- WELL OKAY PARTICIPATE IN
THE DOOR AND MAY AND PATH. AND
HOW DO SEE S. YOU AND YOU SEE
ENTERED ALLAH THE NEW AND SLOTS.
BETWEEN CAN. WOOD ADMISSION BE
SPECIFIC- ARE LIMITED BY MAJOR.
WE SAW A COUPLE OF- WHAT IS
THAT WE ARE- STILL WE HAD A
MISSION. A FEW YEARS AGO WE'VE
MOVED- THE- THE IT TO BE I DO
WAYS OF AN ALBUM HAND SAYING-
THE ADMISSION OF. STUDENTS BUT
I'M CERTAINLY WILLING LOOK AT
REINSTITUTING THE PATH INTO
WHAT WE CAN DO SO IT THE
SUFFERS WITH THE A WE TO AND-
THE ABILITY OF TO TRY. TO THOSE
YOU. THAT AS YOU MAY HAVE THE
THAT'S- TAKE- AT TRAIN INTO. TO
BE BROUGHT THE COUNTER PROBE
TORE- MAJOR ENTERED. I TIME AND
TO WE CAN TO GET AS MANY OF US
DO TO START FRESHMEN. GRADUATE
INFO YEARS THE GUY NUMBER THAT
WOULD OUR STUDENTS TO PAY
INDUSTRY DON'T. TO BE ABLE TO
GRADUATE IN TWO YEARS CAMPUS
TO. CAN PASS FOR MAY THE PEN ON
A PER OF THINGS. AND SO THEY'RE
THE SOMETHING THAT WE IS OUR
CAMPUS CAMPUS- I DECISION OR
MAYBE ONLY A CERTAIN NUMBER OF
AND FOR. AND LABS THAT WANT FOR
ANOTHER AND SO THE PEN ON THE
MAJOR THE ONE IS LOOKING. THAT
AND DIFFERENT HAVE DIFFERENT.
THERE'S CERTAIN ALL THE DON'T
HAVE THE MAJORS THEY OFFER
SORRY ARE OUR GOAL REALLY IS TO
GO THE NUMBER OF OPERA FOR
STUDENTS. THE ALTHOUGH WE UNDER
THAT THERE ARE CAMPUS THE
CAMPERS. THANK A MEMBER MAY I
AM A ANSWER EARLIER QUESTION
I'M SORRY JUMP BEFORE YOU ASK
THE ONE- ABOUT THE CHALLENGES.
FACING OUR STE. AND WHAT I CAN
SAY YOU IS THAT- SO FAR- WE HAD
A HIGHER. RATES THAN WE HAD
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC AND THAT'S
A GOOD THING- BUT I AM
CONCERNED ABOUT THE STRESS THAT
EVERYBODY IS EXPERIENCING RIGHT
NOW AND- I DO APPRECIATE THE
INVESTMENT AND BASIC NEEDS AND-
AND SUPPORT FOR OUR STUDENTS-
CHAIRMAN. IS GONNA CARRY A BILL
THAT WOULD CALL FOR ADDITIONAL
MENTAL HEALTH FUNDING FOR
EXAMPLE I DO THINK THAT THERE
ARE WAYS IN WHICH WE CAN.
BETTER SUPPORT OUR STUDENTS SO
THAT THEY CAN CONTINUE TO BE
SUCCESSFUL DURING THE PANDEMIC
AND AFTER THE PANDEMIC. MAYBE
IT FORGIVE ME I'VE GOTTEN AND I
COULD INTRODUCE THEM A BIT TO
THAT AS WELL THERE'S THE
FOLLOWING. CASH AND YOU KNOW
THE SEARCH FOR ALL OF US ARE
ARE THAT THE ARE DIFFERENT. I
WILL SAY FOR US. THAT THAT WE
HAVE DUG ARE GREAT ENROLLMENT
THIS FALL THEN WE DO IN- THE
PAST WE HAD AN INCREASE IN CAL.
STUDENTS WHO ENROLLED THAN US
MADE UP OF IN SOME OF THE-
ANOTHER STUDENT. AND- BUT WE
HAD A AND IN CAL STUDENTS SO
THAT WAS A INCREASE ENROLLMENT
AND WE'VE SEEN. INCREASE IN OUR
APPLE- THIS YOU CAN. ABOUT THE
LACK YEAR ACTUALLY THE- AB
FIFTEEN OR SO PERCENT AND
ACROSS. INCREASE IN WITHIN.
WE'RE PLEASED TO SEE THAT WE
HAD BEEN IN. OF ABOUT 21%
AFRICAN. APPLICATIONS INCREASE
IN ABOUT 12% AND A DINO
APPLICATIONS AN INCREASE OF 5%
IN TRANSFER APPLICATION SO ALL
OF THOSE GROUPS THAT HAVE
APPLIED. IN IN GREATER NUMBERS
AND ARE GRADUATION RATES AND
RETENTION RATES ARE. AT ALL
TIME HIGHS SO THAT THE WORK OF
FOCUSING ON AND HONESTLY. ONE
OF THE WAYS THAT WE'RE ABLE TO
DO THAT- IS. TO REALLY FOCUS ON
THE ECHO AND- GAPS THAT WE HAVE.
OF THE AS ARE STILL ARE ABLE TO
GRAB. GOT MORE THAT THAT LEVELS
MORE CONSIST WITH THE HIVE
GRADUATE RATES WE'RE SEEING IN
THE PAST. AS WE WILL ELIMINATED
THOSE EQUITY GAPS WE GET LARGER
NUMBERS OF STUDENTS. GRADUATING
BEING SUCCESSFUL THAT THERE
REQUIRES A- THE CONTINUAL
INVESTMENT IN STUDENTS AND
STUDENT SUCCESS. AND I ECHO
MIKE MIKE MY COLLEAGUES THAT
THE STUDENT NEEDS THOSE
STUDENTS SUPPORT THOSE THINGS
ARE INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT. AS WE
HAVE A DIVERSE STUDENT BODY
AGAIN WITH WITH US THE MOST
DIVERSE STUDENT BODY THAT WE'VE
HAD. IN OUR HISTORY AND TO WORK
ON HELPING ALL OF THOSE
STUDENTS CONTINUE TO MOVE
FORWARD WE HAVE TO BE.
THOUGHTFUL ABOUT THEIR THEIR
BASIC NEEDS AND IN PARTICULAR
JUDGE LOCALS COMMENTS I THINK
ARE SO IMPORTANT THAT IS THAT.
THE CIRCUMSTANCES THAT EOPLE
FIND IN THEMSELVES IN IN THE
WORLD. ARE CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
TO THEIR ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO
SUCCEED WHEN THEY'RE INVOLVED
IN HIGHER EDUCATION AND- WE
HAVE TO MAKE SURE OUR LENDS
OPEN WIDE ENOUGH TO UNDERSTAND.
THAT WE GET HOLD PEOPLE THAT
SUPPORTING THEM- THROUGH HIGHER
EDUCATION MEANS BEING ABLE TO
SUPPORT THE NEEDS THAT. THEY
HAVE POPPED OUT FROM THE REAL
WORLD. THANK YOU. OKAY THANK
YOU S. MEMBER. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER CHAIR. ALSO WANNA
EXTEND BY WELCOME TO. PRESIDENT
REAGAN CHANCE FOR CASTRO I WAS
JUST REFLECTING ON THE OUTGOING
MESSAGES OF YOUR TWO
PREDECESSORS AND I THINK IT-
REMINDED ME OF THE WORK THAT
THE LEGISLATURE WAS ABLE TO DO
WITH EACH OF YOUR TWO
PREDECESSORS- WHEN PRESIDENT
POTONG L. DECIDED TO RETIRE.
SHE TALKED ABOUT THE
SIGNIFICANT UP KEY INCENTIVES
THE SIGNIFICANT UPTICK. IN
STATE CALIFORNIA STUDENT
ENROLLMENT OVER HER TENURE AND
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE WORKED
WITH HER SPECIFICALLY IN VERY
CLOSELY ON AND WE WERE VERY
PROUD TO DO THAT- WHEN. CSU
CHANCELLOR LIGHTLY HE ABOUT TE
IMPROVEMENT OR A D. GOALS TO
IMPROVE THE FOUR YEAR IN THE
SIX YEAR GRADUATION RATE
OBVIOUSLY THAT CONTINUE TO BE A
FOCUS OF WHAT WE WANT TO WORK
ON- WITH WITH THE CSU AND
OBVIOUSLY- CHANCELLOR OAKLEY
IS- SORT OF NOW THERE'S THE
SENIOR PERSON BETWEEN THE THREE
OF YOU AND WE CONTINUE TO. MAKE
HIS ALL BUT WILL NOT NOT NOT TO
PARTICIPATE BUT IN TERMS OF
TRYING- WE WILL TALK ABOUT A-
IN THIS FOR- SO IT IS YOU KNOW
IT A REMINDER FOR US BECAUSE
THEY WANT TO BE VERY SO. OF BOB
THE COMMUNIQU WE OFTEN I ALWAYS
THAT THERE THE REAL BACKBONE
ABOUT HIGH AVERAGE SYSTEM AND
FOR. AS AS YOU SEE IS. R. I.
IT'S A THE KEY CALL THAT SET
THIS APART FROM THAT IT THE
REALLY A- HIGHER EDUCATION
SYSTEM THAT IS- BUT BUT GOING
TO. THE ISSUE AROUND A ROLL IN
MISSION THAT YOU THINK WE'RE
ALL TO ABOUT A LITTLE BIT LIKE
TO START CHESTER DRAKE. I'M ONE
OF THE ISSUES THAT WE LIKE
AGAIN WE WERE A PRESS APOLLO ON
HIS TRY TO IN. OUR THE
PERCENTAGE OF. IN STATE IN ROME
AS AS YOU MAY WERE THE PROBABLY
ABOUT THE TIME WHEN OU LEFT
OHIO. ON IN STATE ENROLLMENT
ACROSS THE SYSTEM PILOTED FIVE
TEN PER. AND NOW. BECAUSE BAD.
THE LET'S AND YOU SEE IT'S A
18% AND WHILE THAT ET PERCENT
FOR AS A CAP WITH WE DIFFER
DIDN'T- WANTED TO SEE AS A
ASPER GOAL BEFORE MANY OF THE-
UNITS CENTER SYSTEM THAT WERE
ON. THAT OVERALL CAN SAW AS A
GO RATHER THAN- AS THAT TO BE
CAUGHT. SO ON. IN IN YOUR MIND-
SORT OF NEEDS TO BE. TO REPAIR.
.COM LORD YOU KNOW SHOULD BE
BADGE BUT WHAT HE'S BE DONE TO
BADGE. SO THAT CAN GET TO-
INSURE ACCESS FOR CAL HAS
STUDENTS. I THANK YOU VERY
PROBABLY. MENTION THE TO ONE-
SORT OF- FRESH TO TRANSFER
RATIO WHICH THE LEDGES. TO
GOVERNOR BROWN. ALSO BUT YOU
KNOW TO TELL US HOW WE CAN.
ENSURE ACCESS A FOR
CALIFORNIANS YOURS LIKE MICHAEL
OF US AROUND THE TABLE- TO. THE
UNIVERSITY CAL. WELL THANK VERY
MUCH NUMBER TWO YOU KNOW THE-
WHAT ARE INTERESTED BEEN AND
WHAT HAPPENED OVER THESE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS HAS BEEN. THE
NUMBER OF THAT WE HAVE A BIG
FOR K. STUDENTS HAVE CONTINUE
TO IN. AND SO WE LIKE BEING
MORE EFFICIENT WOULD LIKE OF
BEING ABLE TO HAVE OUR CAPACITY
GROW SO THAT WE CAN EDUCATE
MORE CALIFORNIA STUDENTS I KNOW
THAT- SINCE I LEFT THERE WAS AN
INCREASE IN THE NUMBER OF
NONRESIDENT STUDENTS AS AS WELL
BUT- IT WASN'T NON RESIDENT
STUDENTS VERSUS CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS THAT WAS THAT. BOTH
GROUPS- INCREASED AND OUR GOAL
IS TO CONTINUE TO MEET OUR IN
ROLE MODELS IN FACT I KNOW WE
HAVE A EXCEEDED OUR GUARD FOR
NEW- DODD STUDENTS OVER THE
LAST. LAST YOUR THEN WE WANT TO
GET. OUT TO SUPPORT CAL STILL
GROW. AND OTHER THING THE I
LIKE THINK WE WANT TO DO THAT
REALLY IN AND THAT WE WORKED ON.
HERE BEFORE I LEFT- OF IT AND
MY TIME THAT DOOR AND THEN WELL
IT WHILE I WAS GONE AND THAT WE
SAW WE SAW GREAT PROGRESS WAS A-
TIME TO. AND BY IN TIME
2 DEGREES WITHOUT. MAKING THE
FILM PLANT LOW MORE RIGHT TO
COME BE A- AND LEAVES- WITH
THEIR DEGREE AND WE HAVE A
VARIETY OF PROGRAMS- THAT ARE
UNDER WAY THAT WE'VE BEEN
PARTICIPATING IN THAT HELP
STUDENTS TO GET THEIR DEGREES
ON TIME. INCREASE THEIR
GRADUATION RATES AND SHORTENING
TIME DEGREE WHICH AGAIN ALLOW
FOR MORE STUDENTS TO BE TO BE
EDUCATED. I SAY ALSO THAT AS WE
MOVE TO BE MORE IN LINE WHICH
IS REASSURING MOTOR MORE ONLINE
EDUCATION MORE TECHNOLOGY
ENHANCED EDUCATION WE ALSO
BELIEVE THAT THAT CAN HELP TO
SMOOTH THE PATHWAY TO A DEGREE
AND WE WANT TO. BE A MORE
EFFICIENT SYSTEM IN AND IN
THOSE WAYS AS AS WELL AND THEN
CONTINUE TO GROW. SO YOU YOU
ASK HOW YOU CAN HELP IN THE
WAYS THAT YOU'VE HELPED IN THE
PAST BY HELPING SUPPORT US IN
SUPPORTING OUR GUARD CORPS
BUDGET. ALLOWS US TO HAVE THE
FACT THAT THE ALLOW US TO HELP
THE- AND THE SUPPORTED TECH FOR
US TO COME THE CLASS. GRADUATE
AND OUT THERE AND- THERE WILL
FOR INSTEAD. AND SOME OUR CAN.
LET ME SAY ALSO THE- ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE SAW AT. IN IN.
IS OKAY SUCCESS IN THE-
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND GREAT
SUCCESS AT THE K. THE YOU.
SYSTEM IN. UP FOR TO STOP
IMPROVING THE ISSUE PARTICULAR
HAD WAS AMONG THE BEST IN THE
COUNTRY. GRADUATION RATES AND
SO WE SEE ALL THESE AS AS-
WORKING TOGETHER TO MAKE THEIR
MAKE BETTER OPPORTUNITIES FOR
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS TO BE ABLE
TO COME TO. GET AN EDUCATION
AND MOVE OUT INTO THE WORK
FORCE AND THE REST OF THEIR
LIVES. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THAT RESPONSE TO ME JUST FOLLOW
UP WITH A FEW. QUESTIONS AND A
COUPLE COMMENTS SO- US HOW WE
CAN SUPPORT THE UNIVERSITY AND-
WE COULD. FIRST AND FOREMOST-
BY INCREASING THE- BUDGET-
AUGMENTATION WHICH I THINK IS
FINE. DURING MY TENURE IN THE
LEGISLATURE WHICH STARTED- THE
END OF TWENTY TWELVE WE HAVE
INCREASED OUR EXCEPT FOR LAST
YEAR WAS THE FIRST TIME.
INCREASE UC'S BUDGET EVERY
SINGLE YEAR- BUT DURING THAT
TIME WE DIDN'T SEE. THE
CORRESPONDING INCREASE IN IN
STATE ENROLLMENT IN FACT WE
SAW. IN STATE ENROLLMENT IN
SOME YEARS DECLINE AND THIS IS
ALL DURING YOUR- TIME THAT YOU
WERE GONE- AND UNFORTUNATELY.
AT THE THREE CAMPUSES THAT WERE
THE MOST COMPETITIVE- SAN DIEGO
BERKELEY AND UCLA. WE'VE SEEN.
HOW OF STATE ENROLLMENT
SKYROCKETED TO THE POINT I
THINK IT'S AROUND 23224% I
FORGET EXACTLY ROUGHLY- ON.
WHERE THAT IS TO WHILE. I'M
WITH. SOME RESPECTFULLY DOES
JUST CAN DISAGREE WITH YOUR
STAY THAT. WATER WASN'T COME.
TO NON RESIDENT IN RESIDENT
BECAUSE AT THE THEY'RE VERY
MUCH WHAT- COMPETITION. AND
UNFORTUNATELY. LOST ON CONSOLE.
LET ME JUST DIRECTLY DO YOU.
THE EIGHTEEN PER. SHOULD COME
DOWN. YOU SAID I THINK YOU
SAYING DISAGREE YOU STARTED
WITH RESPECTFUL I THINK THEY
YOU WOULD HAVE BEEN THERE LIKE
TO- SO ME SAY THAT THAT I THE
BEST YE I KNOW WHAT HAVE THAT
YOU SEE IRVINE TO I LAW. IN
THOSE YEARS AND I KNOW THAN
WHAT HAPPENED THE YEARS THAT I
WAS AND IN THE PLACES- YES
THERE WAS A INCREASE IN. OUT OF
STATE OR NON READ STUDENTS BUT
THERE WAS OF COURSE AGREE AND
IN IN STATE- US THROUGH AND SO
THE OVERALL. EXPERIENCE THAT I
HAVE DIRECT AND I'M FROM. OVER
LOOK BACK TO THE THINGS I READ
SOME YEAH THAT WAS A DIFFERENT
PLAY OF THE OVERALL- CAL STOOD
HERE AND SO BUT THAT I YOUR
PROBABLY GO FROM ABOUT IT CAN
NOT COULDN'T I COULD SAY THAT.
I THINK THAT THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING IS THAT WE CREATE OUR FOR
K. TO. AND THAT WE KEEP OUR
UNIVERSE AS ACT AS CAN CAN BE A-
I THINK THAT IT'S A WE'VE HAD A
BY PROGRAM UP IN. AS WE
INCREASING AGAIN THE PLACE
WHERE I BEEN RESPONSIBLE WE
INCREASE AS- THE IN STATE
STUDENTS MORE- THERE AND-
THAT'S WE'VE HAD OTHER STUDENTS
COME INTO THE UNIT. OVERALL
LARGER AND THAT SOME THAT I
COMMIT TO- I MEAN I THINK
THAT'S NOT- AND IT THANKS-
SENATE JUST USED TO BE SO THAT
WE COULD INCREASE. MORE SLOTS
FOR CALIFORNIANS. WELL IT'S A
COMPLICATED QUESTION AS YOU OF
COURSE THOUGH AND LET ME SAY
THIS THAT'S HAPPENED IN MY
AGAIN MY EXPERIENCE. THE- OVER
THE LAST MANY YEARS AND YOU
KNOW THIS IS BEEN A NATIONAL
NATIONAL TREND- AS BUDGETS WERE
DODD DECREASED BY UNIVERSITY
FOR TRYING TO MAINTAIN THE
FACULTY STUDENT RATIO IS THE
NUMBER OF CLASSES THAT STUDENTS
NEEDED TO IN- TO HAVE TO BE
ABLE TO GRADUATE ON TIME AND
THERE WERE- AND THEY FOUND THAT
ONE OF THE WAYS TO DO THAT WAS
TO DIVERSIFY AT THE POOL OF
STUDENTS WHO CAME IN PARTICULAR
THOSE ARE BROUGHT IN FUNDING
FROM OUT OF STATE. AND WHAT
HAPPENED AGAIN I USE MY OWN-
EXPERIENCE THERE. WHAT WE SAW
IS THAT IS WE HAD STUDENTS WHO
CAME IN FROM. OTHER PLACES OUT
OF STATE AND INTERNATIONAL.
THERE WERE EDUCATIONAL BENEFITS
TO THE STUDENTS WHO WERE IN.
THE CLASSES I. TEACH CLASSES
AND WEED OUT OF BENEFIT
EDUCATIONALLY FROM PEOPLE FROM
DIFFERENT. PERSPECTIVES COMING
IN. BUT TO YOUR POINT PROP
AVERAGES FOR CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS THOSE STUDENTS TENDED
TO BRING IN MORE FUNDING- THEN
THEY ARE COST. AND THEY
ACTUALLY WOULD INCREASE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR OUR IN STATE
STUDENTS AS- AS WELL SO. IF WE
WERE A FREEWAY AND WE HAD THREE
LANES AND WE HAD THEN- LANE-
THAT WAS STUDENTS COMING FROM
OTHER PLACES. IT WASN'T WE WENT
FROM A THREE LANE. FREEWAY TO A
FOUR LANE WENT FROM THREE LANES
TO FIVE LANES. AND SO WE HAD
MORE LANES FOR IN STATE
RESIDENTS. AT THE SAME TIME
THAT WE HAD OTHER STUDENTS
COMING IN AND- IT WAS THE WAY
THAT WE ACTUALLY BY THE WAY
THAT WE ACTUALLY HAVE THE
FACULTY TO HAVE. MORE
OPPORTUNITY FOR IN STATE
STUDENTS SO. I WILL I'M HAPPY
TO TALK AS WE CAN TALK MORE OFF
LINE ABOUT WHAT THE- THE PROPER
BALANCE IS AND- THAT'S
SOMETHING ABOUT THE PICK MORE
REFLECTION BUT- MAILLET. WHAT
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO DO WAS TO
HAPPEN INCREASED AGAIN CREATION
OPPORTUNITIES- FOR STUDENTS
FROM BE IN STATE POPULATION. AS
WE CREATE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
OTHER STUDENTS AS AS WELL AND
AGAIN SOMETHING I'M I'M HAPPY
TO TALK. WITH YOU ABOUT IT IN
MORE IN MORE DETAIL RIGHT BUT-
WITH ALL. DUE RESPECT PRESIDENT
DRAKE DURING DURING THAT TIME
JUST TO. CLARIFY UC DIDN'T SEE
A DECREASE. IN STATE STUDENT
FUNDING AT LEAST FOR THE LAST
EIGHT YEARS THIS ON INCREASE
EVERY SINGLE YEAR. IN AND AGAIN
OUR PROBLEM WAS INTEL WE-
INTERCEDED AND FORCED.
PRESIDENT APOLLO TONNEAU TO
INCREASE IN STUDENT ENROLLMENT
IT UNFORTUNATELY DID NOT HAPPEN
ON ITS OWN EVEN THOUGH. THE
UNIVERSITY WAS GETTING
COMMENSURATE BUDGET. INCREASES
SUCH THAT IS. PART OF THE CRUX.
OF THE PROBLEM AND FOR. I THINK
ON. GET- YOU YOU BROKE DOWN THE
PROBLEM VERY VERY BECAUSE- VERY
SIMPLY COULD SIMPLY ABOUT
MONEY- THE OUT OF STATE
STUDENTS BRING IN MONEY. THAT
THE STATE STUDENTS DON'T. AND
THERE IS A FINANCIAL
PROPOSITION AND I THINK WE HAVE.
IN THE PAST PASSED THE
UNIVERSITY TO PROVIDE-
INFORMATION OF WHAT IT WOULD
TAKE TO- BY THE OUT OF STATE
STUDENTS OUT AND I THINK WE
CONTINUE TO WATER PURSUE THAT-
I THINK THAT QUESTION I DON'T
THINK THE STATE IS ANYWAYS.
ASKING THE UNIVERSITY TO TAKE A
LOSS ON ACCEPTING MORE IN STATE
STUDENTS BUT I THINK WE ARE
WANTING TO HAVE A REALISTIC-
ON. A REALISTIC DISCUSSION- HI
I WILL SAY THIS- PUBLICLY
BECAUSE THIS IS WHAT HIGH I DO
BELIEVE- AND I THINK PART OF IT
IS BECAUSE OF THE RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN THE PRESIDENT'S OFFICE
AND THE TEN. CAMPUS US. ON THAT
I DO BELIEVE THAT THE REASON
THIS NUMBER HASN'T GONE DOWN IS
BECAUSE THE CHANCELLOR'S WANTED
THEIR FINANCIAL FREEDOM FROM
THE PRESIDENT'S OFFICE. AND
IT'S ONE OF THE ONLY PLACES FOR
FINANCIAL INDEPENDENCE- IN FACT
THE ONLY THING THAT REALLY GREW
SIGNIFICANTLY IN TERMS OF
BUDGET AT THE UNIVERSITY WHAT
IS YOUR OFFICE. THAT'S WHAT WE
SAW THE BIGGEST INCREASE DURING
MY- SORT OF EIGHT YEARS
LEGISLATURE WAS WE SAW AN
EXPLOSION. IN THE PRESIDENT'S
OFFICE WITH- ZERO IMPACT ON
STUDENTS OR FACULTY- SO AGAIN
MARK MY HOPE IS THAT HE'LL TAKE
A HARD LOOK AT. FIGURE OUT HOW
YOUR OFFICE CAN BETTER SERVE
ON. THE DIFFERENT TEN CAMPUSES
OR OTHER DOT ORG ITSELF IS FOR
FIND A WAY TO SUPPORT. THE TEN
CAMPUSES SO THAT WE COULD.
REALLY CONTINUE TO. ON ON. FOR
HOW BEST SERVE YOU KNOW YOUR
STUDENTS YOUR FACULTY OR STAFF.
ON IT I DON'T NONE OF THESE ARE
ISSUES THAT YOU BROUGHT FOR
SAKE I DO WANT TO BE CAREFUL
YOU KNOW CLARIFY. THESE ARE ALL
ISSUES THAT WE HAD DISCUSSED
WITH YOUR WITH YOUR PREDECESSOR
AND I KNOW THAT. YOU HAVE
BROUGHT- SORT OF A WHOLE NEW.
MIND SET BUT WE REALLY DO URGE
YOU AS YOU EMBARK ON YOUR YOUR
TEN YER TO REALLY TAKE A HARD
LOOK AT MANY OF THESE. ARE VERY
VERY SPECIFIC ISSUES THAT HAVE
BEEN DISCUSSED AND I DO WANT
TO. DISCUSS THEM IN A PUBLIC
FORUM BECAUSE THEY HAVE BEEN
DISCUSSED IN A PUBLIC FORUM IN
THE PAST. ARMED SO TO THE LAST
QUESTION. GO AHEAD PLEASE JUST
COME IN JUST TO SAY SOMETHING I
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
THAT WE'RE CLOSE THE FIRST I
HEAR CLEARLY WHAT YOU'RE SAYING
AND I. APPRECIATE THAT. AND I
WILL SAY AGAIN THAT MY- I MET
AT MY OWN LIVED EXPERIENCES
THAT WE WORKED TO AND HAD TO DO
JUST THOSE THINGS THAT WE WORK
ACTUALLY TO- USE THAT INCREASE
FUNDING. AT THE CAMPUSES THAT I
WAS RESPONSIBLE FOR TO ADDRESS
THE INTEREST THAT THAT THAT YOU
MENTIONED. AND I YOU KNOW I
YEAH. I WOULD NOT SAY NOTHING
ABOUT MY ANY OF MY- ESTEEMED
PREDECESSORS. IF MY- CAMPUSES
DON'T THINK THAT I ENHANCE
THEIR ABILITY TO SERVE THEIR
THEIR- STUDENTS THEN WE'LL DO
SOMETHING DIFFERENT I'M I'M
THERE'S NO WE'RE HERE. I BY
CAME BACK TO BE THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
FOR THE PURPOSE OF ENHANCING
THE WORK AT THE UNIVERSITY DOES
THE OFFICE IS NOT THE- THE
OFFICES THE FACILITY- BUT THE
WORK IS REALLY THE WORK OF THE
FACULTY AND THE STUDENTS. AND
WORKING WITH THE CHANCELLOR FOR
THAT AND OF THE CHANCELLOR'S
UNDERSTATE THE CHAPTERS WOULD
FEEL THAT THERE'S A COMPETITION
BETWEEN THE WORK THAT I'M DOING
AND WHAT THEY'RE DOING IF THEY
DIDN'T FEEL THAT I WAS A-
PARTNER. AT HELPING THEM TO DO
THAT THEN I WOULD. SAY THAT WE
SHOULD MAKE A DIFFERENT.
ARRANGEMENT BUT I WOULD I
WOULD- HOPE THAT THE FEEL THAT
THAT'S THE CASE. YOU ARE WHAT
WE'RE TO BE DOING GOING FOR
THEN WE- REALLY DO I THINK THE
SAME. INTERESTS IN MIND AND
WANT TO PARTNER WITH YOU IN IN
DOING THAT AND- SO THAT'S
THAT'S THE MINDSET THAT WE
BROUGHT. THAT'S WHY WE'RE HERE
THAT'S WHAT WE EXPECT TO DO AND
I WOULD LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU ON THAT. I WOULD JUST
READ I THINK THAT'S WHY YOU'RE
THE- FRANKLY THE PERFECT PERSON
FOR THE JOB AT THIS PARTICULAR
TIME AND YOUR EXPERIENCE THAT
YOU SEE THAT STAFF. YOUR BEING-
A FORMER CHANCELLOR UC IRVINE
BUT ALSO YOUR YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE WITH IN THE OFFICE
OF THE PRESIDENT- YOU KNOW I
KNOW FOR A FACT THAT- YOU KNOW
I PERSONALLY. WAS VERY EXCITED
WHEN YOU WERE HIRED BECAUSE I
THINK- ONE I WAS EXCITED THAT
WE FINALLY HAVE A YOU SEE
PRISON RUNNING YOU SEE AGAIN.
AND THAT'S NOT AS A AS A
PRODUCT OF YOU SEE THAT MAKES
ME VERY PROUD. BUT ALSO THE
FACT THAT. YOU UNDERSTAND WHAT
IT'S LIKE AT THE CAMPUS LEVEL
AND AT THE FACULTY LEVEL AND I
THINK- IN MY OPINION THAT'S
SORT OF WHAT'S BEEN MISSING. IS
HIS NOT SENSITIVITY TO REALLY
WHAT HAPPENS. IN THE CLASSROOM.
AT THE CAMPUSES I HAVE BEEN SO
IMPRESSED BY. YOUR ATTENTION
EXERCISE I DON'T AS I KNOW YOU
ARE BECAUSE THE THOSE WERE YOU
ALL YOUR FORMER COLLEAGUES. ON
SORT OF HOW WELL THEY EACH
KNOW. THEIR CONSTITUENTS WITH
THERE'S THE FACULTY WHETHER TO
STAFF WHETHER TO STUDENTS WAS
THERE'S A COMMUNITY. AND REALLY
HOW BIG A JOB THEY HAVE AND SO
I REALLY APPRECIATE THE FACT
THAT YOU. DECIDED NOT TO RETIRE
AND TO COME DO THIS FINAL JOB
IN TO COME BACK TO CALIFORNIA
INTO THIS SO I DO. I DO REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT I WANTED TO
JUST ASK ONE QUICK QUESTION
ABOUT THE FACULTY DIVERSITY AND.
AND KIND OF FOLLOW UP WITH THE
OTHER SEGMENTS WHICH IS- YOU
KNOW WE DID A FEW. A FEW SMALL
GRANTS. TO THE UNIVERSITY DO
YOU SEE AROUND. DIVERSITY IT
SEEMS LIKE THEY'VE GONE QUITE
WELL. I DO HAVE TO STAY IN AND-
YOU KNOW THIRTY PLUS YEARS
SINCE I GRADUATE I DIDN'T
GRADUATE IN. TWENTY SEVENTEEN.
YOU KNOW I GRADUATED IN
NINETEEN NINETY TWO. AND SO- MY
ONE OF MY BIGGEST
DISAPPOINTMENTS WAS GOING BACK
AND LOOKING. IN SINGLE FRANKLY
A LOT OF MY CLASSMATES WHO GOT
PHD IS WHO WANTED TO PURSUE.
FACULTY POSITIONS BUT REALLY TO
SEE HOW. LITTLE THE RACIAL
COMPOSITION OF THE FACULTY AT
UC NOT GET TO SEE A FEW AND A
CSU. HAD CHANGED AND- YOU KNOW
CAN YOU CAN YOU GIVE ME A SENSE
OF REALLY WHAT WE CAN DO THAT
KIND OF SUPPORT. THAT YOUR
EFFORTS FOR GREATER- FACULTY
REPRESENTATION. WELL YEAH I
APPRECIATE VERY MUCH YOUR
INTEREST AND- AGAIN YOU KNOW I
HAVE A SHARED EXPERIENCE YOU
KNOW AND ROGER WAITING FROM
UNIVERSITY AND THEN SEEING
GOSH- THERE'S CHANGE BUT IT'S
AWFULLY SLOW MUCH SLOWER THAN
WE- WE WANTED I KNOW WHEN I.
FINISHED I GRADUATED UNIVERSITY
IN STATE ON FACULTY AND I.
EXPECT THE BILL THIS WOULD BE
AND I WAS ALWAYS- FORGIVE ME
FOR BEING A LITTLE PERSONAL AND
ALL THIS IS TRUE FROM AGAIN
MIKE MY COLLEAGUES JENNIFER
OAKLEY AND- THAT CHANCELLOR
CASTRO. IS THAT WE WERE OFTEN
THE FIRST TO DO THIS FOR THE
FIRST TO DO THAT YOU KNOW T
WAS ALWAYS KIND OF BREAKING A
THERE. FOR THESE FOR DECADES
IT'S ALWAYS THAT YOU EVERY STEP
YOU YOU TAKE. AND I ALWAYS
THOUGHT THAT WELL THAT'S GREAT
IT'S GOING TO BE LIKE THEM THE
WAY CAME BACK OF A BOAT ON A
LAKE WHERE. YOU MIGHT BE FIRST
BUT THEN THE- THE- THE- EFFECT
IN BACK OF YOU WOULD GET WIDER
AND WIDER WITH MORE AND MORE
PEOPLE COMING. YOU KNOW AS YOU
MOVE ALONG AND I KNOW AFTER A
FEW YEARS I LOOKED BACK AND WAS
MORE LIKE A DASHED LINE YOU
KNOW THAT THAT A TRIANGLE I
MEAN THERE WAS. WATER AND
ANOTHER AND ANOTHER SO IT'S
BEEN A CONTINUAL EFFORT FOR
MANY OF US FOR ALL THESE YEARS.
TO MENTOR AND SUPPORT AND TO
HELP THEIR BE MORE DIVERSITY IN
OUR IN OUR FACULTY RANKS AND SO
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU AS MUCH AS WE CAN. TO DO
THAT WE'RE COMMITTED TO
IMPROVING ABOUT THE DIVERSITY
OF OUR FACULTY WE'RE COMMITTED
TO REFLECTING THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WERE COMMITTED TO
SUPPORTING THE INCREASINGLY
DIVERSE STUDENT BODIES THAT WE
HAVE WITH- PEOPLE WHO COME FROM
THEIR COMMUNITIES AND- TO WHOM
THEY CAN RELATE THAT MOST
EFFECTIVELY ON. AND WILL WILL
AGAIN VERY MUCH WELCOME EUROPE
YOUR PARTNERSHIP AND I WAS THE
PARTNERSHIP OF MY COLLEAGUES AT
CSU AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES AS
WELL. THANK YOU OUR DISTRIBUTOR
BECAUSE WHENEVER WE TALK ABOUT-
FACULTY DIVERSITY WE OFTEN HEAR
THERE'S NOT THERE'S A LACK OF A
PIPELINE. BUT YET SOMEHOW WHEN
UCLA NEEDS A QUARTERBACK OR
STARTING CENTER THERE'S NEVER A
SHORTAGE OF A PIPELINE ITSELF-
WOULD LOVE TO SEE THE SAME
LEVEL OF RECRUITING- FOR THE
RIGHT KIND OF FACULTY AS AS-
THE LEVEL OF RECRUITING THAT
GOES INTO. PUTTING TOGETHER OUR
HIGH LEVEL MATHLETICS PROGRAM
SO THANK YOU. JUST GOING TO-
CHANCER. AGAIN PRESS. TRADE WE
REALLY. YOUR MESSAGES PERSONAL
NOT JUST FOR YOU BUT REALLY FOR
ALL OF US I THINK AS AS YOU AS
YOU SEEN- ALL OF US. ARE
PRODUCTS OF YOUR HIGHER
EDUCATION SYSTEM THERE'S NOT
ABOUT THAT WOULD BE UP HERE
WITHOUT. ANY OF THE SEGMENTS
AND SO. THIS IS VERY THIS IS
VERY PERSONAL TO US SO WE'RE
GLAD THAT IT'S PERSONAL. TO
YOU. SO GOING JUST TO-
CHANCELLOR CHANCELLOR CASTRO.
OWNED WE'VE SEEN A- SLIGHT DROP
IN ENROLLMENT- AND HONESTLY YOU
KNOW NOT NOT IN YOUR- PREVIOUS
SCHOOL FRESNO CA PRODUCTIONS ON
UPTICK IN ENROLLMENT. BUT
WE'RE- YOU DON'T WANT TO HEAR
ABOUT WHAT WE CAN DO TO ASSIST.
THE SORT OF ENROLLMENT EFFORTS
AS WELL AS THE ADMISSIONS OUT
REACH WE KNOW THAT WHILE YOU
SEE RECEIVED RECORD
APPLICATIONS- THE COMMUNICATOR
LEDGES AND SEE AS YOU SAW-
ADMISSIONS DROP SO WHAT WHAT
CAN WE DO TO BE. SORT OF
HELPFUL THERE. IT SURE TANG
IT'S NICE TO SEE A FELLOW GOLD
BEAR YES- WELL I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT EVERYBODY KNOWS THAT
ARE. THAT ARE IN ROMAN ACTUALLY
WENT UP DURING THIS ACADEMIC
YEAR BY ABOUT 1% AND AT SOME
CAMPUSES AS YOU SAID FRESNO WAS
UP ABOUT 5% BUT AS A SYSTEM WE
WERE UP BY 1% AND AS YOU
PROBABLY KNOW THERE MANY
SYSTEMS AROUND THE COUNTRY THAT
WERE DOWN. TWENTY OR MORE
PERCENT SO THAT'S THE GOOD-NEWS. ON THE CHALLENGING SIDE
OUR APPLICATIONS WERE DOWN HAVE
BEEN DOWN SO FAR BY ABOUT 5%
NOW IT'S A LITTLE TOO EARLY TO
PREDICT THAT THAT'S GOING TO
LEAD TO A LOWER ENROLLMENT. IT
WILL ALL DEPEND UPON- OUR OUR
YIELD RATES AND WE'RE BEING
VERY AGGRESSIVE AND- GETTING
MORE STUDENTS TO APPLY I DON'T
KNOW IF YOU SAW THE WASHINGTON
POST ARTICLE OVER THE WEEKEND
BUT IT SUGGEST THAT BECAUSE OF
THE PANDEMIC SOME STUDENTS ARE
ARE NOT MEETING THE USUAL
DEADLINES AND I COMPLETELY
UNDERSTAND THAT- SO WE- FLEXED
THEIR- AND I DO BELIEVE WILL
PICK UP MORE APPLICATIONS. AND
MY HOPE IS THAT BY THE TIME WE
GET TO THE FALL IN THE
ENROLLMENT PART- THAT WILL BE
EITHER AT OR SOMEWHERE NEAR
WHERE WE WERE- LAST YEAR LAST
FALL- AND THEN OVER TIME I'D
LIKE TO. ALONG WITH ALL OF YOU
TRY TO GROW THOSE ENROLLMENTS I
THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT FOR
US TO EDUCATE MORE CALIFORNIANS
AND GET THEIR DEGREES AND HELP
THEM TO BECOME LEADERS. NO
NOTHING THANK YOU AND DO YOU
ARE YOU- YOU KNOW WHAT CAN WE
DO OBVIOUSLY WITH A SLIGHT DROP
IN APPLICATIONS THIS YEAR WHAT
CAN WE DO TO ASSIST YOU IN YOUR
IN YOUR YIELD EFFORTS BECAUSE
OBVIOUSLY WE WANT TO ENSURE.
THAT AS MANY PEOPLE CAN YOU
KNOW WHO HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
YOU KNOW WHO WHAT. THE
OPPORTUNITY CAN GET THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ENROLL. WELL IT
AS A MAN WERE CONTINUE TO BE
VERY AGGRESSIVE EACH CAMPUS
THROUGH OUR ADMISSIONS OFFICE
IS DOING A LOT OF VIRTUAL.
CONNECTIONS THERE ARE A COUPLE
WAYS THE STATE CAN BE HELPFUL-
ONE IS TO WORK WITH US TO GET
OUR FOLKS VACCINATED AS-
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE I THINK A
LOT OF STUDENTS ARE JUST.
FRANKLY TIRED OF THE VIRTUAL
EDUCATION AND- SOME MIGHT BE
SAYING WELL I'LL WAIT A LITTLE
WHILE PERHAPS SO. I THINK IF WE
CAN CONTINUE TO WORK TOGETHER
SO THAT AS MANY STUDENTS AS
POSSIBLE CAN BE ON CAMPUS. IN
THE FALL THAT THAT WILL BE. A
TERRIFIC AND THEN. TO MAKE SURE
WE ALL HAVE THE FUNDING THAT WE
NEED TO SUPPORT OUR STUDENTS.
WHERE THEY'RE AT AND THE
FEDERAL MONEY WILL HELP US WITH
SOME OF THE EMERGENCY ISSUES
BUT- THE CORE OPERATING BUDGETS
THAT WE NEED. TO SERVE ALL OF
OUR STUDENTS WHERE THEY'RE AT
AND HELP THEM AS YOU KNOW SOME
STUDENTS HAVE. A LITTLE BIT
LONGER ROAD TO TRAVEL AND-
WHERE YOU KNOW MY JOB AS
CHANCELLOR IS TO WORK WITH THE
PRESIDENT'S AND- AND THE REST
AND THE CAMPUS IS TO TRY TO
ACCELERATE. OUR TIME TO A
QUALITY DEGREE AND TO ELIMINATE
THOSE EQUITY GAP SO YOUR
SUPPORT THERE WOULD BE VITALLY
IMPORTANT. THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR CLARIFYING THE- ENROLLMENT
FIGURES I KNOW WHAT ARE YOUR
BIG ISSUES AS MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SAN BERNARDINO WAS TALKING
ABOUT WAS REALLY AROUND SORT OF
CLOSING THE EQUITY GAP- AND
WHAT I WANTED THAT WIN WITH.
THE EQUITY GAP OFFICE OFFICE
OFFICE SHOWS ITS BIGGEST GAP IS
REALLY AROUND. YEARS TO
GRADUATION WHO GRADUATES. SO
CAN YOU CAN YOU TALKMORE
ABOUT. YOUR PLANS THERE- AS
YOU'RE GOING TO AS A AS YOU GO
INTO YOUR- PRESENT IDENTICAL
TEAR CHANCELLORSHIP. APPS
CHAIRED TANK- YOU KNOW I'VE
I'VE BEEN DIGGING DEEP IN TERMS
OF WHAT THOSE GAPS LOOK LIKE AT
EACH CAMPUS. AND ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I PLAN TO DO IS
WORK WITH THE PRESIDENT SO
NUMBER ONE. WE ALL KNOW. WHERE
WHAT THE GAPS ARE NOT JUST AT
THE CAMPUS THAT THEY LIED BUT
WHAT THE GAPS ARE. AT OTHER
CAMPUSES. AND HOW CAN WE WORK
TOGETHER YOU KNOW THE- THERE
ARE SOME CAMPUSES AS I
MENTIONED EARLIER. THE FIGURE
OUT HOW TO GET THERE. TELL GAP
DOWN TO YOU KNOW ZERO. AND
OTHERS HAVE NOT. THERE ARE
OTHER CAMPUSES THERE TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO GET THERE UNDER
REPRESENTED GAPS LIKE INFRESNO
IT'S DOWN TO. TWO THREE
PERCENT. AND OTHERS OR IT'S
MUCH HIGHER SO I WANT TO
FACILITATE MORE EXCHANGE AN
AUTHENTIC WAY TO HELP EACH
OTHER. AND WE DO HAVE SOME
REALLY GREAT- TOOLS THAT THE
CHANCES OFFICES DEVELOP. WHERE
I'M GONNA BE ABLE TO SHORTLY
GIVE EACH CAMPUS. SOME
OPPORTUNITIES TO SEE HOW WE CAN
DO. THINGS BETTER IN TERMS OF-
ELIMINATING THOSE EQUITY GAPS
IN. REACHING OUR AMBITIOUS
GRADUATION GOALS. SO THAT THAT
WOULD ALL BE PART OF THE
GRADUATION INITIATIVE TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE- A PROGRAM THAT WE
HAVE AND- I'M RECONSTITUTING
THE LEADERSHIP GROUP OF THAT AS
WELL. AGAIN TO ACCELERATE OUR
PROGRESS IN ELIMINATING THE
GAPS. AND I WAS SO EXCITED TO
HEAR YOU TALK ABOUT FACULTY
DIVERSITY IS ONE OF YOUR MAJOR
GOALS- WE HAD TRIED TO WORK
WITH- CHANCELLOR WHITE IN HIS
OFFICE ON THAT ISSUE WITHOUT
ANY SUCCESS AND FORTUNATELY. SO
WHATEVER WE CAN DO TO SUPPORT
YOU IN THAT EFFORT- WE ARE YOU
KNOW VERY MUCH. HERE TO TRY TO
HELP YOU. THANK YOU CHAIR TANG-
THIS WAS A TOPIC THAT-
CHANCELLOR OAKLEY PRESIDENT
DRAKE AND I TOUCHED UPON IN OUR
MEETING A WEEK AGO AND- WERE
PLANNING TO DO A DEEP DIVE SO I
I'D LOVE TO COME BACK LATER
AFTER WE'VE HAD. A SOME MORE
DISCUSSION BECAUSE WE THINK
THAT TOGETHER WE CAN MAKE A-
FINALLY IMPORTANT DIFFERENCE
ABSOLUTELY I THINK IT GOES
WITHOUT SAYING THAT THAT THE
HELP IS OFFERED TO ALL THREE
ALL THREE SEGMENTS. SUGGEST
GOING TO. CHANCELLOR OAKLEY-
IT'LL START. THE BIGGEST ISSUE
THAT WE SEE COMING DOWN THE
PIKE- IS IT IS ENROLLMENT FOR
DOOR SEGMENT AND JUST WANTED
TO- YOU KNOW SORT OF HELP- HELP
UNDERSTAND- YOU KNOW WHAT WE
CAN DO TO REALLY SUPPORT YOUR
EFFORTS. WE KNOW THAT DURING A
DOWNTURN IT IS- IT OFTENTIMES
YOU DO SEE- YOU KNOW THAT.
USUALLY DURING A DOWNTURN YOU
SEE AND I'M GONNA MAKE A PARTY
RIGHT NOW THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM BUT WE JUST WANT
UNDERSTAND WHAT WE CAN DO TO
HELP. WITH YOUR- YOUR
ENROLLMENT. THANK YOU CARE
CHIANG- I THINK. YOU KNOW THIS
IS NOT A NORMAL DOWNTURN THAT
WERE USED TO SEEING- FIRST OF
ALL- WHAT WE'RE SEEING IS NOT
JUST A DOWNTURN BUT A DIRECT-
CHALLENGE TO OUR STUDENTS AND
THEIR ABILITY TO HAVE ACCESS TO
TWO JOBS THAT ALLOW THEM TO
MAKE ENDS MEET. AND SO MANY OF
THEM HAVE HAD REDUCED HOURS OR
OF LOST THEIR JOBS- THE
COMMUNITIES THAT WE SERVE HAVE
BEEN HIT THE HARDEST BY THE
PANDEMIC- CERTAINLY THE HEALTH
OUTCOMES ECONOMIC OUTCOMES THE
RACIAL RECKONING SO THOSE THESE
ARE CHALLENGES FOR OUR STUDENTS
AND OUR STUDENTS TO HEART LIKE-
CSU OR UC WHERE THEY ARE
ADMITTED- TO. CAMPUS WE HAVE
OPEN ENROLLMENT SO THEY COME
AND THEY GO. A AND WE TRY TO BE
AS ACCESSIBLE TO THEM IT'S
POSSIBLE THAT ALSO MEANS THAT.
AS SOON AS THEY'RE HIT BY-
ECONOMIC ISSUES- THEY TEND TO
SCALE BACK SO OUR BIGGEST
ISSUES ARE ARE THREE THINGS.
THAT YOU CAN BE HELPFUL WITHIN
YOU HAPPEN HELP WITH ONE IS.
WITH THE EMERGENCY AID IT'S IN
THIS PACKAGE OUR STUDENTS
DESPERATELY NEED THAT AID. TO
CONTINUING TO LOOK AT WAYS THAT
WE CAN REFORM THE CAL GRANT
SAYS THEM TO ALLOW MORE ACCESS
FOR STUDENTS TO. TO THE CAL
GRANT SAYS THEM. AND THREE. AS
SOMETHING THAT YOU ARE VERY
FAMILIAR WITH- HELPING OR
COLLEGES WITH RESOURCES TO GET-
DISPLACED WORKERS BACK TO WORK-
SO THAT THEY CAN ONCE AGAIN
AFFORD TO PARTICIPATE. AND HAVE
A FOOTHOLD IN IN IN THE NEW
ECONOMY. IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT FOR US AS WE LOOK FOR
MORE AND BETTER WAYS TO REACH
DISPLACED WORKERS WHETHER
THROUGH COUNTY BASED EDUCATION
THROUGH THE STRONG WORKFORCE
INITIATIVE- BUT BUT THOSE ARE
THE THREE AREAS THAT I THINK.
YOU CAN BE MOST HELPFUL IN
HELPING US REACH OUR STUDENTS
AND GET THEM BACK IN OUR
CLASSROOMS WHERE THEY WILL
REACH VERY EDUCATIONAL GOALS.
ABSOLUTELY IF WE CAN I KNOW
THAT AT TIMES WE'VE BEEN ABLE
TO TALK TO PARTNER ON THE
DISPLACED WORKER PEACE IF WE
CAN. CONTINUE TO PARTNER MORE-
PLEASE LET US KNOW I THINK IT
IS EXTRAORDINARILY IMPORTANT I
THINK- YOUR YOUR SEGMENT PLAYS
AN ESPECIALLY CRITICAL ROLE AS
YOU KNOW PEOPLE ARE CHANGING
JOBS ARE SHIFTING INDUSTRIES
YOUR COLLEGES ARE REALLY THE
FIRST STOP FOR ALL THOSE ALL
THOSE FOLKS AND SO I THINK IT'S
REALLY CRITICAL DURING THIS
TIME. THE LAST THING I WOULD
SAY AND NO ONE IS TO COMMENT ON
IT THAT THAT CAN BE CHAMBER
CARD AND I. HAVE BEEN WORKING
TO TRY TO SUPPORT YOUR HOUSING
EFFORTS WE KNOW THAT- FOR
DIFFERENT SEGMENTS HOUSING
IMPACTS ALL OF YOU A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENTLY BUT WE KNOW. THAT
BASED ON WHAT YOU'RE DEPENDING
ON WHERE YOU'RE LOCATED HOUSING
COULD BE A MAJOR ISSUE OR MAJOR
COST DRIVER WHETHER STUDENTS
COM OR CAN'T COME OR FRANKLY
EVEN FACULTY OR STAFF COME. SO
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE ARE
ACUTELY AWARE OF AND WE
UNDERSTAND ALSO EACH OF THIS
EACH OF YOUR SEGMENTS IS
UNIQUELY. POSITIONED TO
POTENTIALLY ASSIST IN BUILDING.
MORE HOUSING AND SO ON. THE
CHAIR AND I ARE LOOKING AT
DIFFERENT EFFORTS SO WE CAN DO
TO PLEASE SUPPORT YOUR EFFORTS
MANY OF YOU AND YOUR YOUR
CAMPUS IS ALREADY BEEN TALKING
ABOUT HOW YOU CAN. WORK ON THAT
SO PLEASE LET US KNOW- AS AS AS
YOU HAVE COME UP WITH MORE
SYSTEM WIDE. THINKING WE'D LOVE
TO ENGAGE WITH YOU ON THAT SO
REALLY APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEE'S INDULGENCE WITH THE
QUESTIONS AND- THANK YOU FOR
ALL THREE OF YOU FOR BEING HERE
TODAY. THANK YOU ALWAYS
APPRECIATE HAVING OUR BUDGET
SHARE INVOLVED. TODAY BUT DO WE
HAVE ALL THREE ON THE LINE
STILL MARK YEAH. SO I THINK
<c.magenta>OST OF THESE ISSUES. HAVE BEEN</c>
HIT I'M NOT GONNA ASK TOO MANY
QUESTIONS BUT MAYBE MAKE SOME.
SOME POINTS ON ALL THREE AND
THEN WE CAN GET TO PUBLIC
COMMENT SO. ALSO I'LL START
WITH. THAT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND THROUGH THEIR-
THAT CHANCE ORTIZ OAKLEY- I TO
AS YOU MENTIONED. I THINK THAT
WE NEED TO FOCUS ON FINANCE
LATER LOWEST INCOME STUDENTS IS
NOT PART OF TODAY'S AGENDA YOU
KNOW MR MEDINA. CENTER LEYVA
AND I ARE GOING TO BE BACK AT
IT LOOKING AT THE CAL GRANT
REFORM MEASURE THIS YEAR- BUT
WE- YOU KNOW WE WILL BE SEEING
THIS PANDEMIC IS HOW MUCH IT'S
IMPACTED OUR- LOWEST INCOME
STUDENTS CENTER COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENT SO. CERTAINLY
WELL AWARE OF THAT AND THAT THE
BASIC NEEDS- EFFORTS ARE. OUR
PRIORITY- WILL BE WORKING WITH
JUSTICE INVOLVED STUDENTS WHICH
I KNOW YOU ARE SUPPORT OF OUR
EFFORT TO. THE FOCUS- RETURNING
EVEN INDIVIDUALS FROM OUR
CORRECTIONS INSTITUTIONS TO
SUCCEED. AND NOT BE A STATISTIC
AS FAR AS RECIDIVISM. I ALSO
WANTED TO NOTE THAT THE WHOLE
NOTION OF THESE ONLINE COURSES
THAT WE WON'T GET INTO THE
ONLINE UNIVERSITY TODAY AND I'M
SURE YOU'RE GOING TO. LEAVE BUT
OVERSEEING THE STUDENTS DROP
OUT I THINK THEY WERE SAYING IS
THAT IS THAT A BIG PORTION OF
THE STUDENTS ARE NOT ABLE TO
SUCCEED WITH WITH ZOOM
UNIVERSITY. AND SO- I THINK
THAT OFFERING MORE COURSES
ONLINE IS A POSITIVE THING WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE.
THE TOOLS AND EQUIPMENT TO HELP
THE STUDENTS SUCCEED YOU KNOW
INTERNET ACCESS WHETHER IT'S
COMPUTERS OR WHAT HAVE YOU
BECAUSE IT DOESN'T WORK FOR
EVERYBODY IN THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES ARE CERTAINLY SO
BROUGHT SOME OF YOUR STUDENTS
ARE. GOING TO SANTA MONICA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES TRANSFERRING
TO UCLA SOME ARE AT EAST LA
COLLEGE GOING TO GO TO. TRADE
SCHOOL SUMMER IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY TRYING TO LEARN ENGLISH
AND- FOCUS ON THEIR BASIC NEEDS
AND SO. IT'S VERY VERY-
DIFFERENT SO- AS WELL I
MENTIONED WE WILL TRY TO FOCUS
ON THE CALL ISSUE ON GOING- AND
THEN KIND OF A THAT DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE IS AN ISSUE THAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT FOR ALL
SEGMENTS OF GOOD USE OF ONE
TIME MONEY. WE MAY NOT HAVE A
LOT OF ON GOING BUT WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE A LOT OF ONE TIME-
SUPPORT. TO OUR CSU SYSTEM. CAN
WE BRING UP THAT- CHANCELLOR
CASTRO. JUST A ONE WORD IN YOUR
FACE WILL SHOW UP. STILL THERE
ALSO CHAIRMAN CARD THERE YOU GO
OKAY SO LOOKING FORWARD TO IT
TO WORKING WITH YOU- THIS YEAR.
ON ON ON THE BUDGET CERTAINLY
WHAT WOULD YOU SEE WHAT YOU
WILL DO WHAT WE CAN TO FOCUS ON
ON ON GOING TO RESTORE. THE
CUTS FROM TWO YEARS AGO WE DO
HAVE A LOT OF ONE TIME- MONEY
THAT WE'RE GONNA BE ABLE TO
HAVE TO PLAY WITH IN THE BUDGET
SO WE'LL LOOK TO THE EXTENT
FOR. DEFERRED MAINTENANCE-
BASIC NEEDS PROGRAMS A WE CAN
SPEND THOSE MONIES OVER AT A
NUMBER OF YEARS TO HAVE SOME
CONTINUITY. I WILL SAY ONE
THING TO WHICH MR TANG
MENTIONED THAT WE ARE ALWAYS
INTERESTED IN ACCESS AND THAT'S
INSURING THAT ALL QUALIFIED
STUDENTS TO APPLY. CAN GET IN
TO SEE ISSUE THE POLICY THAT WE
PUT IN A COUPLE YEARS AGO THAT
YOU KNOW FRANKLY THAT
LEADERSHIP OF. ABOUT FELTING
HERE WEEK WITH IT'S A REALITY
NOW WE HAVE THE AUTOMATIC- SO
WHAT'S IT CALLED. REDIRECTION
THE AUTOMATIC REDIRECTION YOU
CAN MAKE SURE PEOPLE CAN GO TO
ACS YOU AND THAT SEEMS TO BE
WORKING. BUT AS BUT STILL WE
NEED MORE SPACE IN THE CSU ONE
THING THAT I'M WORKING WITH YOU
ON. IS FOR YOUR GRADUATION
PROGRAM- SO S. SON CAMPUS ARE
DOING CSU AS A WHOLE WE'RE
DOING WELL SOME ARE DOING
BETTER HERE AT SAC STATE WE
NOW. AND YOU AT FRESNO YOU DID
IT AT MY JOB THERE TOO BUT
THERE'S THINGS THAT WE CAN DO
BETTER AND THAT AND THAT HELPS.
LOW INCOME STUDENTS MINORITY
STUDENTS AND NOT ONLY IS IT THE
GRADUATE FOUR YEARS. THAT'S
LESS STUDENT DEBT FOR THEM LET.
LAWS YOU KNOW GO TO WORK FOR
SOONER. AND MORE SEATS FOR
THEIR LITTLE BROTHER OR
NEIGHBOUR WHOEVER ELSE TO GET
INTO THAT CSU CAMPUS AND SO.
THAT IS A BIG BIG PRIORITY AND
SO WE HAVE SOME FINANCIAL AID
IDEAS REFORM AND COUNTING ON
YOUR HELP TO MAKE THOSE A
REALITY- FOR UC- PRESIDENT
DRAKE YOU STILL THERE WELL. YES
YES JUST SAY QUOTE. YES SO WE-
OKAY. JUST A COUPLE IN YOUR
BACK. YES YOUR AM A NICE TO SEE
YOU OKAY THERE YOU GO SO WE
WON'T RE LITIGATE THE OUT OF
STATE STUDENT THING BECAUSE-
IT'S A NINE IT'S A NON WINNER
FOR YOU ONE FOR POLITICS THE
LEGISLATURE HUNTER PERCENT DOES
NOT AGREE WITH YOU. ALL OF US
GET A COMMENTS IN OUR DISTRICTS
ABOUT PEOPLE WITH A FOUR POINT
THREE WHO CAN'T GET INTO THEIR
UC CAMPUS BUT THEY SEE STUDENTS
WHO ARE INTERNATIONAL OR
WEALTHY OUT OF STATERS TAKING
THOSE SEATS. AND MISTER LEE
JUST LEFT BUT I WILL NOTE THAT
THAT DIDN'T AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY MATH IS NOT ON YOUR
SIDE BECAUSE THAT NUMBER CHAU
HAS SOMEONE EVER TEAM NOTED.
THAT FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS WHEN
WE GAVE YOU SEE MORE MONEY WE
SAW FEWER CALIFORNIA'S FOR
EXAMPLE A UC DAVIS I WAS ASKING
MISTER LEE WHEN HE GRADUATED
HIGH SCHOOL HE SAID TWO
THOUSAND THIRTEEN SO WHEN HE
WAS IN HIGH SCHOOL THINKING
ABOUT UC DAVIS LET'S SAY TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN TWELVE. TO THE
YEAR THAT HE GRADUATED TWENTY
SEVENTEEN THE NUMBER OF
INTERNATIONAL AN OUT OF STATE
STUDENTS AT UC DAVIS DOUBLED
FROM TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED TO
FIVE THOUSAND AND THE NUMBER OF
STUDENTS FROM CALIFORNIA WENT
DOWN. SO THINK ABOUT THAT FEWER
CALIFORNIANS DOUBLE THE AMOUNT
OF NON RESIDENT STUDENTS ALL IN
THAT PERIOD WHEN WE WERE GIVING
SIX NICK SIGNIFICANT INCREASES.
TO THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
FROM THE GENERAL FUND GRANTED I
THINK YOU PUT THIS ISSUE TO BED
FOR A BIT THE SENATE AS YOU NOW
WANTS TO PUT THAT NUMBER DOWN I
KNOW MR TANG TALKED ABOUT BRING
IT DOWN BUT- BY DOING THAT WE
HAVE TO PUT ANOTHER POT OF
MONEY ON GOING. TO SUPPLANT
THAT THAT WOULD BE GOOD IN A
PERFECT WORLD BUT I THINK THAT
THE URGE TO CONTINUE TO PUSH
THIS IS IT IS NOT GOING TO
HAPPEN- WE WOULD LIKE SOME OF
THE OTHER CAMPUSES THAT AREN'T
THERE LIKE. MERCED IN RIVERSIDE.
NOW THERE'S NOT TO COME CLOSE
TO THAT EIGHTEEN FIRST. REALIZE
YOU CAN'T THE GENIE IN THE
BOTTLE WITH THE OTHER ONES
ABOVE- BUT CERTAINLY THAT IS
THE ISSUE THAT IS VERY VERY
CONCERNING TO US BECAUSE- WE
GOT OUR DISTRICTS THAT SO WE
HEAR THE MOST IS ACCESS TO THE
UNIVERSITY SYSTEMS AND YOU SEE
IS THE MARQUEE. PUBLIC RESEARCH
INSTITUTION IN THE WORLD. AND
WE HAVE NINE FABULOUS
UNDERGRADUATE CAMPUSES AND SO
WE WANT THEM ALL TO STAY DO
WELL AND THRIVE BUT WE ALSO
WANT TO MAKE SURE WE HAVE.
ACCESS FOR THE NEXT GENERATION
AND YOU SEE IT BY THE NUMBERS
LAST WEEK ON STUDENTS APPLYING-
THE DATA CAME OUT LAST WEEK ON.
UCLA AND ALL THE CAMPUS IS THE
NUMBER OF STUDENTS IS THROUGH
THE ROOF AND SO THERE IS A
GREAT NUMBER OF STUDENTS
GRADUATING FROM HIGH SCHOOL. A
THREE G. READY READY TO GO TO
THE UC AND SO- IT HAVING PROPER
ENROLLMENT TARGETS AYE AYE ONE
THING I DO WANNA SAY THAT I'M
FULLY SUPPORTIVE OF AND JUST
GIVE YOU SEE A PAT ON THE BACK
IS. LOOKING AT WAYS TO EXPAND
ACCESS OUTSIDE OF THE CAMPUS.
AND ELECTED BERKELEY THEY'RE
THINKING ABOUT. GOING TO MILLS
COLLEGE OR MOFFETT FIELD ACROSS
THE WAY HERE IN SACRAMENTO- UC
DAVIS IS LOOKING SPENDING
PROGRAMS HERE IN SACRAMENTO AT
THE MED CENTER. SO WHATEVER WE
CAN DO TO BE CREATIVE. TO GET
MORE STUDENTS IN THE UC IS I
THINK A PRIORITY. PLUS I- THE
FOR YOUR GRADUATION RATES HE'S
NOT WHILE NOT PERFECT IT THERE
PRETTY SOLID YOU SEE. BUT WHEN
YOU LOOK AT THE STATS AND YOU
KNOW I'M SURE THIS IS TROUBLING
TO YOU. THE STUDENTS AREN'T
GRADUAL FOR YEARS AND GRADUATE
MORE DEBT. ARE MORE LIKELY TO
BE- BROWN A BLACK KIDS FROM
CALIFORNIA SO ADDRESSING THOSE
ISSUES IS CERTAINLY. A
PRIORITY- AND THEN- YOU KNOW I
KNOW IT'S- NOT POPULAR BUT IN
REALITY- CALIFORNIA WE HAVE A
THREE LEGGED STOOL TO FIND YOU
SEE IT'S GENERAL FUND. IT'S NON
RESIDENT MONEY AND IT'S STUDENT
FEE SO. IF IT'S A FINITE AMOUNT
OF GENERAL FUND. AND WE HAVE A
POLICY CAPPING THE NON
RESIDENT. THAT STUDENT FEE
REVENUE STAYING STAGNANT FOR
EVER I DON'T THINK IT MAKES
SENSE I THINK HAVING. MODERATE
AND PREDICTABLE INCREASES IN
THE COHORT MODEL LIKE. I REGION
PRESENT FORMER SPEAKER AND YOU
ARE TALKING ABOUT. AT THE
BORDER REGIONS I THINK THAT
DOES MAKE SENSE I KNOW THIS
YEAR IS A PROMISED TO KEEP
THEM- STABLE DURING THIS LIST
LIST YOU HAVE COVER NINETEEN
THE PANDEMIC. BUT THE OUT YOUR
I THINK THAT'S A REASONABLE-
PROPOSAL AND I WITH I KNOW THAT
SOME OF YOU HAVE TO LEAVE WE
HAVE PUBLIC COMMENT- WE'LL GET
INTO THIS GREATER- THROUGHOUT
THAT THIS SPRING. I JUST WANT
TO GIVE YOU SOME OF MY
THOUGHTS. OFF THE TOP SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND WE'LL SEE YOU
SOON. THANK YOU. COMMENTS THANK
YOU OKAY THANK YOU SO WITH
THAT- WE WILL GO BACK TO PUBLIC
COMMENT. MODERATOR CAN YOU
QUEUE UP PEOPLE TO. TO ENGAGE
IN PUBLIC COMMENT. ABSOLUTELY
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. FOR
THOSE OF YOU THAT HAVE NOT HAD
YOUR LINE NUMBER TAKEN YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT OUR
FIRST COMMENT COMES FROM NINE
SEVENTEEN. LINE SEVENTEEN ONE
MOMENT PLEASE YOUR LINE IS- MY
NAME IS GOING TO HAVE. WELL
HELLO GOOD EVENING OF FAMILY
MEMBERS MY NAME IS GREAT FOSSIL
NORMAN UNDERGRADUATE STUDENT I
UC SANTA CRUZ AS WELL THE
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE AND THEY
ASK YOU WHY OFFICE OF THE VICE
PRESIDENT OF EXTERNAL AFFAIRS.
WE'RE DISAPPOINTED TO SEE THE
JANUARY BUDGET LEAVE OUT THE UC
STUDENT ACADEMIC PREPARATION
AND EDUCATIONAL PARTNERSHIP
PROGRAM ABBREVIATED SA POP
SOMETHING STUDENTS HAVE BEEN
FIGHTING FOR AN ASKING FOR
INVESTMENTS THAT. WE ARE NOW
LOOKING TO THE STATE
LEGISLATURE TO CHAMPION THE
FUNDING OF THIS CRITICAL
RESOURCE AND DEMONSTRATE ITS
COMMITMENT TO HIGHER EDUCATION
ACCESS AND OPPORTUNITY. WE'RE
ASKING FOR TWENTY MILLION
DOLLAR INVESTMENT IN STATE
PROGRAMS OUT ADDRESS ACCESS AND
EQUITY GAPS FACING. STUDENTS
THANK YOU. THE YOU. NINE FIFTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO I AM RESOURCE
DROUGHT- CORNING- THE BASIC
NEEDS RESOURCES PROGRAM AMOUNTS
AND THE TWENTY A COLLEGE IN THE
CITY OF ON- IN EASTERN L. A.
COUNTY. I WORK DIRECTLY WITH
STUDENTS FACING HOUSING AND
FOOD INSECURITY EVERY DAY. I
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S
INCLUSION OF FUNDING FOR
STUDENT BUT BASIC PAINT IN THE
BUDGET BUT I AM REQUESTING ON
BEHALF OF THE STUDENTS THAT A
PORTION OF THE FUNDS MEANS THAT
CANADIAN. AS I'M GOING RATHER
THAN ONE TIME FOR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE COLLEGES THAT CONTINUE
THE WORK TO CREATE LONG TERM
SOLUTIONS AND SUPPORT OUR
STUDENTS STABILIZE AND IMPROVE
THEIR SITUATIONS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT BAKER. ONE
TWENTY EIGHT. OKAY LINE TWENTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME'S ALEX
NILES OF INSECURE UC SANTA
BARBARA- WITH REGARDS CC BUDGET
WE APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET STEPS- AND FULLY FUNDING
YOU SEE WHO IN THE STRONG
INVESTMENT BASIC NEEDS TO
ADDRESS DIGITAL ACCORDION
MENTAL HEALTH. BUT WE CONTINUE
TO HOPE TO SEE EXPANDED FUNDING
ON THESE ITEMS THANKS. THANK
YOU. NINE FORTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
BOARD LINING THE BEST A FEVER
RESIGNED FROM HACIENDA HEIGHTS
AND I GO TO MOUNT SAN ANTONIO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE. AND THE
STUDENTS ARE EITHER AND THE PTC
ARTISTIC ABILITY STEERING
COMMITTEE REPRESENTATIVE AND
THAT SUCH TRIPLE C. WOMAN
POCKETS I SAID CHAIR. AND I YOU
KNOW I WANT OUT OF THE LEARNING
ENVIRONMENT JUST BECAUSE I
BELIEVE WE CAN STRIVE FOR A
BETTER QUALITY DIFFERENT
OPTIONS- WHILE WE'RE HERE-
DIFFERENT MORE RESEARCH AND
PEDAGOGY PEDAGOGIES- BUT I COME.
HERE FOR PUBLIC COMMENT ON A
FEW THINGS. THANK YOU FOR
FUNDING IN A- INITIATIVE. THANK
YOU THANK YOU GARNERING- WE ARE
AT OUR WHEN I WORKED. POVERTY
WITH MEN ECHO ASSETS ZERO
CAUGHT JUST HAD A RESOLUTION
RIGHT AND WE HOPE TO TALK THAT
THROUGH THE GENERAL ASSEMBLY
AND IT WOULD BE EXTREMELY
IMPRESSIVE IF WE CAN HAVE A
YOUR SUPPORT THEIR- TO LISTEN
MOST OF THE STUDENTS YEAR OF
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
EXISTING ABILITY WITHOUT IN THE-
TO CHARACTER. AND REDUCING THE
STIGMA AROUND MENSTRUATION AND
INCREASING THE CONCEPT OF
GENDER INCLUSIVE LANGUAGE WHEN
DISCUSSING MENSTRUATION BECAUSE
IT'S NOT JUST WOMEN THAT MEN
STREET IT. IS NON BINARY. THAT
SPECTRUM IT'S ALL RIGHT
MENSTRUATION AND IT'S NATURAL-
THANK YOU BOTH THANK YOU FOR
YOUR. LET ME FORGET. THANK YOU.
WHAT THANK YOU. NINE FIFTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY
MY NAME IS JOHANNA OF THE MIND
AND I AM THE BASIC NEEDS
COORDINATOR FOR SAN DIEGO MESA
COLLEGE ON A DAILY BASIS I MEET
WITH STUDENTS PROVIDING THEM
WITH DIRECT SUPPORT OR
EMERGENCY AID AND CONNECTED
THEM TO BOTH CAMPUS AND
COMMUNITY RESOURCES. TO GET
THEIR NEEDS MET I'M
APPRECIATIVE THAT THE GOVERNOR
INCLUDED FUNDING HAS PROPOSAL
TO ADDRESS STUDENT BASIC NEEDS
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES. AND I'M
HERE TO REQUESTED A PORTION OF
THESE FUNDS BE DESIGNATED AS
ONGOING RATHER THAN ONE TIME IN
ORDER TO PROVIDE STAFFING AS
WELL AS DIRECT SUPPORT TO OUR
STUDENTS GIVING THEM ACCESS TO
THE TOOLS THEY NEED TO BE
SUCCESSFUL IN THEIR EDUCATIONAL
PATH. AND CREATE BETTER AND A
BETTER ECONOMICALLY STRONG. AND
PROSPEROUS CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NINE SIXTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU MCCARTY AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS JOSH LEWIS
THE CHAIR OF GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS FOR THE UC STUDENT
ASSOCIATION BURKE HIGHLIGHT THE
NEED TO CENTER STUDENT VOICES
PARTICULARLY MOST VULNERABLE
STUDENTS IN THE BUDGET PROCESS
WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR THE
INCREDIBLE LAUNCHING POINT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PRESENTS
PARTICULARLY POTENTIAL EQUITY
EMERGENCY FINANCIAL AID. THAT
BEING SAID IT'S CRITICAL THAT
THE LEGISLATURE COMPLETELY
RESTORES FUNDING TO DO YOU SEE
AS OUTLINED IN THE ASSEMBLY
BUDGET BUDGET BLUEPRINT WITHOUT
THIS FUNDING EQUITY ACCESS AND
ACADEMIC FLEXIBILITY WILL
SUFFER FOR THE LACK OF STATE
FUNDING FOR SAY PET PROGRAMS IN
THE JANUARY BUDGET IS HIGHLY
CONCERNING. WE HAD UC STUDENTS
ARE ASKING FOR TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS INVESTMENT FOR THESE
PROGRAMS AND LOOK TO THE
LEGISLATOR FOR LEADERSHIP AND
IF NECESSARY INVESTMENT
ESPECIALLY IN LIGHT OF THE
FAILURE OF PROP SIXTY. LOCKLEY
UTSA IS PROUD TO BE A MEMBER OF
THE FIX FINANCIALLY COALITION
AND I WOULD JUST LIKE TO
HIGHLIGHT THE IMPORTANCE OF
FULLY INVESTING IN CALGARY
MONETIZATION. EFFORTS TO THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NINE ONE HUNDRED YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD- HI MY
NAME IS KIMBERLY CANADA. AND I
AM WITH NORCO COLLEGE AND I
WORK WITH THE FOSTER CARE
STUDENTS THERE TO THE GUARDIAN
SCHOLARS PROGRAM THAT WE CALL
PHOENIX DOLLARS I LIKE TO
THINK- EVERYONE FOR GETTING AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK. I HEARD
EARLIER PRESIDENT DRAKE SPEAK
ABOUT THE NEW NORMAL. AND ABOUT
HOW STUDENTS NEEDS- HAVE
CHANGED IN THE WARM ALL BASED
ON THAT I'D LOVE TO SEE AND NOT
SO MUCH MY PERSONAL GROWTH BUT
FOR MY STUDENTS THAT WE WOULD
BE ABLE TO STAY. IN BUT BASIC
NEEDS FUNDS AND THEN IT MOVES
FROM- EDUCATIONAL OR NOT
PERMANENTLY FUNDED DEPARTMENT
FUNDING FUNDING THIS WILL HELP
US ADDRESS INEQUITIES IN THE
SYSTEM AND ALSO IT WILL ALLOW
OUR COLLEGE TO PLAN ON A
REGULAR BASIS HOW CAN THEY CAN
FURTHER SUPPORT. THE ON GOING.
NEEDS OF OUR STUDENTS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. MY NINETY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI THIS IS DANIEL ONE DRUG WITH
CHILDREN NOW I WANT TO EXPRESS
OUR APPRECIATION THAT THE
GOVERNOR INCLUDED FUNDING IN
HIS PROPOSED BUDGET FOR
STUDENTS BASIC NEEDS. HOWEVER
WE'D LIKE TO SEE MORE OF THE
FUND FOR STUDENT BASIC NEEDS AT
COMMUNITY COLLEGES BE
DESIGNATED AS ONGOING FUNDING
RATHER THAN ONE TIME FUNDING TO
ENSURE THEIR STABILITY IN THIS
CRITICAL FUNDING GOING FORWARD
THANK YOU. NINE FORTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO HELLO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TWENTY MY STAFF AROUND
OPENPOWER READY COLLEGE AND I'M
THE DIRECTOR THE FACT THAT
EQUITY AND I DO WORK WITH THE
STUDENTS BUT BASIC NEEDS
SECURITY- MANY ARE ALSO
UNDERSERVED AFTER UNDER
REPRESENTED. AND JUST FALL OF
TWENTY TWENTY ALONE- MARLBORO
COLLEGE LOCATED IN DECEMBER BY
COUNTY OR LIKE WE LIKE TO SAY I
HEAR YOU FELT THE CALIFORNIA WE
APPROXIMATE THREE THOUSAND
MAYBE COLLEGE STUDENTS AND
THEIR HOUSEHOLD MEMBERS. NOW
WHY WE'RE APPRECIATIVE OF THE
GOVERNOR COULD FUNDING IN THE
PROPOSAL BUT STRESSED BOTH
THESE TECHNIQUES AT OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES I AM HERE TO
REQUEST THAT A PORTION OF THE
FUNDS HE DOES NEED TO THE
ONGOING RATHER THAN ONE TIME SO
WE CAN CONTINUE THE GREAT WORK
THAT WE'RE DOING OUR STUDENTS
TO DEVELOP CHEAT. SO THEY CAN
BE I WANT THE CSU. ONE DAY
THANK YOU. NINE ONE THIRTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME JEANETTE NIKKI AND I
WORK WITH STUDENTS- WORKS
BASICALLY THE LOS ANGELES
SOUTHWEST COLLEGE LOCATED IN
SOUTH LOS ANGELES AND WE ALSO
APPRECIATED THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
INCLUSION OF FUNDING FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS AND
THEIR BASIC NEEDS. BUT ALSO
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT A PORTION
OF THESE TERMS BE DESIGNATED
FOR ONGOING BRUSH ONE TIME.
FUNDING. FOR COLLEGES. THANK
YOU. NINE ONE TWENTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
BEING CHAMPIONS OF HIGHER
EDUCATION MY NAME IS SANDRA
HAMILTON SLAIN IN NINETEEN OF
COLLEGE. IT HAS BEEN STATED.
MOST STUDENTS TO DROP OUT OF
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DO SO BECAUSE
OF ECONOMIC CHALLENGES NOT
BECAUSE OF THE ACADEMIC
DEMANDS. SO MANY COMMUNITY
COLLEGES ARE CAREGIVERS AND
PROVIDERS IN THEIR FAMILY AND
SO THEY FEEL A REAL CONFLICT
BETWEEN MEETING THE IMMEDIATE
NEEDS FOR THEIR FAMILY. PERSONS
MAINTAINING ENROLLMENT IN ORDER
TO BE PREPARED FOR SECURE
EMPLOYMENT AND INCOME IN THE
FUTURE. WE ALL LOSE WHEN
STUDENTS ARE FORCED TO ABANDON
THEIR EDUCATION. IN ORDER TO
PROVIDE RELIABLE ACCESS TO
STABLE AND SECURE HOUSING AND
CONSTRUED RESOURCES THIS
FUNDING FOR BASIC NEEDS IS
NEEDED ON AN ANNUAL ON GOING
BASIS NOT JUST ONE TIME. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. ONE ONE THIRTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE ONE THIRTY SIX YOU
MAY BE ON MUTE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE- MY
NAME IS SHAYLA IDEALISTIC THERE
AND I AM CURRENTLY ENROLLED
STUDENT AT MOUNT SAN ANTONIO
COLLEGE I WANT TO USE MY TIME
TODAY TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
ANY ACTION TAKEN TO FULLY FUND
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM.
AS WELL AS ANY ACTION TAKEN
TOWARDS EXPANDING EMERGENCY
FINANCIAL AID GRANTS RETENTION
AND RE ENROLLMENT STRATEGIES
VERITEX ACROSS PATHWAYS
TECHNOLOGY AND OUR
PARTICIPATION OF THE FACT THAT
AS MENTIONED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. ADDITIONALLY I BELIEVE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS
WOULD LIKE TO SEE BASIC NEED
FUNDING TO BECOME AN ONGOING
INVESTMENT AS WELL AS AN
INVESTMENT AS WELL AS IF YOU
INVESTMENT INTO CAL GRANT
REFORM TO ENSURE THE FULL COST.
OF ATTENDANCE IS ACCOUNTED FOR
NOT JUST TUITION AND FEES ON A
PERSONAL NOTE I WOULD LIKE TO
ADD THAT I HAVE PERSONALLY SEEN
HOW IMPACTFUL FUND. BASIC NEEDS
CAN BE. I CAN BE IT FOR
STUDENTS OF SOMEONE WHO HAS
VOLUNTEERED NUMEROUS TIMES THAT
MY SCHOOL FOOD DRIVE LASTLY I
WANT TO ADD THAT PROPOSITION
SIXTY THREE REVENUE OUGHT TO BE
USED MORE CONSISTENTLY DEFINED
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS. AND
AS SOMEONE WHO HAS STRUGGLED A
LOT WITH THE- ANXIETY AND
DEPRESSION THROUGHOUT MY
COMMUNITY COLLEGE EXPERIENCE I
CAN ATTEST TO HOW IMPACTFUL
THAT WOULD BE FOR. ME
PERSONALLY. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU PRESS COMMENT
ON THE LINE PLEASE. HI MY NAME
FIFTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
SHARE MCCARTY AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS BENJAMIN
LEVIN I AM A STUDENT TRUSTEE AT
GROSSMONT COLLEGE I WOULD FIRST
LIKE TO THANK ALL OF YOU IT
TAKES A VERY SPECIAL KIND OF
HIGHER EDUCATION CHAMPION TO
STAY IN A COMMITTEE FOR THREE
HOURS. LISTENING TO TESTIMONY
IN ASKING QUESTIONS ALL UP ALL
I WOULD LIKE TO SAY IS THAT
THESE ARE ALL CRITICAL
PRIORITIES EVERYTHING THAT IS
BAD FOR CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS AND WE AT THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM I'M I KNOW WOULD LIKE TO
SEE BASIC MEANS FINDING BECOME
AN ONGOING INVESTMENT. TO
SUPPORT AN ONGOING THE AND
INVESTMENT TO CAL GRANT REFORM
TO ENSURE THE TOTAL COST OF
ATTENDANCE TO THE COUNTY FOR. I
KNOW MYSELF PERSONALLY WOULD
LIKE TO SEE PROP SIXTY THREE
REVENUE BECAUSE IT SHOULD BE
USED TO FUND MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES FOR CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS
WE'VE ALL BEEN HIT HARD DURING
THE PANDEMIC AND MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES CAN NOT BE UNDERFUNDED
IN. THIS CRITICAL TIME THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU NEXT
COMMENT ONLINE PLEASE. NINE ONE
SIX THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND ONE SIXTY
YOU MAY BE AMUSED PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO. YOU'RE ON HELLO.
HI MY NAME IS ERICA AND I'M A
FIRST YEAR GRADUATE STUDENT
STUDYING PUBLIC HEALTH AT UC
BERKELEY MORNING REYES IN
RICHMOND VIRGINIA I DREAM OF
THE DAY I CAN CALL THE UC
SYSTEM MY ACADEMIC HOME AWAY
FROM HOME HAVING ACCESS TO
RESOURCES THROUGH MY
INVOLVEMENT HAS MADE MY
GRADUATE EXPERIENCE NOT ONLY
POSSIBLE BUT LIFE CHANGING
THESE RESEARCHERS ARE LIGHT IN
PER STUDENT STATE FUNDING AT UC
IT'S CRITICAL TO THE LAWS OF
OUR STUDENTS. USUALLY OBSTACLE
THE NINETEEN MANY STUDENTS
ACROSS THE UC SYSTEM NEEDED TO
PICK UP ADDITIONAL PART TIME OR
FULL TIME EMPLOYMENT TO SUPPORT
THEMSELVES AND THEIR FAMILIES
SOME OF THESE POSITIONS BUT
IT'S DIRECTLY IN THE FRONT
LINES OF THE PANDEMIC LIKE MINE
I WORK AT A HEALTH CLINIC AND
EACH WEEK I TEST FOUR HUNDRED
PLUS RESIDENTS OF SANTA CLARA
COUNTY WITH NO HEALTH INSURANCE
I'M SUPPORTING MYSELF AND LIKE
MANY OTHER STUDENTS WE ARE
RELYING ON OUR INSTITUTIONS
QUICKEN SYSTEM HEALTH INSURANCE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES HOUSING
ASSISTANCE AND BASIC NEEDS OF
THE PATIENT. WE NEED FOR
LEGISLATORS TO ACT AND
PRIORITIZE RESTORING CUTS TO UC
STUDENTS JUST LIKE. MERE
DEPENDING ON IT. THANK YOU.
NINE ONE SIXTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS SORT OF LIGHTING THE
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR FOR UC
SANTA CRUZ THE WHOLE
STAKEHOLDER IN THE UC SYSTEM.
ATKINS WE GREATLY APPRECIATE
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET TAKEN
STEPS TOWARDS FINDING YOU SEE
IF YOUR BASIC NEEDS ADDITIONAL
EQUITY THIS IS JUST NOT NEARLY
ENOUGH TO RESTORE THE CUTS THAT
WERE IMPOSED ON THE UC LAST
YEAR. THAT'S WHY WE'RE REALLY
LOOKING TO THE STATE
LEGISLATURE TO CONTINUE ITS
LEADERSHIP RESTORED UC'S BUDGET
CUTS AS OUTLINED IN THE
ASSEMBLY BLUEPRINT FOR THE
BUDGET. ADDITIONALLY WE ARE
GREATLY DISAPPOINTED TO SEE THE
JANUARY BUDGET WE THOUGHT THAT
YOU SEE STATE PROGRAM IT'S
SOMETHING THAT STUDENTS WHO CAN
FIGHT FOR THREE YEARS AND WITH
THE FAILURE PROPOSITIONS
SIXTEEN. THIS PROGRAM IS ONLY
MORE IMPORTANT THAN EVER SO I
HIGHLY URGE RECENTLY TO
CONSIDER TWENTY MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT INCENTIVE PROGRAMS
ADDITIONALLY WE LIKE TO JOIN
STUDENTS IN ALL THREE SEGMENTS
AND HIGHER AT AS PART OF THE
FIX FINANCIAL AID COALITION A
CALLING ON THE STATE
LEGISLATURE DUSTING CAL GRANT
REFORM. TOGETHER THE TOTAL COST
OF ATTENDANCE FOR CALIFORNIA.
STUDENTS THANK YOU. MY TWENTY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO. GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS DR
PASSED COURTS MY LOOK STUDENT
AT UCSD AND THE VICE CHAIR OF
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS FOR THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
STUDENT ASSOCIATION. ALTHOUGH
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WAS
CERTAINLY SHOWED UP TO THE
RIGHT DIRECTION IN TERMS OF
HELPING THE FUNDING YOU SEE. A
SPECIALIST FROM INVESTMENT AND
BASIC NEEDS LIKE MENTAL HEALTH
AND DIGITAL EQUITY IN MY
PROPOSED IS NOT ENOUGH TO
RESTORE LOST YOUR COMPANIES SEE
WE URGE THE STATE LEGISLATURE
TO TAKE ACTION ON THIS AND- I'M
ASSEMBLY PERFECT THE BUDGET.
CUTS OUT COMPLETE RESTORATION
OF BUDGET CUTS THE UC I'M NOT
SURE THE BC DOES NOT HAVE TO
IMPLEMENT ANY CUT COST. CUTTING
MEASURES. LIKE LAYOFFS CAL
MENTAL IT TO INCREASE. THAT
WOULD HAVE TO UP TO THE
COMPLETE RECTORY OF THESE
BUDGET- ADDITIONAL DISAPPOINTED
SEE THAT. YOU SEE SAY POP
PROGRAM LOCKED OUT OF THE
JANUARY BUDGET. K. POP OF THE
CRITICAL REFER FIRST YOU TO
TURN OF OCT BECAUSE THE EQUITY.
AND IT IS VITALLY IMPORTANT
THAN EVER TELL YOUR PROPERTY.
WILL MISTY LET'S SAY TO HELP
ALL OUR ASK A TWENTY MILE
DOLLAR. IN PAPER TO HELP THE
SUPPORT THE PROGRAM. FINALLY
UBS JOIN STUDENTS ALL SEGMENTS
CALM I JUST. AND HOW GRANT. TO
COVER HER ACOSTA. FOR
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS. BUT A
PANDEMIC DEVASTATING ECONOMIC
IMPACT ON STUDENTS THEIR
FAMILIES THIS IS A CRITICAL
MEASURE. TO TAKE NOW MORE THAN
EVER THANK YOU. NINE FIFTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS ASHLEY
BURCH AND I WORK WITH WHAT YOU
THOUGHT SAN DIEGO CITY COLLEGE
AND BUT YOU THEIR GROWTH IS
LIKELY AS OTHER STUDENTS TO
EXPERIENCE BASIC NEEDS
INSECURITY AND WHILE I'M
APPRECIATIVE OF THE GOVERNOR'S.
INCLUDING FUNDING AND HAVE
PROPOSAL TO ADDRESS THE BASIC
NEEDS I COMMUNITY COLLEGES I AM
HERE TO REQUEST THAT A PORTION
OF THESE FUNDS BE DESIGNATED AS
I'M GOING RATHER THAN A ONE
TIME PURPOSE AS WE KNOW THAT
MEETING THE STUDENTS BASIC
NEEDS TO HELP THEM ACHIEVE
THEIR EDUCATIONAL GOALS. THANK
YOU. NINE ONE TWENTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING ASSEMBLYMEMBERS MY
NAME IS STEPHANIE ROB AND I
WORK WITH THOUSANDS OF STUDENTS
EXPERIENCING BASIC NEEDS
INSECURITY AT ALLAN HANCOCK
COLLEGE IN SANTA MARIA. WELL IN
THE PROJECT MILD MILD I'M
APPRECIATIVE THAT THE GOVERNOR
INCLUDED FUNDING IN HIS
PROPOSAL TO ADDRESS STUDENT
BASIC NEEDS A COMMUNITY
COLLEGES I WOULD LIKE TO
REQUEST THAT A PORTION OF THE
FUND BE DESIGNATED AS ONGOING
RATHER THAN ONE TIME FUNDING
THANK YOU. NINE ONE SEVENTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING MISTER
CHERRY MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY
TSHOMBE HALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
FACULTY ASSOCIATION. YES THEY
BELIEVE THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
BUDGET IS A GOOD STARTING POINT
AND IT IS UP TO AT THE END THE
TRUSTEES ADMINISTRATION
STUDENTS. THEIR BARGAINING
UNITS TO MOVE THIS FORWARD AND
TO MAKE A COMPELLING CASE FOR
THE ADDITIONAL RESOURCES ARE
SICKENING. UP TO ADD TO MAKE
WISE DECISIONS WITH THE
RESOURCES WE RECEIVE FROM THE
STATE CLINTON THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL INCLUDE FIFTEEN
MILLION PER STUDENT MENTAL
HEALTH AND TECHNOLOGY NEEDS. IT
IS CLEAR FROM THE DATA AND THE
LIVED EXPERIENCES OF OUR
FACULTY THAT THE MOST EFFECTIVE
MECHANISM FOR INCREASING THE
AVAILABILITY QUALITY CADET
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES. TO
ENGAGE MORE FULL TIME TENURE
TRACK COUNSELING FACULTY WE
URGE YOU TO DIRECTLY IMPLEMENT
EDUCATION TACKED ON THAT
REALITY. WHAT A GOOD START THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL IS NOT
PETITIONS TO AFFECTIVELY
ADDRESS THE MANY CHALLENGES WE
FACE. YES THEY ASK THAT YOU
JOIN US IN ADVOCATING FOR THE
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES THAT WOULD
ENABLE US TO MARKETING. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU FOR.
NINE ONE FORTY YOUR LINE OPEN
GO AHEAD- HELLO MY NAME THE
NAKED CARROT AND I AM COMMUNITY
COLLEGE GRADUATE I'VE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK AT GOBLINS
JOINT COMMITTEE COLLEGE FOR THE
LAST FIFTEEN YEARS SERVING
UNDERREPRESENTED STUDENTS
CURRENTLY ARE THIRD AT THE COW
WORK THE PROVIDER AND I ALSO
MANAGE OUR FRESH EXACT PROGRAM
FOOD PANTRY AND ARE HOMELESS
AND HOUSING INSECURE PROGRAM.
I'M EXCITED AND GRATEFUL FOR
THE GOVERNOR O INCLUSION OF
FUNDING FOR STUDENT BASIC NEEDS
AND THE BUDGET HOWEVER I'M
REQUESTING THAT A PORTION OF
THE FUNDS TO BE DESIGNATED AS
ONGOING RATHER THAN ONE TIME
FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGES THIS IS
CRITICAL TO ENSURE ONGOING
DEDICATED FUNDING TO SUPPORT
OUR MOST VULNERABLE STUDENTS
WITHOUT. INTERRUPTION THANK YOU.
LINE ONE SIXTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS CHRISTINA CALDERON AND
I'M THE DIRECTOR OF SPECIAL
PROGRAMS AND SERVICES THAT ARE
SYDNEY COLLEGE I'M HAPPY WITH
INSURING THE BEAT MOST OF OUR
STUDENTS AT PARK NICOLLET YOUR
MAT AND IT CAN BE EXTREMELY
DIFFICULT WITHOUT ABLE COULD
YOU COME HERE TO YEAR. I AM
VERY APPRECIATIVE OF THE ONE
TIME FUNDING AVAILABLE ON THE
BUDGET BUT I AM ASKING THAT A
PORTION OF THESE FUNDS BE MVED
WHEN ONGOING BASIS. SO THAT WE
CAN ADDRESS THE BASIC NEEDS OF
OUR STUDENTS CONSISTENTLY. FROM
YEAR TO YEAR THANK YOU. AND ONE
TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
MY NAME IS TONY COLLINS ON WITH
LOS ANGELES SOUTHWEST COLLEGE
IN SOUTH LOS ANGELES I'M A PART
OF THE GATEWAY HOUSING PROGRAM
THAT WE HAVE ON CAMPUS. I'M
VERY APPRECIATIVE OF THE
GOVERNOR- INCLUSION IN FUNDING
FOR BASIC STUDENT NEEDS HOWEVER
I AM REQUESTING THAT A PORTION
OF THE FUNDS BE DESIGNATED AS
ONGOING RATHER THAN ONE TIME
FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGES SO THAT
WE CAN EXTRAPOLATE INTO STAYING
OUR RELATIONSHIP WITH OUR
STUDENTS. AND ALL THEIR
INSECURITIES THANK YOU. NINE
ONE FIFTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MY
NAME IS COMPENSATION ON THE
NORTHERN VICE PRESIDENT OF U.
A. W. TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY FIVE.
I'M COMMENTING TODAY ON BEHALF
OF YOUR W. TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY
FIVE REPRESENTING OVER NINETEEN
THOUSAND ACADEMIC STUDENT
EMPLOYEES AND YOUR W. FIFTY
EIGHT TEN REPRESENTING OVER
TWELVE THOUSAND POSTDOCS AND
ACADEMIC RESEARCHERS AT UC.
SOME SIX STATES SUPPORT FOR THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA'S
BUDGET IS VITAL FOR
STRENGTHENING THE UNIVERSITY'S
RESEARCH MISSION. CONTINUING TO
DELIVER HIGH QUALITY OF
EDUCATION CALIFORNIA STUDENTS.
AND LIVING ON THE UNIVERSITY'S
EQUITY GOALS. OUR MEMBERS ARE
BETTER ABLE TO PERFORM THE
UNIVERSITY'S RESEARCH AND
EDUCATION MISSIONS WITH
INCREASED COMPENSATION
AFFORDABLE HEALTHCARE ACCESS
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES AND
OTHER PROGRAMS THAT BENEFIT.
UNDERSERVED AND
UNDERREPRESENTED COMMUNITIES
RECENT STUDIES HAVE ALSO SHOWN
THAT EVERY DOLLAR INVESTED IN
YOU SEE TRANSLATES TWENTY ONE
DOLLARS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ECONOMY. TEN DOLLARS NO WORKER
INCOME THIS IS OFTEN
INDEFINITELY CALIFORNIA'S
RECOVERY FROM PANDEMIC. YOU W.
TWENTY SIXTY FIVE AND FIFTY
CENTS THE PROPOSAL RESTORATION
OF BASE BUDGET CUTS AS WELL THE
EXTENSION OF FUNDING FOR YOU
OTHER BUDGET PRIORITIES THANK
YOU. NINE EIGHTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON STEPHANIE
GOLDMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
FACULTY ASSOCIATION. DEFERRALS
WHILE PROVIDING FOR BASIC NEEDS
QUITE A PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT HOWEVER WE'RE
DEEPLY CONCERNED ABOUT PROPOSED
COLETTE BELIEVE IT SHOULD BE
MATCHED THE THREE POINT EIGHT
POINT 4% KATE FALL COLOR.
FURTHERMORE THE GOAL SHOULD NOT
BE CONTINGENT ON THE CREATION
OR IMPLEMENTATION OF QUALITY
PROGRAM AS THE AS THAT
UNDERMINES THE PURPOSE OF THE
CALL I WHICH IS MAINTAIN
PURCHASING POWER. WE ALSO ASK
THAT JUST FOR THIS YEAR SHOULD
BE ROAMING GROWTH FUNDING TO A
COLLECTIVE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
AREN'T GROWING BECAUSE OF THE
HEALTH CRISIS. THIS WOULD PUT
OUR INSTITUTIONS IN A BETTER
POSITION ONCE A ROMAN RETURNS.
FINALLY WE SUPPORT ADDITIONAL
FINANCIAL GRANTS SPECIFICALLY
FOR THE LPS STUDENTS. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU
THROUGHOUT THE BUDGET CYCLE
THANK YOU. NINE ONE TWENTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS MY NAME IS
SUSAN ROBERTS AND I WORK IN THE
PAST TWO YEARS PROGRAM AT THE
COLLEGE. DIDN'T THE SACRAMENT
FOSTER CARE TWICE AS LIKELY AS
OTHER STUDENTS TO EXPERIENCE
BASIC NEEDS AND SECURITY I
THINK GROUP OF THIS ON A DAILY
BASIS I TALK WITH STUDENTS WHO
ARE WITHOUT FOOD MEDICAL CARE
AND SOME ARE ALSO EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS. WHEN THEIR BASIC
NEEDS AREN'T BEING MET STUDENTS
ARE UNDERSTANDABLY NOT ABLE TO
DRIVE TO BE SUCCESSFUL IN
COLLEGE I AM VERY APPRECIATIVE
THAT THE GOVERNOR INCLUDED
FUNDING AND IT PROPOSAL TO
ADDRESS STUDENT BASIC NEEDS
THAT COMMUNITY COLLEGES. BUT I
AM HERE TO ALSO REQUEST THAT A
PORTION OF THESE FUNDS BE
DESIGNATED AS ONGOING RATHER
THAN ONE TIME TO BETTER ADDRESS
STUDENT NEEDS AND TO HELP THEM
ACHIEVE THEIR GOAL OF. HIGHER
EDUCATION THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. ONE ONE FORTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HM MCCARTY AND- SACRAMENTO
AMERICANS DIDN'T CHECK A
COLLEGE I WANT TO EXPRESS MY
SUPPORT FOR PLUTONIC CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM AND
APPRECIATION FOR MERGING TO
FINANCIAL AID GRANTS PROTECTION
IN OUR AREA BERMAN STRATEGY
YOU'RE A TEXTBOOK COSTS
PROBABLY TECHNOLOGY REQUIRED
COMPLETION OF THE BOBSLED
ALLOCATED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET ALL OF THESE ARE
CRITICAL PRIORITIES FOR
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS. ADDITIONALLY
STUDENTS WOULD LIKE TO KEEP
BASICALLY IT'S. PROBABLY BECOME
AN ONGOING INVESTMENT. IN AN
ONGOING. AND BEST IF YOU'RE
GRANT TO THAT COST OF THE-
ACCOUNTABLE. NOT JUST A JEWISH
AND- FINALLY. SIXTY THREE
REVENUE SHOULD BE USED TO FIND
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES FOR
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME THIS EVENING AND I'VE GOT
A GREAT WEEK. NINE ONE
SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE ONE
SEVENTEEN YOU MAY BE ON MUTE
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO YES YOU'RE ON. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN PARTY MY
NAME IS SHANNON NINE ONE THE
CITY COLLEGE I WANT TO EXPRESS
MY SUPPORT FOR THE FAMILY
BUDGET FUNDS TO BE ALLOCATED
TOWARDS EDUCATION FINANCE AND
SUPPORT BASICALLY CAL GRANT
ACCORDING TO THE PROPOSITION
THIRTY SIXTY THREE SEVENTY TWO
FUND MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
EVEN AMONG STUDENTS NOW YOU
LOOK FOR THE PANDEMIC BASIC
NEEDS OF THE CRUCIAL ISSUE
AMONG STUDENTS AND NOW THE
CRISIS THAT THE COUNTRY
BECOMING MORE POINT OF THE
TOPIC CHOI JOKES. NEED A
PORTION OF THE FUNDS THAT.
SUPPORT THE BAKING THROUGH A
LONG TERM OPPOSED TO ONE TIME.
THANK YOU. LINE ONE A ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
MY NAME IS ANNA BREAKING AND I
AM A LONG BEACH COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENT AND LIKE MANY
OF THE PREVIOUS CALLERS I
IMPLORE CONSISTENT FUNDING TO
BE DEDICATED TO CAL GRANT
REFORM AND ONGOING BASIC NEEDS
SUPPORT ESPECIALLY TOWARD
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES AS A
STUDENT BUT STRUGGLES WITH
MENTAL HEALTH I KNOW INTIMATELY
HOW INTERNET INTERTEK ROLLED
THE SERVICES ARE. AND WOULD
REALLY APPRECIATE ANY FUNDS
BEING DEDICATED TOWARDS THEM
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME.
NINE ONE THIRTY FOUR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS MONICA
WE START I AM THAT YOU CAN'T
THANK FOLKS COUNTERPART NAKAL
COLLEGE AND I WANTED TO THANK
EVERYONE THAT WAS A THINKING
CRITICALLY OR QUESTIONS AND FOR
YOUR TIME I APPRECIATE THAT
FUNDING THAT'S ALLOCATED FOR
BASIC NEEDS- SO APPRECIATIVE OF
THAT EFFORT BECAUSE THE
STUDENTS THAT CURRENTLY SERVES-
HAVE HOUSING SECURITIES
INCLUDING SECURITIES. SO I'M
REQUESTING THAT A PORTION OF
THESE FUNDS BE DETONATED AT THE
ONGOING EFFORT RATHER THAN A
ONE TIME COMMUNITY. COLLEGE
CONTRIBUTION THANK YOU. MINE
ONCE ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
THANK YOU FOR YOUR EFFORTS AND
SERVING AS THE FACE OF
CALIFORNIA EDUCATIONAL LEADERS
MY NAME IS MIKE TANGLE MISSED
AN EDUCATOR AT AMERICAN RIVER
COLLEGE SACRAMENTO SERVING WITH
THE OPENNESS CARE NEXT UP SAP
ISTER OF CURRENT AND FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH WHO ARE TWICE AS
LIKELY. AS OTHER STUDENTS TO
EXPERIENCE BASIC NEEDS
INSECURITY MENTAL HEALTH
DEPRESSION. AND ARE LIKELY TO
FACE MORE PERSONALIZED HURDLES
I PURCHASED. I'M APPRECIATIVE
THAT THE GOVERNOR INCLUDED
FUNDING THIS PROPOSAL TO
ADDRESS STUDENT BASIC NEEDS AT
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE LEVEL.
BUT ON BEHALF OF SUPPORTING
STRUGGLING STUDENTS AT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE I AM HERE TO
REQUESTED A PORTION OF THESE
FUNDS BE DESIGNATED AS ONGOING.
RATHER THAN ONE TIME THANK YOU.
NINE FIFTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING CARE MAN MCCARTY AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS DR
KENTE JOHNSON DIRECTOR OF
SPECIAL PROGRAMS THAT WORK WITH
INTERFERENCE IN BANK NEEDS
INSECURITY AT COLLEGE OF THE
REDWOODS LEADING THE GROWTH
PROGRAM. WHILE I'M APPRECIATIVE
THAT THE GOVERNOR INCLUDED
FUNDING IN HIS PROPOSAL TO
ADDRESS STUDENT BASIC NEEDS
THAT COMMUNITY COLLEGES I'M
HERE TO REQUEST THAT A PORTION
OF THESE FUNDS BE DESIGNATED AS
ONGOING RATHER THAN. ONE TIME.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME.
NINE ONE SEVENTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING CARE MCCARTY AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
CRYSTAL AND I AM A STUDENT AT
THE END THAT COMMUNITY COLLEGE
I'D LIKE TO ADDRESS THE
DECREASE AND YOU DON'T
REGISTRATION AND THE CCP FROM
FROM THE PERSPECTIVE OF A
STUDENT. STUDENTS FEEL THAT THE
EDUCATION IS BEING UNDERMINED
THROUGH THE CURRENT DAPTATION
OF OUR EDUCATION SYSTEM TEST
ONLY ONLINE COURSES DURING THE
CODE NINETEEN PANDEMIC. AND
THAT'S LEARNING ENVIRONMENT
STUDENTS ARE MORE UNMOTIVATED
ASSEMBLY ARE JUST UNABLE TO
FOCUS IN THE SAME WAY THEY
WOULD IF THEY WERE ATTENDING
CLASSES IN PERSON. WITH IMPACT
BANKING CLASSES STUDENTS WERE
ABLE TO FULLY IMMERSE
THEMSELVES INTO THEIR
EDUCATION. BUSINESS NOW WHEN
STUDENTS ARE NOT ONLY ARE
HAVING MORE DIFFICULTY-
FOCUSING ON THEIR STUDIES BUT
HAVE TO DEAL WITH THEIR
FINANCIAL HARDSHIP CAUSED BY
THE INCREASED UNEMPLOYMENT RATE
DUE TO THE PANDEMIC I THINK
THAT IF WE CAN USE FINANCIAL
AID READY RESOURCES AND
PROGRAMS TO INCENTIVIZE AND
ENCOURAGE STUDENTS TO CONTINUE
TO PURSUE A HIGHER EDUCATION.
MORE STUDENTS WILL RETURN TO
THE CCT PROFOUND MANY OF THE
STUDENTS IN THE C. 50% LIKE
MYSELF ARE SELF SUPPORTING A
MAJOR CONCERN I HAVE IS FOR
HOUSING AT THE COST OF LIVING
IN CALIFORNIA IS
DISPROPORTIONATE TO OUR STATE'S
CURRENT MINIMUM WAGE. I MYSELF
MAKE ABOVE MINIMUM WAGE AT THE
RATE OF EIGHTEEN DOLLARS AN
HOUR AND EVEN I AM UNABLE TO
AFFORD A ONE BEDROOM APARTMENT
I. INDIA ON MY OWN. I HAVE NO
CHOICE BUT TO LIVE IN A SHARED
HOUSEHOLD AND THEY'LL ONLY LET
PAYCHECK TO PAYCHECK I HEAR
THIS BECAUSE MANY STUDENTS ARE
SELF SUPPORTING. ARE ONLY
MAKING AS MUCH AS MINIMUM WAGE
AND THAT DUE TO THEIR CURRENT
LEVEL OF EDUCATION WHICH SEEMS
THERE FUNDS AS- AN ADDITION TO
IT BEING THERE- BASIC NEEDS.
NOW ALTHOUGH I SUPPORT MYSELF
FOR EVEN. AND I'M CLEAN AS AN-
AND THE STATE OF. I STILL MEET.
CERTAIN CRITERIA TO BEGIN AS IN
THE PEN AND THE FIVE THAT APPLE.
IN THE MAIL AND HAVE IT ARE OF
THE IT. IS ACTIVE AND YOU COME
UP. IT AS AN- IS THAT TWENTY
FOUR YEAR OLD AGE. ANOTHER OF I
AM OF THE PATH THAT. THAT
APPLICATION THE I WOULD LIKE TO
OUT IS THAT. STUDENTS ACTUALLY
REQUIRED TO BE FULL TIME IN
ORDER TO QUALIFY FOR FINANCIAL
AID. NOW SOMEONE IS A FULL TIME
STUDENT AT THE BARE MINIMUM OF
TWELVE UNITS. ONE UNIT
REPRESENTING AN HOUR OF CLASS
TIME. AND ARE EXPECTED TO HAVE
AN ADDITIONAL TWO TO THREE
HOURS OF STUDY TIME PER UNIT
OUTSIDE OF ARE ALREADY EXPECTED
CLASS TIME. AVERAGES YOU THIRTY
SIX TO FORTY EIGHT HOURS
DEDICATED TO SCHOOLWORK FOR A
WEEK. THANKS ARE GOING TO
SCHOOL FULL TIME AT A MINIMUM
OF THIRTY SIX HOURS A WEEK.
GETTING THE FOR RECOMMENDED
EIGHT HOURS OF SLEEP PER NIGHT.
AND WORKING FOR CRYING OUT
FORTY HOURS PER WEEK WE ARE
ONLY LEFT WITH THIRTY SIX HOURS
OR LESS A THREE TIME IN THE
WEEK. IF FACT. LEADING US TO
QUESTION IF THAT LEFT OVER TIME
IS SUFFICIENT ENOUGH DRAFT AND
MAINTAIN OUR MENTAL AND
PHYSICAL HEALTH. IF THE PATIENT
IS NOT REPRESENTATIVE OF A
HEALTHY WORK SCHOOL AND SOCIAL
LIFE BALANCE. THIS IS A PROBLEM
THAT WILL SURPASS AND. CONTINUE
AFTER WE RETURNED. EVEN WHAT IT
CONSIDERED THE NEW NEW ACT THE
PANDA ITSELF. I GOING FUNDING
IN TO FIND AS THE PROGRAM LIKE
HOUSING AND OTHER NEEDS WELL
GET AT HIGH AND THE OPPORTUNITY
TO BE SUCCESSFUL IN OUR OUR ADS
HIGHER EDUCATION WITHOUT
UNDERMINING OUR PHYSICAL MENTAL
HEALTH. THAT IS ALREADY
DEPLETING FUTURE THE CURRENT
PANDEMIC WE ARE EXPERIENCING
THANK YOU. NINE EIGHTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE EIGHTY ONE YOU MAY BE ON
MUTE PLEASE GO AHEAD. BRING ON
THE LINE THIRTY FIVE LINE
THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO CAN YOU
HEAR ME. YES WE CAN. GOOD
EVENING ARCHER MCCARTY AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
LONGER AND I SERVE AS THE VICE
PRESIDENT LEGISLATIVE JERRY FOR
THE TOP ONE STATE TO THE
LOCATION WELL WE ARE THANKFUL
FOR GOVERNOR DO SOME QUICK
PROPOSAL IF YOU STAND UNITED IN
OUR BELIEF THAT ADDITIONAL
FUNDING IS NECESSARY SO WE CAN
FULLY FUND AND CONTINUE
PROGRESS BY GRADUATION. TWENTY
TWENTY TWO AS WELL AS ENSURE A
FULL RESTORATION OF THE TWO
HUNDRED NINETY NINE MILLION
DOLLARS CUP LAST YEAR THEREFORE
WE ASK THE STATE LEGISLATURE TO
INCREASE THE REOCCURRING FUND
AUGMENTATION BECAUSE THE END
YOU BY THREE HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS I FOR ONE TIME
FUNDS WERE CALLING THE
LEGISLATURE TO INCREASE THAT
AMOUNT BY FIVE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY ONE MILLION DOLLARS.
THIS INVESTMENT WILL YIELD HIGH
RETURNS AS THE WOODEN SURE THAT
THE P. IF YOU IS ABLE TO
PROVIDE INCOMPLETE MANY OF OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS
RESULTING IN JOBS REPORT
INVESTMENT BY THE STATE
GOVERNMENT SEE IF YOU ARE A
DIRECT INVESTMENT IN
CALIFORNIA'S FUTURE WORKFORCE
AND INDEED. ARE- STUDENTS WERE
ALSO HAPPY TO SEE THE THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN ON GOING ON.
OUT TO SUPPORT BASED WILL. WERE
INCLUDED IN GOVERNOR. HELLO AND
WE HOPE THAT THE STATE LED.
ADOPT OR- THE THIS ALLOCATE.
LASTLY ABOUT TO AND THE THAT
THE IF YOU. BELIEVE THAT CAL
FINANCIAL AID SYSTEM THAT
COVERS FULL COST OF ATTENDANCE
NOT GOOD TO. FEES THAT AND I
WILL THAT MODERNIZE THE CAR. IS
STUFF AND RIGHT DIRECTION.
THANK YOU FOR TALKING. MY
NINETY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
THIS IS THEIR DIRECTION THAT'S
WHICH RECALLS WITH A CALIFORNIA
WE APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S
RECALLS PROJECT BUT WE WOULD
ENCOURAGE PREDICT RESULTS IN A
PARK DISTRICTS TO KEEP IN TOUCH
INCLUDING COST. ENGINE CAPACITY
FOR THE STUDENTS AND COMMUTERS
ALSO ASKED FOR MAXIMUM
FLEXIBILITY AND LOCAL CONTROL
OVER FUNDS DESIGNATED
OPERATIONAL NEEDS CONSTRUED
SUPPORT. FINALLY WE WOULD ASK
YOU TO CONSIDER AN EVALUATION
AND ANALYSIS OF THE INTERPLAY
BETWEEN STATE AND FEDERAL
SUPPORT TO ENSURE THAT WE'RE
NOT DUPLICATING EFFORTS IN SOME
AREAS WILL BE THE HEART. OF
AFFORDABLE YET YOU'RE A LOT OF
CHALLENGES. WHICH SO THANK YOU.
NINE FORTY EIGHT YOUR IS OPEN
GO AHEAD. NINE FORTY EIGHT YOU
MAY BE ON MUTE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS WITH WINTER
AND I WORK FOR WHICH FOSTER AND
HOMELESS YOUTH OVER THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE. I APPRECIATE
THAT THE GOVERNOR INCLUDES
FUNDING IN HIS PROPOSAL TO
ADDRESS STUDENT BASIC NEEDS AT
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. AND I'M
HERE TO REQUESTED A PORTION OF
THESE FUNDS BE DESIGNATED
ONGOING RATHER THAN ONE TIME.
WE I WAS A COMMUNITY COLLEGE
HAD SEEING. A VAST INCREASE IN
HOUSING. AND HOMELESSNESS- IN
NEWS RESEARCH AND. WE
DEFINITELY WOULD LIKE TO SEE
THE FUNDING BE ONGOING RATHER
THAN ONE TIME THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. NINE ONE THIRTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI ALL HI MY NAME IS JESSICA
AND I'M CURRENTLY A SECOND YEAR
STUDENT LONG BEACH CITY
COLLEGE- I'D LIKE TO EXPRESS
THAT I WOULD LIKE HIS FAMILY
BUDGET FINDS HERE TO BE
EDUCATION FINANCE IN SUPPORT OF
BASIC NEEDS CAL GRANT REFORMING
USING PROPOSITION. SIXTY THREE
RUN YOU TWO ONE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES AS SOMEONE WHO
STRUGGLES WITH SEVERAL MENTAL
DISORDERS AND DEAL WITH
HOUSEHOLDS- TOXICITY DAILY DUE
TO THE PANDEMIC. INCREDIBLY
DIFFICULT TO REACH OUT TO
OTHERS FOR HELP SHINING OR FEAR
OR MENTAL HEALTH COLLIDING WITH
HER SCHOOL WORK IS SPECIAL WE
HAVE NO CHOICE BUT TO PERTAIN
TO ARE WORKING QUITE HOME- IT
WOULD BE BACKING GREATLY
APPRECIATED YES- THIS FUNDING
BECOMES ONGOING DEDICATED TO
GIVING TO PROGRAMS I CAN OFFER
SUCH EMOTIONAL SUPPORT FOR
STUDENTS WERE DEALING WITH
THINGS LIKE DEPRESSION ANXIETY.
OR EVEN ADHD AND XCERRA THAT'S
MENTAL HEALTH IS CONSIDERED THE
FOUNDATION NO ALL STAR THE
FOUNDATIONS THAT DEALING WITH
ALL ASPECTS OF LIFE- EMOTIONAL
FACTORS LIKE SCHOOL MOTIVATION
SOCIAL INTERACTIONS ARE
INCLUDED IN THAT MISSION AND
WITHOUT IT- INCREDIBLY
DETRIMENTAL TO HUMAN HEALTH ANDLIMIT THE MENTALLY PHYSICALLY.
AND ACADEMICALLY THANK YOU.
NINE TWENTY SEVEN YOUR IS OPEN.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY IS JASIM
IN THE I'M A NOT FOR ON THE
CALL I WANTED MY SUPPORT FOR A
FULLY FUNDED COLLEGE SYSTEM
ENROLLMENT COMMUNITY COLLEGES
FELL BY 10% LAST FALL IN THE
STUDENT TO RECEIVE FINANCIAL
AID 70% LOST SOME OR ALL OF
THEIR INCOME. SO MANY STUDENTS
STRUGGLED WITH BASIC NEED PRIOR
TO THE PANDEMIC AND MANY MORE
ARE NOW SUFFERING IT IS
IMPORTANT TO ALLOCATE
PROPOSITION SIXTY THREE REVENUE
TO FUND MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
WITHIN THE COMMUNICATIVE CENTER
HELPS STUDENTS FURTHER THEIR
EDUCATION CARE. THANK YOU. NINE
ONE THIRTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME'S MELISSA MEADOWS I MANAGE
THE HOMELESS AND HOUSING AND
SECURITY PROGRAM AT PARKS TO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE I AM
APPRECIATIVE THE GOVERNOR'S
INCLUSION OF FUNDING FOR BASIC
NEEDS FOR STUDENTS IN THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE BUDGET EVERY
QUESTION A PORTION OF THESE
FUNDS BE DESIGNATED AS ONGOING
RATHER THAN ONE TIME. THANK YOU.
MINE ONE SIXTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GREETINGS
FROM THE CARTY AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS CODY WHAT
SHOULD YOU DO UNITS TO CERTAIN
THAT MOUNT SAN ANTONIO COLLEGE
IN WALNUT CALIFORNIA AND I HAVE
THE HONOR TO WORK WITH OUR
COLLEGES DEDICATED TEAM OF
STAFF AND FACULTY. SUPPORT THE
MANY MANY STUDENTS STRUGGLING
WITH BASIC NEEDS INSECURITY AND
THEY STRIVE TO COMPLETE THEIR
COLLEGE EDUCATION. AS THIS IS A
CRITIC STUDENT EQUITY ISSUE I
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S
SUPPORT FOR ONE TIME STUDENT
BASIC NEEDS FUNDING IN THE
BUDGET PROPOSAL. HOWEVER IN
ORDER TO TRULY INCREASE OUR
CAPACITY TO BUILD ON THE
EXISTING BASIC NEEDS WORK ON
ALL OUR COLLEGES. IT IS THE
CENTRAL TO ALSO GET THE DATE
ONGOING FUNDING FOR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. SO THAT WE CAN
PROVIDE YOU STAINED EQUITY
BASED SERVICES AND RESOURCES TO
PROVIDE OUR STUDENTS A
TRANSFORMATIVE EDUCATIONAL
EXPERIENCE. THANKS FOR YOUR
TIME. NINE ONE SEVENTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING JOSHUA
HAGEN ON BEHALF OF THE CAMPAIGN
FOR COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY WE
WOULD LIKE TO EXTEND OUR
GRATITUDE TO GOVERNMENT KNEW
SOME FOR HIS STRONG HIGHER
EDUCATION BUDGET AMID THE
FISCAL PRESSURES OF PANDEMIC
OUR HIGHER EDUCATION
INSTITUTIONS HAVE PROVEN
THEMSELVES TO BE AN INVALUABLE
RESOURCE FOR PUBLIC HEALTH AND
ECONOMIC RECOVERY OUR STATE.
AND WE ARE GLAD TO SEE
MEANINGFUL INVESTMENTS IN THESE
INSTITUTIONS CONTINUE WE URGE
THE LEGISLATURE TO SUPPORT
STABLE BASE FUNDING FOR OUR
HIGHER EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS
AND TO PRIORITIZE RACIAL EQUITY
IN THESE INVESTMENTS THE
PANDEMIC EXPOSED IN FURTHER
EXACERBATED RACIAL INEQUITIES
THAT HAVE ALWAYS EXISTED
THEREFORE WE NEED TO BE EVEN
MORE BOLD CONSENT OUR POLICIES
AND RACIAL EQUITY. IN
PARTICULAR EFFORT TO MODERNIZE
FINANCIAL AID TO TARGET OUR
MOST VULNERABLE STUDENTS AND
INVESTMENT IN EMERGENCY AID FOR
STUDENTS WHO HAVE HAD THEIR
EDUCATION DISRUPTED BY THE CAN
DOWN NECK MUST BE SUPPORTED.
FINALLY WE URGE THE LEGISLATURE
TO STREAM IT TO EXPLORE
STREAMLINING AND SIMPLIFICATION
OF THE TRANSFER PROCESS
GOVERNOR NUISANCE BUDGET
PROPOSES A DEAL WITH MISSION
PATHWAY BASED ON THE FRAMEWORK
FOR THE ASSOCIATE DEGREE FOR
TRANSFER OF THE ADT THE ADT HAS
PROVEN ITSELF TO BE AN
INVALUABLE RESOURCE AND
PROVIDING STUDENTS THE TIME THE
PAST TRANSPORT AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING TOGETHER TO
SIMPLIFY ACCESS FOR STUDENTS
AND. TO STRENGTHEN THE AT T.
THANK YOU. NINE ONE. FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN GO AHEAD. MICHAEL
YOUNG WITH THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS-
REPRESENTING OVER HALF OF THE
BACK OF A COMMUNITY COLLEGE
THAT COMES AS A RELIEF TO THE
DEFERRAL WE APPRECIATE THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO PAY DOWN
BERKELEY 70% OF THE EXISTING
DEFERRALS FROM LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET HOWEVER WE ARE SWITCHED
LATER TO USE A ONE TIME MONEY
TO A POLITICAL DIFFERENCE- ALSO
SIMILARLY. SIMILARLY TO KEEP%
CLOSE WITH A CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM
RECEIVED A CALL LAST YEAR- WE
REQUEST THAT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEM. RECEIVE THAT
THREE POINT EIGHT FOUR ADJUSTED
AMOUNT- TO THE BUDGET CYCLE AND
THE CABLE COUNTERPART-
ADDITIONALLY HI IN THE COOLER
TO BE CONTINGENT ON THE
CREATION OF OR INCLINATION-
POLICY PROGRAMS IS PROBLEMATIC
AND WE CAN GO CONTINGENCIES.
FASTER CLOACAL IS REALLY JUST
IT SHOULD BE A MEANS OF-
KEEPING THEM WHOLE. AS WE GO
FORWARD. LET'S LEAVE NOT AS
TODAY HEARING. I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE ALL CONTINUE
TO THE ON TREND. AND GOING TO
THE COUNTY COLLEGE- EVERY DAHLE
DAM EVERY DAY AND YOU NEED WILL.
EVERY DOLLAR IN HOW. IS GOING
HAVE TO GO FOR. I DID BUDGETARY
CYCLE THAT WE DEAL WITH THE
BUDGETARY REALITIES AND THE
FALLOUT OF THE COOKING NINETEEN
PANDEMIC AND TO CONTINUE TO.
PLAN YOU KNOW LIKE HOW IS THAT
NOT JUST PROVIDE DUPLICATE
PROGRAMS TO THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEM BUT ALSO BE ABLE
TO MEET. ITS ONGOING GOALS- IT
MAGIC THE INEFFICIENT BUT
IRRESPONSIBLE USE CALIFORNIA
FUNDING SO- WE URGE THEIR
LEGISLATION TO CONFIGURE-
DEFENDING THE COVERAGE. THANK
YOU. NINE FIFTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MMHM
HELLO HM OKAY YES YOUR HONOR-
HI GOOD AFTERNOON GOOD EVENING
ON CHANNEL QUALITY AND
REMEMBERS FINDING OUT ON THE
STREET ASK YOUR COLLEGE
SACRAMENTO- I WOULD LIKE YOU'D
EXPECT NOTHING FOR A FULL
REFUND OF OUTCOME BECAUSE THEY
THINK AND ALSO WOULD LIKE TO
APPRECIATE LIKE ACTION WITHIN
FINANCIAL AID GRANTS. OUR
RETENTION AND ENROLLMENT OF USE
THAT YOU WANT TO PROVIDE A
BUDGET AND- FINANCIAL SUPPORT
FOR THE BASIC NEEDS- YEAH I
THOUGHT SO I I'M HERE JUST. TO
SAY THAT I WOULD LIKE TO SEE.
OUR AT THE ONE TIME AND ALL
LIKE- BECOME THE ONGOING
EMOTIONAL SUPPORT AND ON THE-
UP AND THEN UP AND CAL. CAL
GRANT. REFORM TO ENSURE THAT
TOTAL CALL OF THE CALIBER.
HUNDRED NOT YOU SHOULD BE- I
ALSO LIKE. STATE COUPLE ARE
SHIFT. ON THE. THOUSAND TO
FIFTY. FIFTY FOUR YOU SO MUCH
HAVE A GREAT. MY ONE SEVENTY.
YOUR LINE OPEN PLEASE AHEAD.
HELLO OKAY EIGHT DAVID EIGHT ME-
KEVIN MCCARTY I NON NUMBER MY
NAME IS A VERY MARK COVERS THE
SECOND SUCH THEIR YOU CAN. I'M
A FIRST GENERATION LONG COLLEGE
REYES THE NEW YORK CLASS ARE
HOSTILE. FIRSTLY FOR HELLO LIKE
MY HAVE BEEN AFFECTED BY THE
ONGOING. SORRY I DIDN'T AMONG
MY CAMPUS IS PUTTING OUR HAVE
HEARD STORIES OF THE DAY OKAY
FOR TO ON THE TO HELP THE
FAMILY ACROSS STILL AT THE
MARQUEE DISHES. AND THEREFORE
PUTTING THE MICRO RISK CONTRACT
THE VIRUS I MYSELF MIGHT NOT
HAVE TWENTY BUYERS GAY TRYING
TO UNPLUG DISSIDENTS HAPPEN THE
STATE STOCKS HERE. THE THING-
THERE'S IF YOU CAN CONDITIONS
NOW- THERE'S ALSO THE FOR THE
WE DON'T HAVE A STABLE AND
PERCENT TO SECURE RELIABLE
CONNECTIONS AMONG OTHER ISSUES
MANY ARE IN NEED OF ECONOMIC
ASSISTANCE COLOR REALLY
CONSISTENT AND MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES HOUSING EDUCATIONAL
SYSTEM. SUCH AS THE EXTRACTION
OF DELIVERING MOBILE HOTSPOT
UNLOCKED WHICH DIDN'T NEED TO
ENSURE ACTIVE TO THE HIGHER
EDUCATION I APPRECIATE THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL FOR
THE UC INTEL I THINK IT'S NOT
ENOUGH FOR STUDENTS. THEREFORE
IF YOU'D EXPECT LEGISLATURE TO
CONTINUE ITS LEADERSHIP AND
RESTORING THE ROCKS ON ON IN
POLITICS FOR THE SYSTEM AND
IT'S THAT ATTITUDE THAT HAVE
EXPERIENCED THIS YEAR THE
AUTHOR GETTING STRONGER TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TO TWENTY TWENTY
BUDGET TO BUY TO PASS A FOUR
THANK YOU KIDDING ARE
UNDOCUMENTED POPULATION DURING
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT I OFTENTIMES
DIDN'T TODAY ACROSS ALL THE
PUBLIC INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER
EDUCATION. I THINK PART OF THE
STATE'S FINANCIAL GET CLOSE
CLIMB UP ON THE LEGISLATURE IN
BATON CAL GRANT REFORM TO COVER
THE COST OF ATTENDANCE FOR
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS THANK YOU
FOR TRACK. SO YOU'RE TRYING TO
SPEAKING. GOOD EVENING TERRY
MCCARTY MANY VENDORS MY NAME IS
JEFF CANDELARIA I'M HERE
BECAUSE OF THE SERBIAN STUDENTS
COPPER CALLED. I WANTED MY
SUPPORT FOR POLICE. CALL FELLOW.
BECAUSE COMMUNITY THE CAL.
SYSTEM IN APPRECIATION FOR IN
NUMBER SEE IF I AID GRANTS OR
AND RENEWAL SHARED NEAR TEXAS
BECAUSE- AND REQUIRED OF THE
FAST ABOUT YOU TO MAKE BUT ALL
THESE ARE CRITICAL TO THE
TRIPLE STUDENTS. STUDENTS THAT
WE REPRESENT A LOT OF THE FEES
THAT. GO ALONG WITH KEEPING
STUDENTS IN SCHOOL ESPECIALLY
DURING A PANDEMIC ARE NOT
COVERED AT ALL- BUT WITH CHILD
CARE THINGS LIKE THAT. THINGS
THAT ARE IMPORTANT WHEN
BUILDING BACK BETTER WHAT A LOT
OF PEOPLE ARE TALKING ABOUT I
THINK WE TO REALIZE THAT THE
STUDENT MAYBE NOT A TRADITIONAL
PATH THAT WE NEED TO BUILD BACK
BETTER FOR THE STUDENTS.
FINALLY PROPOSITIONS THREE.
USED POKE. FUN MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICE FOR TRIPLE YOUR- THANK
YOU. OKAY MINE TOO ONE YOUR
LONG IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO YES YOU'RE YOU'RE ON. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON MCCARTY
COMMITTEE MEMBER MY NAME IS
NINE BAKER I'M A STUDENT AT THE
END THE COLLEGE EIGHTY NINE
AMERICA GOVERNMENT POLITICS. I
WANT SHOW MY ON A THE NEED
AMERICANS IS THE COMMUNITY THE
WITH THOMAS IF YOU'RE HELPING
TO FINANCE HEALTH SERVICES NOW
YOU MORE WITH GRANT OF A KINDA
WE NEED MORE ON IN FRONT TO
ADDRESS ISSUES IN A LONG TIME.
SACRAMENTO ME COLLEGES NEED
WITH SUPPORT THAT CAN HELP OUR
STUDENTS YOU'RE TALKING THANK
YOU THAT FOR YOU TIME AND I'LL
AFTER THAT BETTER A LOT THANK
YOU. I MY NAME IS CHRISTINA
COLORS AND I AM CURRENTLY AT
BAKERSFIELD COLLEGE I SPENT MY
CHILDHOOD IN OTHER THE FOSTER
CARE SYSTEM AND DON'T HAVE THE
SAME ACCESS TO OF THAT MANY
OTHER STUDENTS AFTER THE FALL
BACK ON HELLO ARE DURING MY
TIME IN I ASSURE WITH ONLY
HOMELESS BUT HAVE ENOUGH MONEY
FOR FOOD ALSO GETTING DIAPERS
AND PAY FOR MY TO MEDICATION.
TO GET FOOD I WOULD HAVE TO GO
TO FOR THE PANTRIES AND THAT WE
TAKE SEVERAL DAYS TO GET THERE
AS A STUDENT I DON'T THAT
HAVING TO FOR OF UNCLE UNDER
WHEN SHE THAT CAN IN SUPPORT.
STUDENT LIKE ME WHAT AT BASIC
THANK LIKE THIS TAX AND TRACK.
IS NOT THE TO MAKING THAT ALL
STUDENTS HAVE YOU CHANCE TO GO
TO CALL THANK YOU FOR GIVING
THIS TIME TO SPEAK- AND I
GREATLY IT. STUDENTS ARE TWICE
AS LIKELY AS OTHER STUDENTS TO
EXPERIENCE BASIC NEEDS
INSECURITY. I AM APPRECIATIVE
OF MY COLLEAGUES ARE THAT THE
GOVERNOR INCLUDED FUNDING IN
THIS PROPOSAL TO ADDRESS
STUDENT BASIC NEEDS A COMMUNITY
COLLEGES BUT I'M HERE TO
REQUEST. A PORTION OF THESE
FUNDS BE DESIGNATED AS ON GOING
RATHER THAN ONE TIME. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. NINE ONE SEVENTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING EVERYONE MY
NAME IS MICHELLE SAMPSON AND
I'M A SECOND YEAR STUDENT OF
LONG BEACH CITY COLLEGE- AS AN
ADHD STUDENT WHO'S GRATEFUL FOR
THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
OFFERED BY LBCC I'D LIKE TO
REQUEST THAT ASSEMBLY FUN GO
TOWARDS BASIC NEEDS SUPPORT AND
CAL GRANT REFORM- SUPPORTERS
SUCH SERVICES WOULD HELP
STUDENTS LIKE MYSELF FOR
STRIVING TO DO THEIR BEST.
UNDER DIFFICULT CIRCUMSTANCES
THANK YOU SO MUCH YOUR TIME.
NINE ONE EIGHTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING CHAIR MCCARTY AND-
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME'S
BAILEY HENDERSON AND I TEND UC
BERKELEY AS THE STATE
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS DEPUTY
DIRECTOR. I APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEE'S COMMITMENT TO
EXPANDING ACCESS THE UC BY
CRAIG ADMITTANCE GOAL TO CAP.
BUT THIS DOES NOT MEAN THAT THE
MOST UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES
WILL HAVE MORE ACCESS. THAT IS
WHY THE UC STUDENT ASSOCIATION
IS ASKING FOR TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS INVESTMENT INDUSTRY
ACADEMIC PREPARATION AND
EDUCATIONAL PARTNERSHIP WORKDAY
PEP PROGRAM. TO ADDRESS
ADEQUATE ACCESS AND EQUITY GAPS
BASING OUR STUDENTS. GOING BACK
TO A FAMILY MEMBER RAISES
QUESTION ON EQUITY BEST EQUITY
PRACTICES THESE FUNDS WILL GO
DIRECTLY TO UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES WE NEED MORE
RESEARCH RESOURCES TOPIC THAT
SUCCESSFUL APPLICATION PROCESS.
WITHOUT THEM EXPANSION
ADMITTANCE WILL ONLY SERVE
THOSE BUT THE EASY ACCESS TO
EDUCATION THE FIRST PLACE. YOUR
PROP SIXTEEN IS MORE CRUCIAL
THAN EVER THAT ASSEMBLY DO
SOMETHING TO ADDRESS EQUITY
GAPS BETWEEN COMMUNITIES IN
CALIFORNIA. LET'S CREATE
OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL WHAT GOOD
FOR ALL THANK YOU. THERE ARE NO
FURTHER COMMENT IN THE COMMENT
Q. OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
APPRECIATE THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY
WE DON'T HAVE THE TIME TO
RESPOND AND IT WASN'T AGENDAS
HERE BUT- WE HEAR YOU LOUD AND
CLEAR AND- MANY THESE ISSUES
RELATED TO BASIC NEEDS MENTAL
HEALTH SUPPORT- ESPECIALLY FROM
OUR STUDENTS- WILL BE ADDRESSED
IN THE COMING WEEKS AND MONTHS
SO. THANK EVERYBODY FOR
PARTICIPATING AND WITH THAT WE
ARE JOINED.